Hallo, Wolfgang.
Hallo, Stefan.
Du warst in Frankfurt, du hast hier Filme gesehen. Beim hessischen Filmpreis, du bist um eine Sache nicht herum gekommen. Das Stadtbild, wie hat es dir gefallen?
Nun, ich konnte sehen, dass das Stadtbild Richard David Precht widerlegt.
Das ist sehr interessant, denn typischerweise haben wir es mit Wortspendern im Großen und Ganzen zu tun, bei denen ohne Frage recht eindeutig ist, was sie sagen. Zum Beispiel, ich heiße Friedrich Merz und ich bin ein Rassist. So, das wird dann irgendwie verklausuliert, aber wie auch immer. Jetzt hast du gesagt, Richard David Precht wurde widerlegt. Wir haben über Richard David Precht's Buch gesprochen, Angststillstand, mit der großen Fragestellung, was ist denn gerade die Aussage? Plappern wir alle wild durcheinander und vermüllen die Innenstadt, die du also gesehen hast, mit allerlei und jeder lebt sich aus? Oder hast du ganz Frankfurt im Angststillstand gesehen, alle waren leise, niemand hat irgendetwas gesagt?
Erstmals Werbung in diesem Podcast. Wir werden heute unterstützt von Märkte, Mächte, Emissionen zur Lage der Welt mit Adam Two's. So heißt ein Podcast der Heinrich Böll Stiftung. Wir sind ja große Adam Two's Fans und freuen uns deshalb sehr, dass wir Werbung für diesen Podcast machen können. Es gibt schon viele Folgen. Die aktuelle Folge handelt zum einen von den Klimazielen der Chinesen. Was hat China in den nächsten Jahren vor? Welche Ziele sollen erreicht werden? Das stellt Adam Two's vor und diskutiert es mit den Hosts. Und im zweiten Teil geht es dann um den Solarboom. Da wird besonders der Fokus auf Pakistan gelegt. Dort ist nämlich zu beobachten, wie in Windeseile immer mehr Photovoltaik installiert wird und auch die Preise sinken. Und das ist aber auch eine Folge, die uns sehr viel Auskunft gibt darüber, wie wir eigentlich uns im Westen dazu verhalten sollten. Und was auch schon im Westen passiert.
Ja, Adam Toos spricht ja sehr gut Deutsch. Das ist immer gut. Und er hat diesen internationalen Einschlag der Professor aus Amerika. In der Hinsicht hören wir diesen Podcast ja sowieso. Und in diesem Falle Adam Toos ist unser Bekannt wegen den großen Zahlen. Ja. Diesmal beginnt er, also diese zwanzigste Ausgabe, mit einem Verweis auf Chi und wie er sehr kleine Zahlen nennt, mit der Pointe, vielleicht werden hier Erwartungen geschürt und dann bewusst unterlaufen zu werden, um dann irgendwann das große Festival der erreichten Ziele zu machen. Da sieht man schon, China tickt anders. Ich finde es sehr gut, dass uns das jemand erklärt, dass Adam Toos das macht und in unserer Muttersprache sehr gut. Adam Toos, die großen Zahlen, sowieso empfehlenswert. Schaut mal bei uns im Salonarchiv. Ihr findet, glaube ich, zehn oder zwölf Einträge. Ja. Also wir haben Bücher und Texte von ihm besprochen. Wir hoffen natürlich, dass ihr ihn alle kennt und für den Fall, dass ihr ihn nicht kennt, hier die erste Werbung. Wir sagen euch diesen Podcast.
Also Märkte, Mächte, Emissionen zur Lage der Welt mit Adam Toos von der Heinrich Böll Stiftung. Wir sind schon jetzt große Fans. Weder noch, also in Frankfurt passiert ja viel und gerade war ja auch dann die Buchmesse, als auch der hessische Filmpreis verliehen wurde. Insofern habe ich die Stadt sehr bunt erlebt in jeder Hinsicht. Was aber ja eine These in Richard-David-Precht Buch ist, ist, dass sich jetzt die Gesellschaft in den letzten Jahrzehnten so gewandelt hat, dass nun niemand mehr das zurückgezogene Pfeilschen sein will, das nicht auffällt, sondern alle wollen wie Rosenblühen. Alle wollen besonders sein. Und weil jeder glaubt, besonders sein zu müssen, wird der Diskurs immer schwieriger und es wird immer lauter. Das war ja eine große These und der hat sich ja sehr dann auch angelehnt an Reckwitz, an die Gesellschaft der Singularitäten. Und dann ging ich mit einem Bekannten durch Frankfurt am nächsten Tag, nachdem der Preis verliehen wurde, weil ich noch ins Kino wollte und war erstaunt darüber, dass da vor einem Geschäft eine ganz lange Schlange stand und auch noch ein Schild dort war, dass also die Straße, die dazwischen war, freigehalten wird, damit der Autoverkehr noch weiter gehen kann. Und dann ging die Schlange weiter. Was war das für ein Geschäft? Uniqlo. Das ist jetzt neu eröffnet in Frankfurt. Das gibt es schon seit vielen Jahren. Ich glaube Anfang der 2000 hat auch mal Jill Sander so eine Linie für die designt. Denn in gewisser Weise ist das so ein bisschen Streetwear aller Jill Sander, nämlich zurückgenommen nicht auffallen. Man schaut ins Schaufenster und denkt, es ist so eine Mischung aus Zara, C und A, aber eher ganz gedeckte Farben, keine Auffälligkeiten. Es geht nicht darum, eine Rose zu sein. Und wenn man dann ins Stadtbild blickt, dann ist das tatsächlich das, was prägend ist. Da laufen nicht die schrille Figuren herum. Die findet man dann vielleicht am Abend, wenn man auf eine Party im Literaturhaus ist oder auf dem Hessischen Filmpreis. Aber man findet sie nicht auf der Straße. Und wir haben es ja auch schon gesagt, dass es keine wirklich gute Beobachtung von Richard David Precht ist. Es ist nicht so, dass alle Leute verrückt sind, auffallend schrill sind, sondern dass wir eigentlich das sehen, was man ja Normchor getauft hat. Also dass man eigentlich in der Norm bleiben will.
Normchor höre ich gerade zum ersten Mal. Das ist ja perfekt, ist das schon gängige Begriffe?
Ja, das ist seit einigen Jahren immer mal wieder so ein gewisser Modestil. Und das kann man dann bei Uniqlo auch sehr gut sehen, bei diesem japanischen Hersteller. Dass es also da um offenbar sehr praktische, funktionale Mode geht, die einen gewissen schickert, das ist jetzt nicht meine Mode, wirst du dir denken können. Aber da zeigt sich ganz deutlich, dass es nicht eine Mode, mit der man jetzt verrückt irgendwo auffallen kann, sondern es ist eine sehr dezente Mode. Und das ist ja nur ein Punkt, den wir dann an dem Buch kritisiert haben. Precht war ja unglaublich viel in Talkshows zu Gast. Er hat ja auch dann mit Mangold diskutiert, hat dann auch tatsächlich diese These nochmal wiederholt, dass eigentlich ein Shitstorm einem Pokrom gleichkommt. Auch etwas, was wir kritisiert haben. Wir fanden ja nicht das Buch grundsätzlich nur schlecht oder so, aber es sind doch einige Punkte, bei denen man sagt, das ist nicht gut beobachtet, beziehungsweise sehr ungenau oder ist es auch nicht konsistent, wenn man zum einen sagt, die rechts-links-Unterscheidung ist eigentlich nicht mehr das, was man braucht, um die Welt zu sortieren. Und dann geht er aber doch immer dazu über, zu sagen, ja, die Linken, die Linken, die Linken. Also macht er diese Unterscheidung auch. Wer das jetzt noch nachhören will im Salon, ist das möglich. Da diskutieren wir zwei Stunden darüber. Aber es war erstaunlich, wie medial präsent das Buch war, oder?
Also, Precht ist ja jemand, der die Sache sowieso ein bisschen besser durchschaut als andere. Das ist also klar, dass er dann drei Stunden lang bei Matze im Podcast sitzt und zwei Stunden bei, wo war er noch? Ben oder so? Keine Ahnung. Also ist ja überall.
Bei Ben war er nicht, aber bei Meilschberger war er.
Da habe ich ihn auch gesehen. Tilo war er. Ach, bei Tilo, genau. Da war er noch so lange. Also nicht Ben, sondern Tilo. Und dann hast du ja gemeint, er war auch bei der Buchmesse mit Mangold. Das hast du eben schon angesprochen. Ich habe mir das dann auch mal kurz angeschaut. Mangold hat ja auch die Rezension in der Zeit geschrieben. Und da sieht man natürlich, okay, wenn Ijoma Mangold, der sowieso schon Anhänger allein dieser Idee ist, dass wir hier alle nicht mehr sagen dürfen, was wir wollen und so, gleichzeitig aber großes Föter aufführt, ist ja auch absurd mit 600.000 Abonnenten und so. Und in diesem Gespräch behauptet Precht dann, er hätte bislang gute Aufmerksamkeit für das Buch bekommen und kaum Kritik. Und jetzt hat Wolfgang gerade empfohlen, er hört euch doch noch mal den Salon, was ihr nicht kennt. Ich möchte Richard David Precht aufrufen, vielleicht dann auch noch mal Salon zu hören. Wir schicken die Datei auch gerne zu.
Gut.
Bleiben wir aber beim Stadtbild.
Das Stadtbild. Nein, warte, wir lassen uns erstmal kurz feiern. John Philip hat einen Podcast. Er sagt dort Folgendes.
Ich habe wirklich genau einen Podcast, den ich höre, das sind Die Neuen Zwanziger von Wolfgang M. Schmitt und Stefan Schulz. Das sind ja auch dann immerhin irgendwie 5-6 Stunden plus Bonusfolge, nochmal 5-6 Stunden jeden Monat. Damit komme ich durch. Das reicht mir völlig. Ich brauche gerade nichts anderes.
Sehr gut. Vorbildhaft, finde ich.
Schöne Krüße.
Ein ganz braver Podcast-Hörer. Sehr schöne Krüße von uns. Wir möchten den Gruß gerne zurückgeben. Ich möchte sagen, mir reicht ein Podcast nicht, ungefähr 300 und so. Aber High Freaks höre ich auch. Und ich finde, ihr solltet auch High Freaks hören. Also warum nicht? Gut, das Stadtbild.
Das Stadtbild.
Du hast dich ja schon in deinem Transit-Podcast dazu geäußert. Wir versuchen das mal ganz kurz zusammenzufassen. Friedrich Merz spricht da vom Stadtbild. Er redet erst die ganze Zeit davon, dass jetzt mehr abgeschoben wird und sagt aber, dass ich das im Stadtbild noch nicht bemerkbar mache. Bedeutet also, sie werden immer noch, wenn sie durch die Stadt gehen, sehr viele Menschen sehen. Ja, genau. Wen werden sie denn dann sehen? Und dann beginnt ja genau diese Klassifizierung oder Rassifizierung, die dann vorgenommen wird, sobald man sich diese Frage stellt, ja wen sehe ich denn da eigentlich da? Beim hessischen Filmpreis wurde auch ein Film über Hanau ausgezeichnet und dort wurde dann auch gesagt, ja da ist dann jemand, der passt nicht ins Stadtbild und dann geschieht Gewalt daraus. Also das wollte, man muss immer auch diesen Zusammenhang natürlich sehen. Und vor allem ist es ja dann so, dass Merz wieder eine Äußerung gemacht hat, dann um sich zu erklären und zu sagen, ja ich will das gar nicht zurücknehmen, fragen sie mal ihre Töchter. Woraufhin dann ja diese ganzen entsprechenden Reaktionen bei Instagram kamen über generell Gewalt von Männern im öffentlichen Raum gegen Frauen und so weiter. Was dann nochmal dazu geführt hat, dass Merz sich ja nochmal geäußert hat und dann sagte er, er meinte ja damit Kriminelle und soetwas.
Darf ich es präzisieren?
Das ist ja schon eine interessante Strategie, die da gemacht wird. Also er versucht erst einmal durch ein gewisses Raunen den Raum möglichst weit zu machen und dann sind die interpretatorischen Spielräume groß.
Genau, ich will es mal so richtig präzisieren, denn es kommt ja wirklich drauf an, was genau gesagt wurde. Also er steht vor Woidke bei diesem Antrittsbesuch in Brandenburg, wo man sich denkt, alter du bist seit gefühlt 20 Jahren Bundeskanzler, zumindest deine Idee, und jetzt bist du es halt selber. Was ist ein Antrittsbesuch in Brandenburg? Ist das überhaupt berichten wert? Taucht jedenfalls in den Medien auf. Woidke hinter ihm, ich gucke mit meiner 15-jährigen Tochter die Tagesschau, und wir machen noch Scherze darüber, wer von wem ist wer. Ich kann es jetzt gut unterscheiden, weil ich immer Fernsehpodcasts mache. Aber wer von beiden ist noch mal genau wer? Okay, der eine nickt und der andere sagt, ja, Abschiebung, und wir haben ja auch die Zahlen 60 Prozent runter. Aber dann haben wir ja noch das Problem im Stadtbild. So, es wird also einfach so aus dem Ärmel geschüttelt. Merz weiß selber nicht, wie ihm geschieht. Und ich möchte jetzt schon mal anmerken, das ist der eigentliche Rassismus, um den wir uns kümmern müssen. Hier baut niemand ein KZ auf, hier baut niemand ein Ghetto und hier erschießt niemand jemand auf der Straße. Das Problem in Deutschland ist dieser latente, unsichtbare Rassismus, der sich immer dann Bahn bricht, wenn sozusagen es hart auf hart steht. Wer wird hier versetzt, wer kriegt eine Wohnung, wer kriegt einen Arbeitsvertrag und so weiter und so fort. In diesen kleinen Momenten. Da kann natürlich jeder sagen, ich kenne ihn seit 50 Jahren, der ist kein Rassist. Aber in diesem kleinen Moment, wo es drauf ankommt, war er leider ein Rassist. Dann kommt die nächste Pressegelegenheit, es kommt die Nachfrage, er macht den Spruch mit den Töchtern. Den schüttelt er noch mal so aus dem Ärmel, also kann man wieder ignorieren. Dann kommt es zu einer Demo von Frauen in Berlin. Wir haben häufiger betont, wir kennen das von Abendveranstaltungen, also dass Frauen sich mal zu Wort melden. Da muss schon, man sieht immer so ein bisschen, ich war jetzt auch wieder in Jena. Männer stehen sofort auf, haben irgendeine Frage, wollen irgendwas anmerken. Typischerweise Statement zehn Minuten, die Moderation so, können sie bitte jetzt zur Frage kommen, wie auch immer. Wenn eine Frau sich meldet, weiß man sofort, die hat jetzt gerade 20 Minuten drüber nachgedacht, was sie gleich sagt, jedes Wort ist vorbereitet, das sitzt jetzt. Wenn 6000 Frauen vor die CDU-Zentrale gehen, würde ich sagen, da ist ein Handlungsbedarf. Diesen Handlungsbedarf sah auch die CDU. Merz fliegt ins Ausland, macht wieder irgendeinen komischen Besuch, diesmal wahrscheinlich Antritt bei UK oder so, steht vor der Presse und liest stammelnd zögernd, man hat ihm richtig eingedroschen, keine spontanen Worte, liest ab, was da steht. In diesem Statement kommt dreimal pro Minute das Wort Arbeitsmarkt vor. Wir brauchen ja die Migranten für den Arbeitsmarkt. Das ist also genau das Antidot, was wir ja immer betonen. Du musst die Menschen nicht mögen, wie auch immer, aber volkswirtschaftlich macht es voll Sinn, jetzt einfach ein paar Nigerianer am Stadtbild zuzulassen. Ansonsten ist hier Torgau und das wollen wir nicht. So. Und so verschleppt sich das immer weiter, bis, und das ist jetzt mein Highlight von gestern, ich sitze auf dem Fahrrad und höre, den Podcast der Frankfurter Allgemeinen Zeitung. Livia Gerster ist zu Gast, weil sie darüber geschrieben hat. Simon Strauß moderiert diesen Podcast. Am Anfang ist eine junge Hospitantin, die losgeschickt wurde von der Redaktion. Geh mal zum Hauptbahnhof, fang Stimmen ein. Sie bringt ausschließlich O-Töne mit von Leuten, die sagen, also das, was Merz gesagt hat, ist hardcore rassistisch. Man möchte diesen Leuten einfach sagen, ihr habt absolut recht, weil es reicht vollständig, wenn ihr das so fühlt. Was will man jetzt in großer Aufklärung machen? Will man jetzt im Bahnhof einfach alle Leute mal kurz durchrütteln und sagen, das war kein Rassismus und so? Was macht Jürgen Kaube? Genau das. Er will ganz Deutschland kurz anhalten und nimmt auch an diesem Gespräch teil, um 20 Minuten lang zu erklären, nee, das war kein Rassismus und er meinte ja auch nicht, die Lungenärzte, wenn die sich jetzt Lungenärzte äußern und sagen, ich habe Migrationshintergrund und sehe im Stadtbild, das sieht man mir ja nicht an, dass ich Lungenarzt bin, aber dass ich und so weiter ja und lauter solche Sachen. Oder sage ich würde ich mal so insgesamt ja, wenn sehr viele ältere Männer feststellen, dass sie es nicht vermittelt bekommen, dass irgendetwas, was sie gesagt haben, kein Rassismus sei und sie merken selber, dass sie jetzt mehr als 20 Minuten brauchen, um uns das darzustellen, dann war es vielleicht doch einfach Rassismus.
Möglich, ja.
Ja, und vielleicht gilt dann auch einfach mal, was man so fühlt, nämlich, dass man sich ausgestoßen fühlt von jemanden, der behauptet, und ich meine Friedrich Merz und Stadtbild, nimmt Friedrich Merz am Stadtbild teil. Der Typ wird bewirtet, befördert und wenn er einen Termin in Dänemark hat, fliegt er von Berlin mit dem Hubschrauber dahin.
Ja.
So, Friedrich Merz ist der Allerletzte, der was zum Stadtbild sagen kann. Und er hat aber was zum Stadtbild gesagt, dass alle als rassistisch ansehen, die davon betroffen sind, und wir kennen ja die Anteile der Migrationsgeschichte in Deutschland, alle sind davon betroffen.
Entweder persönlich oder weil die Person, mit der man gerade sich durch die Stadt bewegt, eine Migrationsentwicklung hat.
Das will ich tatsächlich gleich infrage stellen. Wir, denke ich, klammern eine bittere Wahrheit aus, die ich aber jetzt gleich in Form von Clips uns präsentieren möchte. Ich will aber eine Anmerkung dazu machen, erlebt er das Stadtbild? Nein, er erlebt das nicht. Leute, die viel Geld verdienen, erleben sowieso Stadtbild kaum. Das heißt, wenn sie das Stadtbild erleben, dann sind sie oft in einer ökonomischen Lage. Also mit Stadtbild meine ich jetzt, sie müssen regelmäßig mit der U-Bahn zur Arbeit fahren. Sie müssen sehen, dass sie sich in der Mittagspause irgendwo schnell was für 4,50 Euro zu essen kaufen. Und das kostet aber nicht mehr 4,50 Euro, sondern inzwischen 7,50 Euro. Das ist eigentlich Stadtbilderlebnis. Und da merkt man natürlich, dass wir einen enormen ökonomischen Druck inzwischen haben, dass es eine reale Knappheit gibt, die die ganze Zeit gemanagt werden muss von Menschen. Und das macht das Stadtbild sehr hart. Es ist ein hartes Pflaster geworden. Es wird immer härter durch den sozialen Druck, der entstanden ist. Und das ist aber etwas, was ja vollkommen ausgeblendet wird. Mick hatte ja im Fernsehpodcast dieses gute Beispiel mit den Schwimmbädern, dass dann immer gesagt wird, das ist jetzt so ein ganz problematischer Ort geworden. De facto ist es so, dass diese Schwimmbäder tatsächlich sehr überlaufen sind. Einfach deshalb, weil immer mehr Schwimmbäder schließen müssen, weil keine Gelder angeblich da sind. Was dazu führt, dass immer mehr Menschen auf immer weniger Schwimmbäder verteilt werden. Zugleich haben wir Hitzewellen im Sommer, dass die Leute irgendwo hin müssen, um sich mal abkühlen zu können. Das alles erhöht enorm den sozialen Druck, erhöht Gewalt natürlich dann in alle Richtungen und bedeutet also, dass wenn wir über so etwas reden, wir eigentlich über diese Knappheiten, die real existent sind, reden müssten. Und da ist aber, wie wir wissen, die CDU nie bereit zu und Friedrich Merz schon gar nicht.
Ja und ich hätte mir eine Pointe auf, aber ich will schon mal anmerken in einem anderen, also wir treffen immer wieder auf dasselbe Paradox. Friedrich Merz wollte jetzt eine Unterlegenheit darstellen, im Sinne von ein Problem ist noch zu lösen, ich habe es noch nicht bewältigt. Friedrich Merz ist aber Bundeskanzler. Er sagt das aus einer ganz großen Position der Stärke heraus, die sich aber inhaltlich dann nicht widerspiegelt, denn er behauptet ja, oh Mist, ich bin immer noch Opfer des Stadtbilds. Ich muss hier noch was tun. Und diese Verdrehung aus Stärke und Schwäche werden wir jetzt gleich wieder erleben. Damit ist aber nicht aufgehoben, dass das dieser grundlegende, latente Rassismus ist. Jaja. Denn auch Leute, die Ausländer sind, können Rassisten sein.
Ja, wenn du gleich... Das ist ja auch genau die richtige Vorbereitung. Wenn ich auch noch nicht so sicher bin, wie wir das noch vielleicht ein bisschen besser greifen können. Also diese Art des Rassismus, die es da gibt, dass dann so eine Unterscheidung gemacht wird, aufgrund von Ethnizität, bedeutet Rassismus. Und doch glaube ich, müssen wir nochmal diese Form des Rassismus spezifizieren. Und zwar war es so, dass mir in meiner Timeline bei Instagram selbstredend die aufgefallen sind, die sich zum einen empört haben darüber, über die Stadtbildaussage, zum anderen eingeordnet haben, was wirklich in den Städten los ist, bis hin, das hat mir eigentlich am besten gefallen, zu den ganzen komödiantischen, parodistischen Videos, zum Beispiel von Abdul Shahin und so, die dann sagen so, ich gehe jetzt mal raus ins Stadtbild und die hängen sich nochmal so eine Umhängetasche rum und spielen, also mit diesem Klischee, damit sie als das erkannt werden, was Friedrich Merz gemeint hat. Ja, also das habe ich alles wahrgenommen und das spielen wir hier nicht nochmal ab. Ich denke auch, die meisten, die uns so zuhören, können sich in etwa denken, was es war oder haben es auch gesehen. Dann hat es mich aber in andere Ecken getrieben, denn ich wollte tatsächlich mal so ein bisschen schauen, wie wird da von rechts drauf reagiert. Dann findet man auch das, was man sich so vorstellen kann, von Peter Hane bis Ulf Poschert und sonst wem, was die da so alles äußern, hat mich aber nicht interessiert, weil ich das ja auch schon kannte. Dann ist mir aber aufgefallen bei YouTube, und wir wissen, das ist die wichtigste Streaming und die wichtigste Podcastplattform, wenn man so möchte, ist mir aufgefallen, dass es im migrantischen Entertainment-Bereich, Podcastbereich und aber auch bei Straßenumfragen durchaus Stimmen gibt, die nicht nur Merz unterstützen, sondern noch sehr viel weitergehen. Und das, dachte ich, ist ja ein interessantes Phänomen, über das relativ wenig geredet wird, weil wir haben gerade, wenn von links jetzt diese Äußerungen von Merz so kritisiert werden, dann wird dann auch immer sich lustig gemacht über die entsprechenden Boomer. Du hast jetzt ja auch schon gesagt, Friedrich Merz und Woidgim, man kann sie kaum voneinander unterscheiden. Und genauso sind ja auch ihre Wähler. Aber da gibt es ja noch mal so ein anderes Milieu. Dann habe ich bei Ben Ungeskripted mir einen Comedian angesehen, der mal so einen Comedypreis gewonnen hat, jetzt in der Schweiz lebt, ja, sehr komische Sachen sagt. Also es ist nicht alles irr, aber vieles. Aber ich will jetzt auch nicht diesen ganzen Podcast da auseinandernehmen, sondern will mich nur auf Äußerungen von Salim Samatu, heißt er, stützen, in denen es um Flüchtlinge, Migration, AfD und so etwas geht, was er dort im Podcast sagt. Er tritt in ganz vielen Podcasts auf, gibt auch ganz viele Shorts, die dann kommen, in denen er irgendwelche Leute disqualifiziert, die auf der Straße rumlaufen, sich nicht benehmen, die als Hunde bezeichnet etc. Wir wollen jetzt auch hier nicht alles aufführen, sondern mal auf diesen Podcast blicken und auf diese Äußerungen. Er spricht jetzt erst einmal über Flüchtlinge aus der Ukraine, die hier ja privilegiert behandelt worden sind gegenüber anderen Flüchtlingen.
Hey, wir haben viele Leute, die das System ausnutzen.
Oh, das ist gegen die Menschenwürde. Jeder Mensch ist ein netter Netter und keiner würde scammen.
Das wäre meine erste Frage.
Bro, kriegst du was von diesem Scam?
Es gibt so viele, die dann immer wieder so Debatten aufmachen. Ja, wir müssen aufpassen, dass Bürgergärtnisch jeder direkt beantragen kann. Allein schon, dass Ukraine hergekommen sind und direkt ins Sozialsystem kommen konnten und direkte Arbeitserlaubnis bekommen haben. Das ist für mich so, dessen Eltern so auf die harte Schule reingekommen sind. Asylheim, Arbeitsgenehmigung, musstest vorweisen, dass du keine finanzielle Unterstützung brauchst. So war das ja bei unserer Generation unserer Eltern. Die mussten herkommen, mussten zeigen, dass sie ein Bürgen hatten. Die mussten so richtig, dass du pulloß nicht an dieses deutsche köstliche Sozialversicherungssteuergeld rankommen sollst.
Eine Frage. Wir wissen ja jetzt durch deinen Besuch, diese Besuche da sind sehr lang.
Ja.
Redet er drei Stunden lang so? Ja.
Oh Gott. Ja. So kann man sich auch Zugfahrten vergnüglich gestalten. Ich war wirklich hart. Ich will nur sagen, seine Eltern sind aus Marokko und er auch. Also er ist 2009, 2010 nach Deutschland gekommen, lebt inzwischen in der Schweiz, weil er glaubt, dass hier alles den Bach untergeht.
Geht ja auch.
Wir kennen das. Ja, wir werden das auch gleich hören, dass es den Bach untergeht, aber aus anderer Perspektive, nämlich von Ökonomen. Das ist eine Äußerung. Wir haben jetzt schon gehört, die Eltern mussten hier auf die harte Tour ankommen.
Also in dem Punkt stimmt das ja auch voll.
Das stimmt. Ja, genau. Und jetzt hören wir mal weiter.
Dass Leute reinkommen können und direkt am Walk-in und Sunshine. Und wenn der Söder dann so was sagt, wie alle Ukrainer müssen raus aus diesem Bürgergeld. Es kann ja nicht sein, dass in Polen und überall anders haben wir Beschäftigungsquote von extrem hoher Beschäftigungsquote. Und bei uns sind so viele noch im Bürgergeld. Das kann ja nicht sein, das ist ja am Walk-in und Sunshine. Und da kommt so ein Straßenkleber wie der Klingbeil. Das geht nicht, dass Leute, die so gebeutelt sind vom Krieg, die müssen sich erst mal vom Trauma erholen. Die müssen ja das weiter kriegen. Nach drei Jahren, fast vier Jahre, sind ja de facto adoptiert.
Also wenn das jemals in die Nähe eines Originalwortlauts Klingbeil käme, wären wir ja sehr viel weiter.
Ja, ja, das ist also das man Klingbeil als Straßenkleber bezeichnet. Also für ihn ist Klingbeil ganz schlimm, ganz links und so weiter. Also das muss man erst mal so, die Koordinaten sind halt sehr verrutscht. Was wir aber hier schon sehen können, Solidarität mit anderen Menschen, die von irgendwo herkommen, eher nicht. Dann weist Ben ihn darauf hin, also Samathus These ist dann, die machen das alles, also die Grünen und die Linken wollen die vielen Flüchtlinge nach Deutschland holen, um ihnen schnell eine Staatsbürgerschaft zu geben, damit diese dann sich bei der nächsten Wahl bedanken.
Ja, das ist die Idee, die er da ausführt. Das ist die 1 zu 1 Kopie der Vorwürfe von allen, Stephen Bannon und so weiter, all die demokratischen Parteien. Das ist wirklich die original YouTube-Übersetzung automatisiert, dieser Propaganda.
Und das wird hier dann lange ausgeführt, deswegen spielen wir das jetzt nicht, das kennen wir schon, dieses Argument. Dann kommt aber Ben und sagt, ja, aber es gibt doch auch Migranten, die die AfD wählen.
Sorry, ich nehme das weg.
Sorry, ich nehme das einfach nur aus dem Bild raus.
Das habe ich gerade voll geschockt, stimmt das wirklich? Gibt es wirklich viele Migranten, die die AfD wählen?
Ja, es gibt ja auch quasi AfD-Mitglieder, die migrantisch sind und einfach sich hier Feroz und so raushauen, der sich irgendwo hinsetzt und sagt, pass auf, ich wähle AfD, change my mind.
Richtig, weil ich habe gedacht, ich war an deinem Beispiel mit diesem Wählerscam, das funktioniert nicht bei 2. Generationen Türken oder so was. Das kannst du vergessen, weil die sind ja schon hier. Die wollen dann eher, wie zum Beispiel jetzt meine Eltern, die zurück zum Deutschland, wie es vorher war.
Deutschland, wie es vorher war. Was ist jetzt die gute alte Zeit? Wir hören mal.
Bro, vorher hatten wir kein Problem, damit Leute abzuschieben. Ich weiß noch genau, es gab voll viele Leute von unseren Moscheen und so was, die ihren Aufenthalt nicht verlängert haben. Dann sind die irgendwie rumgelaufen, kamen in Personenkontrolle rein. Ah, sie haben ihren Aufenthalt nicht verlängert. Da gab es keine NGOs, die gesagt haben, Pro Asyl, bleib hier, das ist menschenunwürdig. Da wurde sie dann gepackt, in den Van geworfen. Da war er am nächsten Tag in Tunesien, ist er da respawned. Wir haben den nicht mehr gesehen. Wir haben dann irgendwann erfahren von der Polizei, als wir vermissten Anzeige aufgestellt haben, wir haben Abdul Meck Abdul nicht mehr gesehen. Wo ist der? Abdul Meck Abdul wurde abgeschoben. Da hat sein Aufenthalt nicht verlängert. Okay, dann musste der wieder zurück übers Los. Weiß ich nicht, bei Monopoly musste der wieder von vorne beginnen. Aber so war das in meiner Erinnerung. Das war meine erste Erinnerung an Deutschland. Die Polizisten nicht kontrollieren, sitzt gerade, krasser Blick, Respekt.
Ja, das ist heute für die Betroffenen auch so. Zu denen gehört er halt nicht mehr. Deswegen sieht er das nicht mehr.
Ja, aber das musst du dir jetzt wieder vorstellen, was hier glorifiziert wird. Glorifiziert wird, dass der Staat so hart durchgreift, dass Menschen brutal abgeschoben werden, in den Vän reingezerrt werden, dass die Polizei so harsh auftritt. Was wir also hier finden ist, und deswegen glaube ich, ist dieser Begriff Rassismus mir ein bisschen zu diffus. Ich würde sagen, was wir hier vorfinden, ist ein Sozial-Dawinismus, der verknüpft wird mit einem Rassismus. Denn interessant ja auch, er greift das Spiel Monopoly auf. Das ja eines ist, dass dafür sorgt, dass es immer Verlierer gibt.
Dass es niemanden Spaß macht.
Dass es auch niemanden Spaß macht. Aber das ist eigentlich das, wie die Welt ist, wie das Leben sein sollte. Und jede sozialstaatliche Maßnahme, jede Solidarität mit den Flüchtlingen, ist eigentlich eine Unterminierung des Spiels Monopoly. Und deswegen müssen wir zurück zu dieser alten guten Härte, die Deutschland einmal auszeichnete. Wo wir auch sagen, na das ist ja immer noch so. Oder nimmt ihr jetzt gerade ja wieder mehr zu. Aber das ist etwas, was glorifiziert wird. Und wenn man sich durch sehr viele dieser YouTube Shorts klickt, auch von vielen anderen, dann ist das, also von Menschen, die einen Migrationshintergrund haben und auch ganz offen diesen transportieren und auch darüber reden, dass sie den haben, dann ist sehr häufig dazu beobachtet, dass sich da ein solcher Sozialdarwinismus sehr stark ausprägt. Weshalb ich das jetzt hier als Thema so mache, ist nicht um zu sagen, seht ihr, wir Deutsche sind gar nicht so schlimm, die anderen sind mindestens genauso schlimm, sondern was ich hier sagen will, ist, dass hier ein enormes Wählerpotenzial tatsächlich vorliegt, sowohl für CDU, CSU, als auch für die AfD. Das ist etwas, was man auch dann in den Kommentaren finden kann, auch wenn man dann mal zu Instagram oder so geht, da kann man ja dann immer sehr gut sehen, welche Kommentare sind echt, wenn man dann auf die Profile klickt. Und dann findet man sehr viele Bekundungen zur AfD, klickt die Profile an und sieht, das sind ganz eindeutig Menschen mit einem Migrationshintergrund und nicht selten muslimische Menschen.
Genau. Du hast jetzt gesagt, der Rassismus ist hier sekundär. Es ist sozusagen die Methode für ein anderes Problem, das gelöst werden soll. Dazu kriegen wir heute ganz tolle Aufklärung. Also ich finde es ganz überraschend, aber Justus Bender und Erik Ahrens waren in unterschiedlichen Podcasten. Der eine ist der Aussteiger aus der AfD, Graf, Aufbauer und TikTok-Genie. Und der andere ist einfach ganz solider FRZ-Beobachter von dem, was da passiert. Und wir kriegen von beiden exakt dasselbe beschrieben. Nämlich Menschen erleben eine Welt, in der sie auf sich selbst zurückgeworfen nur noch mit einem reagieren können. Und es ist einfach Pessimismus. Absolute Orientierungslosigkeit, Angst und so weiter und so fort. Und darauf reagiert man mit einer Suche nach Ordnung. Die Ordnung bietet der Staat. Und den Rassismus braucht man jetzt, um zu sagen, ich wünsche mir einen starken Staat, der sich aber nicht gegen mich richtet, sondern gegen die anderen. Jetzt macht Friedrich Merz also ein hardcore rassistisches Argument und sagt, das Problem sind immer noch die anderen. Wir alle fragen uns, wer sind denn die anderen? Und genauso wie im Raume steht, diese Frage noch zu beantworten, wer sind denn die anderen, muss man sich fragen, wer sind denn wir selbst? Denn es ist durchaus ein Szenario denkbar. Und wir hören es von Eric Ahrens nachher auch. Wenn man den sozialen Darwinismus, den du jetzt beschrieben hast, in purer Form ohne Rassismus auf sich selber anwendet, dann sortiert er seine eigenen Propagandisten aus. Und er sagt es ganz ausdrücklich. In der AfD hat er Leute kennengelernt, die sind alt, fett, krank und für nichts zu gebrauchen. Und die mobilisieren jetzt den Rassismus gegen die anderen. Wenn jetzt irgendeine Partei kommt und sagt, das mit dem Rassismus ist eine ganz schlechte Idee, weil die Arbeitsplätze, die Arbeitsplätze, die Arbeitsplätze, und es droht ja in der CDU auch, dass man es mal so ganz runterbricht, dann könnte sich so ein Argument, dass die anderen und so weiter sehr krass gegen diese Boomer-Männer richten, weil dann nehme ich deren Abwehr im Sinne von, ich bin ja urdeutsch, gegen mich kann sich ja der Staat gar nicht richten. Wenn wir das einmal auf die ökonomische Logik runterbrechen und sagen, nee, Deutschland ist nicht, was hier urdeutsch ist, sondern Deutschland ist, wer uns hier weiterhilft, und so weiter, dann könnte sich das auch umdrehen. Dann stehen nämlich in urbanen Zentren, und das sieht man in Amerika teilweise schon, dass in urbanen Zentren einfach ein Wählerverhalten stattfindet, bei dem jemand, weil er als, ich bin ein Kommunist, ich will hier den Sozialismus, ich möchte eure Supermärkte betreiben, vom Danied einfach gewinnt. Und dann sind plötzlich diejenigen, die immer in der Minderheit waren, auch wirklich in der Minderheit, nämlich alte, fette Männer, die einfach nur vor YouTube sitzen den ganzen Tag, und die dann erklären müssen plötzlich, welchen Sinn sie eigentlich noch in dieser Gesellschaft haben. Also Rassismus ist sozusagen das Mittel der Wahl, mit der sich die einen...
Aber man muss sich ja von dem sozialen... Weil das werden wir bei Ahrens sehen. Also ich finde, dass eben Ahrens auch eigentlich sehr sozialdarwinistisch nach wie vor denkt. Und das ist das Problem. Denn man kann nur eine Gesellschaft der Solidarität haben, die nicht sozialdarwinistisch denkt, die also nicht in der Monopoly-Logik ist. Und hier wird ja einfach nur diese Monopoly-Logik angewendet. Und natürlich bleibt dann auch so jemand wie Salim Samatu ne Massismus treu, weil der sagt, ja, hier offenbar muss ich noch mal unterscheiden zwischen denen, die immer deutsch sind. Da muss ich das sozialdarwinistische Argument nicht als erstes machen, weil da zählt erst mal, dass die ja schon die richtige Ethnie haben. Bei den anderen aber, da ist, weil sie nicht die entsprechende deutsche Ethnie haben, müssen sie dann noch mal überlosgehen. Müssen sie noch mal möglicherweise abgeschoben werden, weil sie dann noch nicht so richtig dazu passen. Und da sind wir aber jetzt ja in diesem heiklen Gefilde, dass sich hier was überlagert. Nämlich zum einen ein Ausleseprinzip, das wirtschaftlich und ästhetisch und wie auch sonst hergeholt wird. Und dann wird es verknüpft mit einem rassistischen Aussiebeverfahren. Und man muss jetzt nach einer Gesellschaft streben, die keine Aussiebung macht. Und ob jemand alt ist oder jung ist oder wie auch immer geartet ist, darf ja niemals ein Ausschlusskriterium für irgendetwas sein.
Ja, das ist natürlich ein frommer Wunsch. Wir sehen ja, wie wenig wir schon gegen Rassismus vorwärtskommen. Gegen diesen darunterliegenden eigentlich Triebkraft, Sozialdavinismus. Also wir kommen jetzt in Jahrzehnte Europas, in denen wir feststellen, dass nichts mehr funktioniert. Also unser Exportwirtschaftsmodell, das Wachstum organisierte, dazu kommen wir heute. ist im Osten und im Westen abgeschnitten. Wir kommen jetzt vor Verteilungs- und Versorgungsfragen, bei denen wir möchten gerne den Sozialdavinismus überwinden. Also ja, wir können das jetzt verstehen. Also wir durchschauen jetzt sozusagen die Problemstellung, aber nur, weil sie ganz offen zu Tage tritt. Und nur, weil wir sie durchschauen, heißt das nicht, dass es jetzt eine Lösung gibt. Also wir besprechen jetzt auch ganz viele Probleme. Ich habe ja da Übung drin. Ich gehe immer Altenerpublik, Kinderwüste und so weiter. Und das erste, was ich sage, ist, schön, dass Sie alle da sind. Wir reden heute Abend nur über Probleme, für die wir niemals lösen. Wir können sie allenfalls noch so besprechen und verstehen und so weiter. Aber wir lösen jetzt hier keine Altenerpublik und Kinderwüste Probleme. Und so ist das mit diesem Sozialdavinismus auch.
Ja, richtig. Aber deswegen ist ja das Problem dann auch bei Ahrens, dass er eigentlich jetzt sagt, er will auf der Seite der Starken stehen und deswegen ist er nicht bei der AfD. Und das finde ich ist auch kein Argument. Also man kann dann sagen, gut, dass er nicht mehr bei der AfD ist oder was. Wir können ja gleich noch darüber ausführlicher diskutieren, wie weit wir den Ausstieg auch tatsächlich als Ausstieg wahrnehmen sollten. Aber was wir ja auf jeden Fall feststellen können, ist, dass das jetzt nicht das eine durch das andere ersetzt werden soll. Beziehungsweise erleben wir ja hier, dass sich das dann in dieser merkwürdigen Weise überlagert, dass man plötzlich einfach die Guten und die Schlechten einteilt. Und nach dieser Verquickung von Rassismus und Sozialdavinismus ist man nämlich genau dann in der Logik, dass man sagt, ja, der Comedian aus Marokko oder der Lungenarzt aus Marokko ist selbstredend nicht gemeint, wenn man vom Stadtbild redet. Aber die und die und die. Damit kommt man ja genau in diese ganz heiklen Gefilde rein, die dann dafür sorgen, dass Menschen mit einem Fluchthintergrund, der vielleicht sechs, sieben Jahre zurückliegt, die jetzt in der Jungen Union sind, sagen, Friedrich Merz hat recht. Auch diese Posts hat es ja in den sozialen Medien gegeben. Wir hören hier nochmal Salim Samatu.
Ich kann dir ganz klar garantieren, bevor du einen Moslem dazu bringst, dass er Geschlechtsumwandlung für seine Kinder supportet, willst du ihn dafür bringen, dass er mit Gauland und Weidl schunkelt auf dem Oktoberfest? Das wird er vorher machen.
Ja, das stimmt einfach gar nicht. Also das stimmt einfach gar nicht. Wir wissen von der dritten Einwanderergeneration, dass die extrem urdeutsch ist. So, die lassen sich nicht von ihren Klassenkameraden in der Peer Group nicht davon beeindrucken, dass man jetzt sein Leben gestalten möchte. Und zwar in allen Belangen. Und das ist ja auch eines dieser Probleme innerhalb dieser Familien, dass irgendwann der Opa nach Deutschland kam und man ist ihm zu Dank verpflichtet und überhaupt und die Familie liegt ihm zu Füßen. Und im Grunde wird das ganze moderne Leben darum herumgebaut, dass er das nicht mitkriegt in den letzten zehn Jahren, dass man eigentlich jetzt angekommen ist in der westlichen Welt. So, und dann kann er jetzt behaupten, was er will, das ist ja auch hier alles so ein Schmuckwerk an Rhetorik.
Ich will ja auch nicht sagen, der sagt uns jetzt mal, wie es wirklich ist. Dann würde ich ja dem Ganzen auf den Leim gehen. Ich sage nur, dieses ist jetzt, was man sehr häufig vorfinden kann bei YouTube und was eine große Community anzieht. Einmal eine Community, die tatsächlich zum Beispiel muslimisch ist, wie aber auch natürlich eine deutsche Community, die sagt, Gott sei Dank, ich bin ja kein Rassist, wenn das jetzt ein Ausländer sagt, genau so sieht wie ich, dann muss ja alles in Ordnung sein. Wir wissen, dass es besonders beliebt, die AfD würde gerne mehr, glaube ich, auf solche Kandidaten setzen. Und wir erleben, dass das für Deutsche so eine Entlastung ist, wenn der Migrant hinter sich die Tür zuzieht und sagt, jetzt ist aber auch mal Schluss, mehr sollten wir nicht reinlassen. Das ist etwas, was wir da auch erleben können. Ich glaube nur, dass wir zugleich ein bisschen ignorieren, dass es diese konservativen und rechten Strömungen vermehrt bei Menschen gibt, die einen Migrationshintergrund haben und dass auch gerade diese Feindlichkeit zum Beispiel gegenüber Gender vielfach zu hören ist in diesen entsprechenden Podcasts. Und zum Beispiel wir haben ja Hoss und Hopf, wo der eine auch einen ganz deutlichen Migrationshintergrund hat, wo wir das alles auch erleben können. Und das ist heute auch in einer Jugendkultur dort verbreitet. Also da findet nicht notwendigerweise eine Liberalisierung da. Bedeutet also, das Problem Rechtsdruck ist tatsächlich als ein flächendeckendes zu sehen. Und das macht das ja so intrikat auch, weil man ja leicht aus einer linken Perspektive heraus sagen kann, wir müssen alles tun, damit rechts nicht gewinnt, um zum Beispiel Menschen mit Migrationshintergrund davor zu schützen, dass sie entsprechende Repressionen erleben. Wenn wir aber dann Leute haben, die sehenden Auges da reingehen und sagen, ich finde aber die AfD gut. Also wenn sozusagen die, die wir retten wollen, und das ist ja immer schon ein schwieriges Verhältnis, wenn man sich als Retter aufschwingt, wenn die nicht gerettet werden wollen, davon erzählt ja im Prinzip der Schwarze Falke von John Ford. Wenn John Wayne will dann eine junge Frau retten, die will aber eigentlich dann doch gar nicht gerettet werden. In Taxi Driver haben wir das dann wieder aufgegriffen. Das ist eine Konstellation, die uns glaube ich noch nicht so klar ist, die aber, so scheint mir, sowohl die CDU als auch die AfD relativ gut beobachtet. Und die finden ja auch in diesem Podcast sehr viel Anklang.
Also zusätzlich, man muss ja mal gucken, wie viel sozusagen empirisches Korrelat da drin hängt, denn wir sehen ja erstmal ein Medienphänomen. Wir würden ja grundsätzlich sagen, also das, was bei Ben und Gretel so abläuft, das ist jetzt nicht unbedingt, ich meine, du hast da versucht, so ein bisschen Aufklärung zu betreiben.
Es hören hunderttausende Leute.
Genau, es hören sehr viele Leute zu, bei denen ja dann die Frage ist, wenn die The Wolf of Wall Street sehen und da gucken Millionen zu, leben die dann so oder gibt es da irgendwo eine Einflugschneise. Denn hier haben wir ja auch erstmal ein Phänomen, jemand von dem wir intuitiv, und er wird das auch selber nicht abstreiten, je nachdem wie sichtbar sein Migrationshintergrund ist, der also Rassismus erlebt. Der reagiert natürlich darauf. Und ich finde das sowieso immer verwunderlich, dass CDU und SPD auch immer so ein Programm fahren mit, ja, wir müssen jetzt mal gegen Rassismus kämpfen und so, als gäbe es nicht abseits einer inhaltlichen Aufklärung und dem Medienspektakel sowieso eine Gegenreaktion auf Rassismus. Denn ein Land wie Deutschland, das Faktor 5 an Einwanderungsgeschichte hat im Vergleich zur Welt, 20, 25 Prozent Migrationsgeschichte, was glauben wir denn so insgesamt, also wir 60 Millionen Deutsche, was die anderen 20 Millionen hier im Land so machen, dass sie das einfach so, ah ja gut, Rassismus passiert so lange, bis die Deutschen sich dazu verhalten, aber wir selber machen dazu gar nichts. Nein, die gründen natürlich, also türkische Schulen, um endlich mal stigmafrei einfach die Kinder geruhsam durchs Abitur zu bringen, statt bei jedem Elterngespräch wieder den Eltern den Lehrern erklären zu müssen, dass man das Kind jetzt durchaus mal einfach versetzen kann. Ja, lauter solche Sachen. Und da ist natürlich hier so eine Selbstbehauptung im Sinne von, ich lasse mir nicht nur von irgendwelchen Rassisten in dem Land, in dem ich lebe, meine Identität erklären, sondern ich mache es einfach selbst und gehe mit einer ganz komischen Sprechweise in so ein Ben-ungeskriptet-Podcast. Das ist ja fast so ein Stunt, wie dass du dahin gehst, weißt du? Ja, das weiß ich eben nicht.
Da bin ich mir nicht so sicher. Was ich aber sagen kann ist, dass wir...
Ich kann dir sagen, der Ben hat sehr viele Zuhörer, die das sehr wohl über Rassismus abgewickelt haben wollen und nicht über Sozialdarwinismus, wie wir es hier bei ihm hören. Also es sind einfach sehr viele, die sagen, nein, es ist mir egal, ob du ein erfolgreicher Comedian bist, ob du so und so viel Geld verdienst, ob du eine schöne Freundin hast oder was auch immer für vorbildhaft. Ich möchte gerne, dass du, weil ich Ausländer hasse und du wie ein Ausländer aussiehst, der hat auch noch Überzeugungsarbeit zu leisten. Genau wie du da auch.
Nein, nein, nein, das wäre ja noch die, dann würdest du sagen, dass sich da eigentlich nicht viel verändert hat. Und ich würde festhalten, dass wir diesen Rassismus, den du da jetzt gerade beschrieben hast, wo alle quasi dann als Ausländer nicht gewollt sind, dass wir das selbstredend vorfinden. Aber das finden wir in noch nicht mal allen Teilen der AfD. Ja, also soweit will ich da wirklich gehen.
Aber das ist ja kein einheitlicher Block. Das dürfen wir von außen nicht so betrachten.
So, das finden wir nicht mal da. Und dass es viel mehr auf diese sozialdarwinistische Schiene hinausläuft, bei der das auf diese merkwürdige Weise miteinander verquickt wird. Denn anders, also ich glaube, der Punkt ist auch, wir werden ja dieses Buch Zerstörungslust Elemente des demokratischen Faschismus auch lesen im nächsten Salon von Amlinger und Nachtwey. Und das Problem bei dem Faschismusbegriff ist ja, dass man sehr schnell diese Assoziation bekommt, Nazis, Homogenität. Diese Homogenität wissen wir aber ist gar nicht herzustellen. Wir sind in völlig anderen Situationen als 1933, wenn man sich Migrationsanteile und die Pluralität der Religion und all das ansieht. Was wir aber vorfinden, ist, dass dieses sozialdarwinistische Prinzip faschistisch ist. Und dass sich das verknüpft und dass das aber nicht in so einem homogenen, konsistenten Weltbild zu verstehen ist. Eben weil die dann sagen, ja, also ich sage, das Stadtbild stört mich. Und die werden dann noch sagen, hier sind zu viele Ausländer im Stadtbild. Würden aber zugleich sagen, ja, aber so jemanden wie den Salim Samatu, den finde ich gut. Und dadurch wird das alles so miteinander verschoben, dass ja auch keiner von denen sagt, ich habe was mit Rassismus zu tun. Ja, auch bei der AfD in dem Sinne nicht. Also es gab ja auch neue Rechte früher, die sich zum Rassismus klar bekannt haben.
Ja genau, und das haben wir heute nicht mehr.
Und das haben wir in dieser Weise nicht mehr. Und das macht, glaube ich, auch den Kampf dagegen so äußerst schwierig. Macht es für die anderen sehr viel leichter, sich als Verbündete darzustellen, weil die sagen, wir meinen nur, die mit den Messern rumlaufen und auch eure Töchter bedrohen. Deswegen müsst ihr uns wählen. Wir hören mal noch den Vorschlag von Samato, er hätte eigentlich gerne eine Partei Migranten für Deutschland.
Und wie der konservative Werte und für alle Migranten steht diese Partei. Einfach nur Migranten für Deutschland. Also wenn jemand in die Wahlurne geht, diesen Obama-Effekt, oh, Migrant, Migrant. Kriegen wir locker 20 Prozent, locker, weil so ist das voll die Marke.
Und wahrscheinlich würdet ihr, ich denke es war ihr, mit der AfD koalieren.
Wahrscheinlich, das ist einfacher als mit Grün.
Ja, aber guck mal, das ist doch genau dieser, also ich sag noch mal ein Medientheater. Er gaukelt jetzt dem Ben gerade so sehr vor, dass es diese All-Girls-Alliance wie im Big Brother-Haus geben könnte, weil wir müssten doch alle nur auf unsere Eigenschaft schauen, wir sind alle Frauen, jetzt verbinden wir uns mal gegen die Männer. Das kam noch nie dazu. In 50 Jahren dieser Fernsehgeschichte kam es nicht dazu. So dass der Ben sogar mit, na ich sag jetzt mal ihr, also er geht genau in diese Homogenitätsfallerei.
Ja, das ist in dieser Homogenität natürlich nicht, aber was wir hier sehen können, dieser Schulterschluss ist gar nicht etwas, wovor zurückgeschreckt wird. Dann habe ich mir weiter was angesehen. Es gibt einen Kanal, der heißt Ein Gullan. Da ist eine junge Frau, die geht durch die Stadt und macht dort Umfragen. Sie war dann auch in Frankfurt und ist dann mit diesem anderen merkwürdigen Menschen darum gelaufen. Achim Winter, der auch so. Also wir sind jetzt hier im rechten YouTube, sind wir da unterwegs. Der war früher beim ZDF und macht jetzt die ganze Zeit gegen die Wolken und die ganzen Messermänner und so etwas. Ja, genau, wie Peter Hane nur eben auf der Straße mit Umfragen. Den hören wir aber jetzt nicht, sondern wir hören sie. Und was wir vorfinden, dass jetzt nur ein Beispiel für unglaublich viele solcher Kanäle ist, dass man versucht, AfD-Positionen eigentlich von Migranten vertreten zu lassen. Und man findet auch welche dafür. Jetzt will ich auch hier sagen, das ist nicht repräsentativ. Man sieht nun dann an Kommentaren, an Äußerungen und so etwas, dass es durchaus ein Phänomen ist. Ich glaube nicht nur, dass es gesucht wurde, um da einen Clip draus zu machen, sondern wir haben es hier mit einem größeren Problem zu tun. Ich meine ja, wenn wir uns um den Aufstieg der AfD sorgen, müssen wir das in den Blick nehmen. Also hier mal ein Beispiel.
Das Migrationsproblem beziehungsweise...
Ja, es ist viel stärker geworden. Also ich finde, wir haben in Deutschland schon recht viele Ausländer, die das auch ausnutzen und nicht arbeiten, und nur das Geld vom Staat nehmen.
Und wo kommst du her? Du siehst ja auch nicht typisch deutsch aus, wenn man das so sagen darf.
Gesichert rechtsextremistisch.
Also meine Eltern kommen ursprünglich aus dem Iran, aus Tebris. Ich bin aber in Bayern geboren. Also mein Vater ist damals aus dem Krieg geflüchtet, von dem Iran aus nach Türkei und von der Türkei aus nach Bayern. Es war für ihn etwas schwer, weil es ja eine neue Welt für ihn war. Aber er hat sich daran gewöhnt, dann kam meine Mutter und sieh dem jetzt normal in der Stadt.
Ja, guck mal, wir haben einen jungen Mann mit Apple-Kopfhörern, das ist ja das Erkennungszeichen für und so weiter. Boss-T-Shirt. Durchtrainiert Boss-T-Shirt und so. Also wenn ich jetzt ein alter Boomer-Mann wäre, würde ich mich fürchten. Denn solche Leute können die AfD auch übernehmen irgendwann perspektivisch.
Ja, aber jetzt wollen wir mal bei dem, was wir hier feststellen können.
Wir haben gesehen, wie fluide die AfD ist. Die ist, die bewegt sich in jeder Richtung.
Aber du siehst hier, Sozialstaat ist auch da als Problem identifiziert. Menschen, die hier ohne zu arbeiten, auf Kosten von, das ist genau dieser Sozialdarwinismus, den wir dann dort vorfinden und der da sehr stark ausgeprägt ist. Anderes Beispiel in Frankfurt jetzt.
AfD ist stärkste Kraft, was haltet ihr davon?
Super.
Es geht, wenn man ehrlich ist, schon schwierig.
Aber du findest super?
Ich finde das super ehrlich.
Aber warum? Also, Begründe gerne?
Ich habe ja quasi Migrationshintergrund, aber ich fühle mich quasi als Deutscher. Ich habe auch schon lange hier.
Aber deine Forstkraft aktivist auch mit abgeschoben, ne?
Wird schon mal erwähnt. Nein, das stimmt jetzt nicht so. Aber ich finde es gut, dass jemand mal endlich was macht, in diesem Land was bewegen möchte und dass sie halt wieder zur normalen alten Zeit zurückkehren.
Ja, die normale alte Zeit. Also ich habe immer noch vor Augen dieses eine Bild, wie jemand im Hai-Tiana-für-Trump-T-Shirt von Eis abgeführt wird.
Ja.
Also so schaufelt man wirklich sein eigenes Graf. Da gibt es auch keine Aufklärung in irgendwelche Richtungen.
Das ist ein ganz, ganz großes Problem. Ich sage das ja, ich sage das. Das sind also zwei Kumpels, die sich uneins sind. Der andere eigentlich gegen die AfD beschwichtigt aber dann doch noch mal so. Das ist jetzt der letzte Clip.
Ja, weil es gibt ja das Gerücht, dass die AfD ja alle auf Sender rausschmeißen will.
Das stimmt ja nicht, aber wo kommt das dann her?
Durch die Allgemeinerung würde ich mal sagen. Das fängt halt schon im kleinen Auf an, also schon im Grundschulalter. Damals, wo ich in der Grundschule war, wurde mir auch schon erzählt, dass wenn man die AfD wählt, dass alle ausländer rausgehen, sehr rechtsradikal sind. Aber es gibt Vor- und Nachteile. Jede Partei hat Vor- und Nachteile. Man muss für sich selber es bewichten können. Und wenn man sich da angezogen fühlt, man Sinn dahin sieht, dann natürlich dafür einzusetzen.
Du findest es aber okay, wenn jemand sich dafür entscheidet.
Ich akzeptiere alles. Ich bin offen. Nur wer war wirklich toxisch?
Ich fahre Mercedes und er fährt BMW.
Ich sehe, ich sehe.
Aber dann bin ich bei dir.
Ich muss dich auch BMW-Fan leider.
BMW ist da bei Mercedes.
Ja, passt doch.
Ja, also alle suchen ihre Identität. Sie wollen hier ankommen. Genau, der Stimmungswind ist, hier droht eine rassistische Partei nicht Deutsche auszusortieren. Also was macht man? Man fährt Mercedes, geht ins Fitnessstudio, kauft sich Apple-Kopfhörer, weil das irgendwie die Erkennungszeichen sind. Nur am Ende wird halt diese Politik, und das ist das Interessante, weil du jetzt, also weil wir so sehr auf diesen Sozialdarwinismus, auf so eine ökonomische Grundlage, diese ökonomische Grundlage sehen wir ja, ist diesen Parteien am Ende egal im Amt.
Das wissen wir.
Das sehen wir bei Millay, das sehen wir bei Trump, das sehen wir überall.
Ja, ich hab das ja versucht bei Ben auch klar zu machen. Es ist aber nicht leicht, sag ich mal, dass das gehört wird, weil sie darüber nicht sprechen wollen. Wir werden ja heute, nicht dass man uns auf den Vorwurf wacht, ihr redet ja auch nur darüber, nein, wir werden heute noch gar nicht lange über Wirtschaft, den Standort Deutschland, all das sprechen. Was wir hier erleben können, ist aber auch eine enorme Verharmlosung, die damit dann hergeht, indem man sagt, ja gut, ich bin offen, du hast deine Meinung, ich habe meine Meinung, du fährst BMW, ich Mercedes, so wie die darüber reden. Das ist das große Problem. Oder sagen wir ein weiteres großes Problem, das wir nicht unterbelichtet lassen sollten.
Nein, gar nicht. Das Problem ist allerdings so ein bisschen, und jetzt wird es tricky. Man sagt ja immer, die AfD könnte man nicht entzaubern. Wir kommen aber langsam so sehr in die Ecke gedrängt, dass sie sich entzaubern muss. Denn diese Leute lassen sich, so wie viele, nur noch von Realität beeindrucken und nicht mehr von Medienspektakel. Diese beiden Herren, die wir da sehen, deren ganzes Leben in Deutschland profitiert davon, dass es politische Bemühungen gibt, die AfD zurückzudrängen. Das nehmen die aber nicht wahr. Und das hat man ja immer wieder, wie auch im Feminismus, das ist dann irgendwann die dritte Generation, das so als so selbstverständlich, dass man sich schon wieder lustig machen kann über Alice Schwarzer. Oder beim Thema schwules Leben in Ostdeutschland erkämpft nach der Wende gegen Baseballschläger und so weiter. Und heute so wie war es keine Ahnung, ach ja, okay. So, ja und ja, es ist halt die Realität auf der Straße. Irgendwann fällt halt dieser Schutzschirm weg. Das droht ja jetzt in Sachsen-Anhalt und dann Mecklenburg-Vorpommern und so. Und dann haben wir ja da das, was Arne Semsrott beschreibt. Und bei der Veranstaltung, bei der du warst, ich wollte es nochmal kurz erwähnen, die ich ja verpasst habe, als du hier im Städel warst. Genau, ein Monat später war Heinz Bude da und die Kulturirgendwas Ministerin aus Baden-Württemberg. Und die hat das kurz beschrieben. Also im Städel selbst macht sie diese Aufklärung zum Thema, die Museen kommen immer auf uns zu und wir als Staat fördern ja auch Kunst und so weiter. Deswegen haben wir hier sehr große Budgets, mehrere Millionen Euro. Und dann kriegen wir Anträge, bislang haben wir sie immer bewilligt, aber jetzt erkläre ich Ihnen kurz, wie diese Bewilligung abläuft. Ich nehme diese Zettel, ich gehe als eine Person zu einer anderen Person, dem Ministerpräsidenten, dann reden wir darüber und machen grünen Haken dran. Wenn einer von uns beiden von der AfD ist, kommt da nirgendwo mehr ein Haken dran. Und dann ist von jetzt auf gleich, fried man so ganz verwundert, wie, was, können Sie das noch mal sagen? Also so läuft das. Gibt es da kein Gremium, gibt es da keine demokratischen Prozesse oder was auch immer. Und sie so, nein, ich sage Ihnen das, um Sie zu warnen. Also wenn ich hier nicht mehr regiere in diesem Posten, sondern irgendwann dann der AfD da sitzt, dann kriegt es hier für kein Museum mehr Geld. Und alle so, wie, warte mal, wir sind doch hier gerade in so einem Museum und so.
Ja, das ist völlig richtig. Ich weiß das auch aus Rheinland-Pfalz von Menschen.
Die werden sofort abgeschoben. Also da kommt ein Eiswagen und sammelt die ein für die AfD.
Die sich für Förderungen bewerben, für Festivals und so etwas. Und das funktioniert quasi mit Handschlag. Und anders nicht. Und wenn man den Handschlag nicht mehr bekommt, bekommt man nicht. Aber da würde ich jetzt doch noch einhaken, weil du das jetzt gerade sagst, wenn die AfD regiert werden, die da alle abgeschoben. Ich bin mir, also ich will ja nicht hier sitzen und die AfD verharmlosen, aber ich bin mir bei genau dieser Sache zunächst einmal nicht sicher. Denn was wir eigentlich erleben können bei diversen rechten Strömungen ist, dass es durchaus dank dieses Sozialdarwinismus, dank des Sozialdarwinismus noch mal eine andere Einsortierung gibt. Dass nämlich dann gesagt wird, ja, aber die haben ja einen deutschen Pass. Oder ja, die aber haben ja die Funktion in der Wirtschaft und deswegen werden sie nicht abgeschoben, deshalb werden sie nicht drangsaliert. Und das ist ja etwas, wonach jetzt so ein Salim Samato oder auch diese beiden Herren eigentlich rufen. Sie wollen ja für sich, weil sie hier gut angekommen sind und erfolgreich sind, eine bessere Behandlung haben. Sie wollen das Privileg haben, quasi auch das erste Klasseticket, das alle Deutschen haben, aber die anderen dann bitte nicht. Da soll man dann mit besonderer Brutalität vorgehen. Und was ich befürchte ist, dass wir einen sehr bunt schäckigen Faschismus bekommen, wenn wir ihn bekommen. Und dass wir das nicht so sehr mit dieser alten Homogenität verwechseln sollten. Denn auch andere europäische rechte Parteien haben eine erstaunliche Heterogenität, die aber zugleich auch rassistisch, aber eben sehr häufig über den Sozialdavinismus funktioniert.
Die AfD ist als nationalstaatsdavinistische Partei gestartet, die Deutschland aus dem Euro-Geflecht ausheben wollte. Das war vor 15 Jahren oder vor 14, 13. Jetzt gerade ist die AfD Höcke.
Die AfD ist gerade auch sehr stark Weidel.
Ja, kann sein, dass man, wenn man diese Leute nach Stuttgart schickt, dass sie da nicht abgeschoben werden. Aber wenn sie irgendwo anders werden als im Südwesten und die AfD regiert.
Die sind für Höcke ein Feindbild.
Genau, das werden sie immer bleiben.
Sind sie für Alice Weidel eines? Das ist die Frage.
Also Höcke kriegen die nicht umgewädelt.
Ja, aber die Frage ist ja, welche Zukunft wird der Höcke in der Partei haben?
Aber das sind ja die allgemeinen Richtungsstreits in der AfD. Die gerade sehr leichtfertig sind im Schicksal.
Wenn wir jetzt mal ganz kühn sind und uns vorstellen, wie jetzt eine Koalition geartet sein könnte, eine blau-schwarze oder schwarz-blaue, dann wissen wir ja, dass darin der Höcke-Flüge nicht stark sein könnte. Also bei allem, was man der CDU so zutraut, wäre das jetzt auch nicht denkbar.
Also ich komme gerade wieder aus einem Besuch in Jena zurück und ich sag dir...
Also ich rede von der Bundes-CDU. Du kannst mir natürlich da...
Im Thüringen stellt sich diese Frage, die du aufgeworfen hast, nicht mal für die CDU.
Ja, ich hatte ja diese Filmdiskussion über diese Doku, ich weiß nicht, ob du die schon gesehen hast, Kein Land für Niemand. Nein, noch nicht. Doku über Migration und Ökonomie, sehr, sehr gut. Und hab dann auch mit dem Regisseur darüber gesprochen, mit einem der Regisseure. Und das war ganz interessant, dass die ja auch einen Clip haben von einer CDU-Politikerin, ich glaube Landreite, Nessee. Und es ist nicht zu unterscheiden, ob sich der Höckeflügel gerade geäußert hat oder die CDU-Dame, die fängt nämlich dann an, ja, das sind halt Ziegenhürden und wir brauchen schon hier Ziegenhürden. Also sowas gibt die von sich.
Von daher, Weidel sitzt irgendwo in der Schweiz und ist so auf Gnaden, weil man dann immer sagen kann, ja, die Frau ist doch jetzt nicht Hitler und so.
Also ich sehe schon die Tendenz zum Melonisierung und das sehe ich auch als Problem bei diesem Ahrens-Ding, dass Erik Ahrens sehr stark sich mit diesem Höckeflügel auseinandersetzt und mit diesen traditionell faschistischen Strömungen. Und er, glaube ich, ja auch sagt, wenn die da so weitermachen, dann muss ein Verbot her. Aber wir wissen ja, dass ein Krah schon verstanden hat, um kein Verbot zu bekommen, darf man genau diesen rein faschistischen Kurs nicht weitermachen und darf nicht unterscheiden, zum Beispiel zwischen Staatsbürgern und Staatsbürgern, egal woher sie kommen.
Aber, du weißt, wie isoliert Krah ist?
Das weiß ich nicht.
Na ja, Krah ist Immunität, der Bundestag ist erstmal wieder aufgehoben, lauter Verwerfungen.
Das ist jetzt Kaffeesatz-Sesarei, das können wir auch nicht sagen, und in drei Wochen kann alles anders sein. Aber da bin ich mir nicht so sicher. Was ich weiß, ist, dass Alice Weidel sehr beliebt ist und zunehmend auch, glaube ich, andocken kann, an manche Teile aus der CDU, CSU. Und was ich hier jetzt nur gerade sagen will zur Einführung, wir kommen ja jetzt dann dazu. Ahrens ist also der, den wir ja hier ausführlich besprochen hatten, als er vor ein paar Monaten bei Ben ungescriptet war und dort seine Genetik, Rassenideologie verbreitet hat. Jetzt präsentiert er sich beim Zentrum für politische Schönheit als Aussteiger. Ich will mal so sagen, er ist intelligent genug, um diese Argumente jetzt da gleich zu machen. Ich trau dem Braten noch nicht so ganz, könnte mir auch vorstellen, dass er in drei Monaten woanders sitzt und sagt, ich bin jetzt bei Scientology, weil das die einzige Wahrheit ist. Ich will nur sagen, für mich ist der jetzt nicht so ganz satisfaktionsfähig. Was ich aber deutlich machen will, ist, man kann sich trotzdem mit den Argumenten auseinandersetzen.
Ja, ich sag mal so, der Ahrens, wir hören das jetzt nicht, weil er uns ein Pfannkuchen-Rezept empfiehlt und wir dann feststellen, nee, er hat doch gelogen, drei Eier sind besser als vier in diesem Mehlverhältnis. Wir können, also wir kennen Ahrens, ob er uns hier eine Wahrheit sagt und aus welchen Gründen, wie auch immer, ist völlig egal. Es geht nur um so eine intrinsische Plausibilität der Argumentation, die er ja beim Zentrum für politische Schönheit im Podcast gemacht hat. Die sind ja auch nicht blöd. Also wir haben ja auch so Hinweise bekommen, wie ob man denen jetzt so das Mikrofon hinhalten muss. Und ich denke mir so, informiere ich doch nochmal, wo dieses Gespräch stattfand und so. Also das sind ja Leute, die sind so engagiert, dass sie diesen komischen Lautstärkewagen da ins Weitelsommer-Interview fahren und so. Also da ist er jetzt im Gespräch. Jetzt kann man sagen, okay, das war eine dumme Aktion und so, aber sie ist jedenfalls nicht aus Mangel an drüber Nachdenken zustande gekommen. Also überall denken jetzt viele Leute.
Was ich glaube, wir müssen jetzt auch nicht auf dieses Interview in dem Sinne eingehen, dass wir sagen, wie wurde es geführt. Aber das will ich schon noch anmerken. Sie glorifizieren Ahrens schon sehr, dass Ahrens ja selbst seine Rolle schon fast wieder bereit ist, ein bisschen runterzuspielen in der AfD. Was sie auch so nicht so richtig verstehen ist immer noch, dass sie Ahrens nach der großen Enthüllung fragen. Aber da ist ja gar nicht die große Enthüllung da. Also dass man jetzt erwarten kann, dass man von Ahrens nochmal so ganz interessantes Insiderwissen bekommt.
Das habe ich jedenfalls gar nicht bekommen. Darum geht es ja gar nicht. Ich sage jetzt mal, damit jetzt alle genau wissen, was wir jetzt genau machen. Wir hören jetzt zwei Podcasts. Das eine ist Lass uns über Politik reden von Prof. Dr. Alexander Lortz. Das ist mein Finanzminister hier in Hessen. Der war vorher Kultusminister und hat zwischenzeitlich die Kultusministerkonferenz geleitet. Ich habe ihn noch im Ohr, wie er in Berlin in der Bundespressekonferenz saßen, auf die Journalistenfrage, ist das nicht voll krass, wie Bildung in Deutschland vererbt wird. Er dann vorne als Chef der Kultusministerkonferenz sagte, ja, stimmt, vielleicht haben sie ja noch eine Idee. Also auf dem Niveau. Ich halte nicht allzu viel von ihm. Der zusammen mit Anja Schöper, ein Podcast, in dem sie Gäste einladen, sie reden dort mit Justus Bender, ein wirklich hochgeschätzter AfD-Versteher und Autor, arbeitet für die FAZ.
Also ein AfD-Experte, nicht Versteher im Sinne von, er findet die AfD gut.
Ja, ein AfD-Beobachter und Experte, genau. Und im Kontrast dazu hören wir den Podcast Zeitsturz. Der ist also vom Zentrum für politische Schönheit. Wie heißt der Chef nochmal? Ruch da oder so? Der sich immer so anmalt im Gesicht. Ich glaube jetzt leider... Philipp Ruch. Philipp Ruch. Okay, steht auch gar nicht in dem Podcast-Beschreibung drin. Na ja, gut. Also diese beiden Podcasts hören wir jetzt so ein bisschen im Wechsel, um uns darüber aufzuklären, was hat es mit diesem Rechtspopulismus auf sich? Und wir haben jetzt eine gute Vorarbeit geleistet, indem wir gesagt haben, Rassismus ist eine Methode für das eigentliche Prinzip des davinistischen Aussortierens und die Gesichtspunkte sind dann so ein bisschen offen. Ich würde sagen, damit sich so eine Mehrheitsgesellschaft in Sicherheit wiegen kann, bedienen sie sich des Rassismus, weil da einfach das so klar ist, wen man hier aussortiert. Wir taugen nichts, die kommen und uns in der Sozialkasse und so und da, ne? Ob das in der Realität entspricht, wie auch immer, Deutschland ohne Migranten kann man sich nicht vorstellen, wie auch immer, das ist alles eingepreist. Hier geht es jetzt um die intrinsischen Logiken, um mal richtig zu verstehen, was ist dieser Rechtspopulismus. Also zuerst Ahrens.
Ich glaube ja, dass Rechtsextremismus im Grunde eine Depression ist. Also ich kenne auch keine gut gelaunten Rechtsextremen zum Beispiel. Es gibt keine hoffnungsfrohen Rechtsextremen. Das gibt es alles nicht. Das ist alles immer nur Propaganda nach außen, aber das sind extrem unglückliche, autoritäre Haufen sozusagen.
Ja, ein Haufen. Was ist ein Haufen? Man weiß nicht mal, was der Unterschied von Haufen und Einzelfall ist, sondern es ist einfach völlig undefiniert eine Menge.
Und depressiv.
So, das ist das ganz Wichtige. Die haben, wenn überhaupt, eine gemeinsame Eigenschaft. Sie schauen auf die Welt und sie reagieren mit Depression. Und Depression ist sozusagen dieses allerletzte, ich habe gar kein Handlungsvermögen mehr.
Also Depression nicht im klinischen Sinne, sondern depressiongelähmt, ich weiß nicht mehr ein noch aus, wo soll ich hin mit meinem Hass?
Ängstlich, Angst vor morgen insbesondere, strukturlos, wie man halt eine Depression definiert. So, Justus Bender.
Ich glaube, es geht sehr stark vom Individuum aus und es ist sehr emotional und irrational. Also es gibt ein Merkmal, das AfD-Anhänger oft zeigen und das ist ein ungeheurer Pessimismus. Also wenn man mit Leuten zum Beispiel vom Einzbach-Institut redet, dann meinen die, das ist eigentlich das Merkmal, an dem wir die erkennen. Also das ist ja nicht so, dass das irgendwelche Hartz-IV-Empfänger aus dem Erzgebirgskreis sind, sondern das sind Leute, die haben ein Unternehmen, denen geht es gut eigentlich. Aber die haben wirklich die ganz große Sorge, dass es bergab gehen wird in Zukunft. Und wenn die darüber reden, dass das Abendland und Deutschland und Europa und alles geht in den Bach runter und Migration und Euro-Krise und Ukraine kriegen, was nicht alles, die meinen das wirklich ernst. Und wenn man davon ausgeht und dann mal mit Psychologen auch redet, dann machen die so psychologische Untersuchungen. Also die fragen Leute nach ihren Charaktereigenschaften und ordnen das so ein. Und dann fragen sie mal, und was haben sie eigentlich gewählt bei der Europawahl 2024 oder so?
Und dann ist einfach völlig klar AfD. Also es ist auch schon im klinischen Sinne, einfach die sind depressiv. AfD-Wähler sind depressiv. Jetzt sehe ich auch auf die Welt und denke mir, das kann nichts mehr werden. Also jeden Tag ist hier eine Brückenaufgang mehr gesperrt. Und statt mal was zu reparieren, wird einfach nur noch gesperrt. Und dann hört man Podcasts und hört China, Amerika, irgendwas und so. Die Welt bricht auf uns ein. Nur ich reagiere damit ja nicht mit einer Depression, weil ich noch an politische Programme glaube. Jetzt hast du ja diesen Clip gespielt. Die AfD-ler glauben noch an Politik. Das müsste man jetzt mal hinterfragen. Die Politik spielt sich noch vor, dass es angeblich Programme gäbe, wie komplette Remigration von 20 Millionen Menschen in Deutschland oder so. Nur das ist ja kein Glaube an Politik.
Nein, das ist ja einfach ein Versprechen, das bislang nicht eingelöst werden musste. Folglich können sie gut dran glauben.
Genau. Und das ist aber nicht die Definition von Politik, die wir typischerweise haben, sondern...
Während die SPD die ganze Zeit das Scheitern der Sozialdemokratie vorführt, bedeutet also, da ist nicht mehr der Traum der Sozialdemokratie da oder der Wunsch oder so etwas, während die AfD erst einmal mit dem Versprechen gestärkt überall hingehen kann, weil sie bislang noch nichts realisieren musste.
Genau. Und die SPD muss sich halt auch sehr überlegen, ob gegen eine Depression hilft, zu sagen, ja, wir haben jetzt irgendeinen Steuersatz um 3 Prozent angepasst ab 2027. Also dieses Folgenlose, wir machen irgendwas, was sich gut in den Nachrichten ankündigen lässt, aber niemand spürt irgendetwas. Man spürt sich nicht mehr. Diese Leute wollen sich gerne ritzen und so. Dann merken die, dass überhaupt noch ein bisschen Welt da ist. Und da könnte man jetzt noch mal in diesen amerikanischen Neuen Wahlkampf, also beim Dani und so, sich mal anschauen. Das passiert jetzt auch die kommenden Tage, dass einfach die Wahl stattfindet. Ahrens, kann es natürlich jetzt so ein bisschen ausführen?
Ich wollte eben, dass Deutschland und die weiße Rasse die Welt beherrscht. Oder zumindest, dass wir hier keine Menschen anderer Rasse ins Land lassen.
Wie stehst du jetzt dazu, wenn du das so sagst?
Nun, ich weiß, aus welcher Motivation ich das selbst damals sagte. Und ich weiß, dass diese Urmotivation, dieses rechte Grundgefühl eben einfach keine rationale Überzeugung war, sondern ein Gefühl und im Grunde würde ich jetzt im Nachhinein sagen, ein Symptom einer tiefsitzenden Depression. Also auch ich hatte diese Untergangsangst. Auch ich hatte diese Angst, dass diese Welt im Grunde für mich keinen Raum bietet und dass ich mir diesen Raum erstreiten muss und dass diese Welt oder irgendwelche in dieser Welt wirkenden Kräfte mich ausmerzen wollen und dass ich im Grunde eine Defensive dagegen führe. Ich fühlte mich nicht als Aggressor. Ich fühlte mich in der Defensive. Und diejenigen, die mir nun diese Defensive absprechen wollten, also die jetzt sagen, ja, das ist aber eben rassistisch oder schlecht oder böse, was du machst, die sah ich als Handlanger dieser Aggressoren.
So, ich bin sehr gespannt auf dieses Buch im Salon, denn Zerstörungslust. Jetzt sagt Ahrens aber, wir sehen uns in der Defensive. Wir sind nicht die, die was aktiv kaputt machen wollen, sondern das Kaputtmachen sieht allenfalls aus der falschen Richtung so aus, wie was kaputt machen, eigentlich sind wir die Bewahrer. Wir verteidigen etwas, also das wird noch zu bepulver sein.
Make America Great Again, er sagt ja nicht, wir zerschlagen Amerika.
Genau, und man hat jetzt so eine Vorstellung von früher war alles besser und so weiter und so fort. Und da ist es halt gerade noch so ein akademischer Diskurs, dass man die dann vorwirft, ja, wir wollen doch an morgen denken und nicht an gestern. Und dann sagen die einfach, nee, morgen ist nicht mehr, wir verteidigen jetzt das, was gestern war. So oder? Also diese Defensivhaltung. Bender, es ist, also wir kommen ganz nahe jetzt an so eine klinische Depressionsdefinition in Sachen, was sind so therapeutische Gegenmaßnahmen.
Und dann kommt auch raus, dass AfD-Wähler unglaublich einen starken Ordnungstrang haben. Also sie, vielstärke Unionswähler haben das auch ein bisschen, aber weit nicht so stark wie AfD-Wähler. Und anders als Unionswähler haben sie eine ganz starke Empfänglichkeit für Ängste und Psychologen nennen das dann Neurotizismus. Also wenn man denen erzählt, übrigens hier kommen jetzt so ein paar hunderttausend Leute aus Afrika, wissen nicht genau wer, wir lassen die einfach mal rein oder so. Manche Leute sagen dann, das kann interessant werden und es belebt die deutsche Gastronomie oder was auch immer. Und andere, die eben so sind, entwickeln dann ungeheure Ängste. Und es beleidigt sozusagen ihren Ordnungs-Sinnen, dass da was unkontrolliert an der Grenze passiert und so. Und so kann man daher kommen quasi ein bisschen erklären, wie das zustande kommt, dass eben in anderen Zeiten, die nicht so krisenbehaftet sind wie unsere, gibt es auch immer Leute, die sehr angstemfänglich sind, aber die verstreuen sich dann irgendwie oder die beteiligen sich nicht so an der Politik oder die sind mal hier, mal dort oder waren vielleicht früher in der Friedensbewegung oder so. Und jetzt heute versammelt diese AfD sehr stark solche Leute und macht denen das ganz konkrete Versprechen, sie auch von ihrer emotionalen Last zu befreien.
Also diese Vorstellung von Nationalismus, die da mobilisiert wird, hat ja ganz viel mit diesem Ordnung, wo kann ich meine Ordnung verankern? Ah, Nationalstaat. Und das begegnet uns in ganz vielen anderen Diskussionen. Wie zum Beispiel Ole bekommt diese Frage von dieser Bosetti, wann bist du bereit deine Heimat zu verteidigen? Und Ole so, wieso verteidigen? Naja, aus Sympathie, mit wem soll ich sympathisieren und so weiter. Also dieses Clash auf wirklich nicht nur Culture, sondern grundlegende Paradigmen. Auf die Frage hin, wann würdest du mit Waffengewalt deine Heimat verteidigen? Da könnte man ja genauso gut sagen, ich als Frankfurter würde niemals auf einen Offenbacher schießen. Und dann würden die in der ARD und im ZDF und in allen scheiß Podcasts sofort sagen, es geht doch nicht darum, auf Offenbacher zu schießen, sondern auf, ja was denn, naja, die aus anderen Ländern.
Franzosen? Nee, Franzosen nicht mehr.
Genau, jetzt Franzosen nicht mehr. Also das, was der Ben da hier beschreibt und der Ulrich, wie heißt der von der Zeit?
Ulrich?
Nein.
Ulrich, Dingsabums, Bernd Ulrich, so Bernd Ulrich. Der damals, als die AfD 17 Prozent hatte, also geschrieben, oder 15 Prozent, bei der Bundestagswahl, ich glaube 2017 oder so, meint er so, hm, steckt nicht in jedem von uns so 15 Prozent AfD und bei diesem Wehrpflichtsdiskurs im Sinne von, wann würdest du hier, auf wen schießen, und dass man gar nicht darüber redet, auf wen zu schießen ist, sondern völlig klar ist, auf die verhassten Russen. So, ja. Da muss man sagen, ja, ihr müsst euch selbst hinterfragen, nicht immer nur über AfD-Leute reden und so, sondern fragt mal bei euch selber nach, wo stecken eure 15 Prozent AfD? Und wenn es mal 30 Prozent sind in Deutschland, ist das dieselbe Frage. Wo stecken die 30 Prozent AfD in dir, die das ermöglichen?
Ja, und das ist ja so erstaunlich, wirklich bei dieser Werbpflichtsdiskussion, dass man sagt, ja, das ist selbstverständlich, dass man sich mit der Nation so sehr identifiziert. Aber wenn ich das tue, da muss ich ja konsequent auch sagen, genau, da muss ich die Nation auch laufen schützen. Vor Flüchtlingen zum Beispiel. Ja, also das liegt ja eigentlich sehr nah beieinander. Deswegen erleben wir für mich die interessanteste Querfront aller Zeiten. Also die Querfront, die wir ja lange Zeit diskutiert haben, war jetzt im Querdenkerlager und Wagenknecht und weiß ich nicht, wer ist an der Seite von Höcke. Aber interessant ist ja eigentlich diese Querfront, ich würde es mal in der Eiferei halber sagen, fast auch dann alphabetisch gut zwischen Anne Will und Ali Smeidl in Bezug auf die Werbpflicht und auf die Aufrüstung.
Genau, also in allgemeinen Diskussionen ja immer daran denken, Ordnungstrang und Angst, egal was für Fragen kommen, wie zum Beispiel zum Thema Werbdienst, immer zurückfragen, also fast therapeutisch so, liebe Frau Bosetti, warum haben Sie solche Angst vor den anderen? Und warum ist Ihr Ordnungsrahmen der Nationalstaaten? Sollten wir das nicht mal nochmal besprechen so? Ich dachte, wir sind weiter, also einfach direkt auskontern. So, Ahrens hat eine sehr schöne Analogie. Er redet vom Meeresgrund. Ich finde jetzt das sehr plausibel, ja.
Also die AfD macht das besser, was eben der der Sumpf oder der Meeresgrund besser macht, also Dinge fallen nach unten und die AfD ist sozusagen ganz unten und fängt die Dinge auf. Also in dem Maße, wie die Gesellschaft sich desintegriert und immer mehr Leute abgehängt sind und immer mehr Leute depressiv werden, sammeln sie sich bei der AfD.
Völlig richtig, völlig richtig. Ich will auch nochmal hier betonen, dass mich das enorm geärgert hat während der Ampelzeit, hat man die Rezession geleugnet. Immer wieder gesagt, na ja, aber ganz zur Stimme sieht es nicht aus. Außerdem gibt es ja schon da einen Hoffnungsschimmer. Wir werden gleich sehen, wie dramatisch die Zahlen sind und wie lange sie es schon sind. Das heißt, da ist schon ganz viel nach unten weiter gefallen und denen, die da fielen, hat man noch von oben zugerufen, nein, nein, das ist alles gar nicht so. Und die AfD muss nur da sitzen und die Hände aufhalten.
Genau, also früher hieß es, du kannst nicht tiefer fallen als in Gottes Hände und heute bist du natürlich gottlos und fällst auf das unentdeckte Land Meeresgrund. Also sagen wir immer, wir kennen mehr von der Mondoberfläche als vom Meeresgrund. Also da fallen wir gerade hin und allein, weil der Meeresgrund halt da ist, so funktioniert dieses Prinzip.
Also, was man auch noch mal gut auf unsere Migrationsthematik, die wir eben angesprochen haben, also Migranten, die durchaus mit der AfD was anfangen können, da können wir das auch dann finden. Die erleben dann auch ständig Dysfunktionales, fallen also auch nach unten und erwartet die AfD.
Genau, niemand ist näher Meeresgrund als Migranten in Deutschland. Also das ist ja nun von daher hier nur kurze Zäsur im Sinne von, wenn das, was wir bisher gehört haben von Wenda und Ahrens so stimmt, und ich finde, es ist sehr plausibel, dann müssen wir uns wirklich darauf einstellen, dass die AfD hier 30, 35 Prozent in den nächsten Jahrzehnten holt. Also das ist einfach ein Phänomen, das für immer bleibt und es sich noch, also einige Potenziale hat, ausgebaut zu werden.
Zumindest länger bleibt.
Nun hat man ja auch ein bisschen mit Realität zu tun. Bender erklärt mal, Trump ist ja wirklich da von Leuten, die sozusagen auf den Meeresgrund warten durch dieses, was sind das hier, ich sinker irgendwie ein, keine Ahnung, Orientierung suchen. Die haben jetzt alle Trump gewählt.
Also wir können jetzt immer Trump auch mal nehmen als natürlich ganz andere Situation. Aber es ist ja so ein bisschen ein Beispiel für eine rechtspopulistische Regierung. Und ich kann da jetzt nicht erkennen, dass Amerika jetzt geordneter wäre, sondern das ist Chaos, das ist ständige Unbeständigkeit. Man weiß nie, was morgen ist und Krieg und Frieden und Krise und Zölle und was nicht alles. Also genau, das ist ein Widerspruch, der ja aber vor allem auf der rationalen Ebene besteht. Also wo man dann auf Leute einreden würde, seht ihr denn nicht, jemand denkt doch mal nach, das macht doch keinen Sinn, alles. Und ich verstehe das immer. Also auf mich würde das auch Eindruck machen, so ein rationales Argument. Aber ich glaube, das ist ein bisschen so, wie wenn jemand, der wirklich Höhenangst hat und wirklich gerade eine Panikreaktion hat und der soll in die Seilbahn steigen und auf 3000 Meter hochfahren, wenn man dem sagt, du guck dir doch mal die Stahlseile an, wir haben das mal durchrechnen lassen von Ingenieuren, du musst dir wirklich überhaupt keine Sorgen, man guckt mal Zuglast, fünf Tonnen, was weiß ich. Das funktioniert nicht, das ist einfach eine andere Ebene, das ist Ratio und Irrationalität. So erkläre ich es mir, ist das, wenn man auf AfD Leute einredet, mit diesen ganzen Faktenchecks und ganzen Argumenten. Funktioniert nicht.
Wir haben dafür ein kollektives Beispiel, der Brexit. Der Brexit ist jetzt zehn Jahre her, fast. Die Briten machen das einfach als Tabu. Neuschwerferage so stark wie nie. Alte Parteien aussatiert, das ganze Land auf links gekrempelt, Armut, Sonderesgleichen, Gesundheitssystem nicht mehr der Rede wert. Aber es wird auf gar keinen Fall über den Brexit geredet. Einfach ausgeschwiegenes Thema.
Naja, wir haben das ja jetzt letztes Mal gehabt mit den vielen Migranten, die aus afrikanischen Ländern gekommen sind aufgrund des Brexits.
Die dann wieder nachgearbeitet werden muss, Widerstimmungsverschwankungen und so weiter. Also es ist diese Idee von Deutschland ist ein leichter Land der Dichter und Denker und wenn das hier ökonomisch den Bach runtergeht, kriegen wir das irgendwie aufgeklärt. So wird nicht passieren. Also da kann man schon mal große Angst vor haben.
Warum ist das so? Warum ist nicht die SPD der Meeresgrund?
Ja, dieselbe Frage eben jetzt. Warum macht die SPD ja keine Aufklärung an Ahrens? Warum schafft sie das nicht? Ökonomische Stabilität und so weiter.
Weil die Menschen, wenn es ihnen schlecht geht, nicht zu einer Lösung tendieren, sondern zu einer Reflexhaltung und sozusagen nicht diese, könnte man jetzt sagen, vernünftige Option der Solidarität.
Die AfD wird verkörpert in der Haltung?
Nicht die vernünftige Haltung der Solidarität und der sozusagen rationalen Betrachtung gesellschaftlicher Zusammenhänge wählen, wo man dann sagen könnte, okay, es geht uns schlechter aufgrund vielleicht von Ungleichverteilungen. Und da müsste man dann strukturell gegen vorgehen. Das macht eben der Intellektuelle, der nicht persönlich davon betroffen ist jetzt. Aber die meisten Menschen, wenn es denen schlechter geht, dann reagieren sie eben, wie der Mensch als Tier in der Savanne reagiert, wenn er eine Bedrohung sieht. Er hebt den Sperr auf und geht in eine aggressiv kämpferische Verteidigungshaltung gegen den Fremden, der als Bedrohung wahrgenommen wird. Ich denke, es ist halt ein atavistischer, naturwüchsiger Reflex.
Das kann ich auch gut nachvollziehen. Vor allem merkt man da auch nochmal, wie wichtig es ist, das so einzuordnen, wenn wieder Leute ankommen und sagen, das Ökonomische spielt oft gar keine Rolle. Ich hatte das jetzt auch kürzlich nochmal, dass ich so einen Vortrag hörte von jemanden, der sich mit Rechtsextremismus beschäftigte, der dann sagte, nein, es ist immer der autoritäre Charakter. Und dann denkt man aber, ja, es gibt diesen autoritären Charakter und das scheint auch ein ganz starkes Phänomen zu sein. Aber das Ökonomische ist ja davon nicht losgelöst. Die Sache ist nur, die, die ökonomisch fallen oder davor stehen zu fallen, werden sich ja über ihre ökonomische Lage oft nicht in der Weise bewusst, dass sie sagen, ach so, das liegt wohl an den Mieten, dem Neoliberalismus, der SPD, die nicht geliefert hat, die doch eigentlich sich besinnen müsste auf bla bla bla, sondern das wird genau dann nicht mehr weiter analysiert, wie die Briten auch nicht ihre ökonomische Lage bereit waren zu analysieren. Und dann ist dieser Autoritarismus als Angebot da und den nehmen sie. Und wenn sie dann in Umfragen gefragt werden, dann sagen sie irgendwas von, ich brauche eine starke Führungsperson oder wir brauchen eine starke Führungsperson. Und sie reden dann nicht über die Ökonomie. Das heißt aber nicht, dass die Ökonomie irrelevant ist, sondern sie ist eigentlich so präsent, um bei dem Meer zu bleiben. Es ist wie der Fisch im Meer, der gar nicht mehr darüber nachdenkt, dass er im Wasser ist.
Ja.
Also ich will jetzt kein Marxist werden und so, ne?
Nein, um Gottes Willen. Der Freund wird dich ja vorbewaren, nein. Also das ist ja eigentlich mein großes Projekt innerhalb dieser zehn Jahre.
Aber sehr viele Sachen, Dicht zum Marxismus zu ziehen. Auf halbem Wege, so halb geschafft. Wir haben diese Themen jetzt hier, Rassismus, wie wir das beschrieben, dann kann man irgendwelche Leute sagen, der Ahrens ist aber, ist ja wirklich ein Aussteiger, wie auch immer. Das sind alles sekundäre Fragestellungen. Primär, wenn man jetzt dieser Marxistischen These folgt, also primär ist einfach, haut das Ökonomische hin. Wenn ich diese These jetzt mal anhänge, aus sehr plausiblen Gründen, wir haben in Amerika diesen Präsidenten, der so lebt, wie sich arme Leute in Reichen vorstellen. Er ist also stellvertretend für sie reich. So auf so eine ganz vulgären Art und Weise.
So wie die Geissens hier.
Genau. Und diejenigen, die das nur aus Zuschauer-Sicht erleben, aber damit sympathisieren, sind in diese Problemlage, die Donald Trump nicht hat, emotional involviert. Und das ist das Signalwort für alle therapeutischen Versuche, jemanden, der emotional involviert ist, der kann sich nie selber am Schopfe daraus ziehen, sondern der braucht dann Hilfe. Und wenn diese Hilfe nicht da ist, dann kann man noch so klug das durchschauen, dann ist es einfach wie es ist. Und das haben wir hier gerade politisch.
Jetzt hast du das so schön ausgeführt und wir sind hier ganz im therapeutischen Bereich. Ich werde ja, wenn ich bei Podiumsdiskussionen immer gefragt, was kann man denn tun, dann sage ich immer, gut ist regional etwas zu tun. Die Sportvereine, die Jugendzentren, also überall dort, wo Sozialität stattfindet, kann das Rechte nicht funktionieren. Beziehungsweise wir sehen ja jetzt diese große Gefahr, dass das alles mal abgebaut wurde. Kommen die Rechten und sagen, wir machen jetzt ein Familienfest und hier kriegt jeder gratis eine Bratwurst. Dadurch bekommen die jetzt wieder Zulauf. Also das ist das eine. Ja, wir können aber ja noch mal, jetzt wenn wir in dem Therapeutischen schon sind, so weit gehen, dass man eigentlich sagen müsste, wir haben so ein Haustürwahlkampf jetzt erfolgreich gesehen bei den Linken oder auch bei der Petition Deutsche Wohnen und Co. enteignen. Eigentlich müsste man so Therapeuten haben, die an die Tür klopfen und sagen, wir machen mal ein Gesprächsangebot. Ich meine, wir können uns einmal die Woche oder wie sie wollen unterhalten. Wir sind dann da, so ganz allgemein mal gesprochen. Also ich weiß, das ist jetzt schwierig umzusetzen. Man braucht auch wirklich sehr viel Manpower dafür.
Wir können es beziffern.
Aber das ist eigentlich der Punkt, ne?
Also damals schon bei Obama war einfach klar, pro Bundesstaat sind hier 50 bis 80.000 Leute sozusagen auf der Straße und führen Gespräche. Naja, die werden so angeschrieben von der Kampagne. Und dann heißt es, wir haben sie identifiziert. Wir wissen, dass sie schon Obama-Freund sind, aber drüben wohnt im Haus 17 jemand und so weiter. Und dann führt man dieses eine Gespräch. Der Mamdani war jetzt in der Daily Show bei…
Aber hier reicht ja nicht ein Gespräch bei Leuten, die emotional so verringert sind. Das ist ja das Schwierige daran.
Aber das Faszinosum ist ja, weil du jetzt so gesagt hast, das Lokale. Leute reden ja derzeit über Innenstädte, als wären sie da die ganze Zeit. Aber die Straße, über die sie selber jeden Tag fünfmal gehen, also pro Jahr 70.000 Mal, so, die ist ihnen völlig egal. So, über die reden sie nie. So, der Mamdani war jetzt bei John Stewart und erzählt dort so, und wir denken ja immer das große TikTok-Zeitalter der Ahrens, der Kra und so weiter. In New York haben die einfach eine Kampagne mit 80.000 Leuten, die für die Kampagne, also nicht nur angesprochene Nachbarn, sondern wirklich so richtig, das sind 80.000 Leute, die einfach in New York Wahlkampf machen. Und dann klopft er so auf den Tisch und führt so vor, wie dann 15 Sekunden warten und dann ein Gespräch führen über Mamdani. So, und dann beschreibt er dieses Prinzip. Hier geht es nicht darum, Wähler zu gewinnen, sondern die Coalition zusammenzustellen, mit denen man später die versprochene Politik auch wirklich macht. Von der nämlich immer heißt, nee, also in diesen Institutionen kriegst du das nie. Und wir haben ja bei Trump gesehen, der bringt einfach seine eigene Institution mit und baut die Alten ab. Also wird einfach ein kompletter bis hin zu Teardown the White House gemacht. Also das ist das halbe Gebäude einfach. Jetzt hätte er sprengen müssen, das wäre noch cool gewesen. Dann damit so ein Bagger das so verschämt zu machen. Und dann kommt da ein Ballroom hin. Und so kann man natürlich Politik mal wirklich ganz neu denken. Also im Sinne von hier diese Meeresboden-Ideologie, dass man wirklich dieses train the swamp, also einfach so einen ganzen Meeresboden mal abpumpt und da mal wirklich dann sieht, was da so los ist.
Wir alle kennen das doch, wenn wir in der Innenstadt sind, haben wir doch keine Möglichkeit, irgendetwas zu machen gratis. Wir können uns einen Kaffee in ein Restaurant einbegeben, in eine Fastfood-Kette. Wir haben gleichförmige Innenstädte, die immer mehr verweisen, weil die Leute online bestellen, was auch grundsätzlich nicht schlimm ist. Nämlich, es war nie so, dass man sagen musste, eine Innenstadt braucht 15 Deko-Shops oder irgendetwas. Warum soll es das in der Innenstadt geben? Wie könnte eigentlich die Innenstadt anders aufgebaut werden? Es gab ja dann im Zuge der Lockdown so große Überlegungen, wie müssen wir die Innenstadt neu denken? Ist ja nichts von geblieben im Prinzip, bis auf ein paar regionale Projekte. Bedeutet also, diese Innenstadt ist eigentlich eine, die die ganze Zeit Menschen produziert, die auf den Meeresgrund fallen, weil nur wenige, da irrt ihr auch, ich hab David Precht, nur wenige das Geld haben, um diese modernistische Konsum-Subjektivität hervorzubringen. Das sind Leute, die verdienen 5000 und mehr, die können shoppen gehen und sagen, Mensch, war wieder ein toller Tag in der Stadt. Und für die anderen ist die Frage, wenn ich jetzt hier bei McDonalds was esse, dann kann ich aber nachher nicht noch mir hinten einen Kaffee leisten, also was mache ich? Das ist die Frage, die sich stellt. Und vielleicht kann auch jemand zu H&M was kaufen gehen und das war's.
Also wenn die Zahlen stimmen von Scott Galloway, dann ist jetzt in Amerika 50 Prozent des Alltagskonsumens von zehn Prozent der Leuten gemacht.
Ja, das halte ich für plausibel.
Nur noch die Upperclass ist so in der Innenstadt. Und ich habe es gestern für Frankfurt mal für einen Text auf meiner Seite kurz nachgerechnet, natürlich mit KI-Hilfe und so. Aber in Frankfurt gibt es 330.000 Mietwohnungen und wir kennen ja die Mietpreise und so. Das heißt, in Frankfurt wird jedes Jahr ein Betrag von 5 Milliarden Euro mobilisiert, nur damit hier gewohnt werden kann. Und für den Einzelhandel sind es nochmal 6 Milliarden. Also allein Wohnen, dass Leute anwesend sind und Einzelhandel, dass sie sich versorgen, sind schon 11 Milliarden. Ich würde jetzt wie in der Stadt in Frankfurt nochmal das Doppelte drauflegen für so Elefants und so. Das heißt, diese Stadt pumpt einfach jedes Jahr 20 Milliarden durch und das sieht man ihr aber nicht an. Also es gibt so ein paar Hochhäuser, die machen aus Panorama, so aus der Ferne macht das Sinn und sieht schön aus. Aber im Grunde lebt jeder vor sich hin mit 3,80 Euro am Tag und so. Das ist im Grunde das Stadtbild Frankfurt am Main. Also es gibt unendlich viel eigentlich mal zu machen. Und klar, man könnte dann die Gegenrechnung, das ist natürlich dann aufwendige Recherche, diese 10 Milliarden, die also nicht pro Tag pro Nase einfach gleichmäßig verteilt irgendwo ausgegeben werden, also mit denen in Japan Ski gefahren wird und in Neuseeland einen Bunker gebaut und so weiter und so fort. Warum ist das Geld dort? Warum ist das nicht einfach hier in der Stadt? So, und das generiert Meeresgrund. Und jetzt schaut natürlich keiner so ins Detail auf die Lebenswelt, auf die Straße vor der eigenen Haustür, sondern wir haben nur noch ideologische Großwetterlagen. Und da macht man zwar noch namentliche Unterschiede, aber wir hören das jetzt hier mal und überlegen uns so ein bisschen, was war nochmal der Unterschied zwischen Hardcore, sächsische Schweiz, Nazis und irgendwelchen Salafisten beim IS?
Das heißt, ich glaube nicht, dass diese rechten Parteien also ursächlich dafür verantwortlich sind, dass junge Männer nach rechts rücken, sondern ich glaube, dass sie das im Grunde einfach abgrasen, ein Potenzial, was sowieso in der Luft liegt. Und warum das ausgerechnet jetzt heute in der Luft liegt, ich glaube, das war nie weg. Ich glaube, das wird nur durch Social Media im Grunde entfesselt. Aber dieser Rechtsdruck und ein allgemeiner autoritärer Turn und der Wunsch nach festen Strukturen, nach solchen festen Konstrukten, Nationalstaaten, Imperien und Identitäten, ob in religiöser Natur oder nationaler Natur, der ist Ausdruck einer allgemeinen Verunsicherung. Und ich würde sagen, das scheinbare Gegenmittel zu dieser Depression, die das rechte Grundgefühl ist. Das rechte Grundgefühl ist, ich bin verloren in einer mir feindlichen Welt. Und die scheinbare Antwort darauf ist, ich habe eine Identität, die mich eben mit anderen zu einem starken Kollektiv verbündet, sei es nun national oder religiös. Ich denke, dass Islamismus und Rechtsextremismus im Grunde halt dasselbe Grundgefühl ausdrücken in unterschiedlichen Kulturkreisen.
Ja, also das sagt jetzt nicht nur Eric Ahrens, da gibt es gute Bücher. Wir haben das häufig hier gelesen. Der schwarze Staat oder wie auch immer. Dann diese Aufklärung über die CDU, christlich und konservativ. Wie hängt das miteinander zusammen? Von Andreas Pütmann und so. Und es ist immer wieder dasselbe. Im Grunde ist die kleine Unterscheidung zwischen die Frau ist zu Hause am Herd, kümmert sich um die Kinder, am Sonntag geht es in die Kirche und jeden Morgen im gleichen Rhythmus macht man irgendwelche Rituale. Da kann man sich dann aussuchen, ob man das unter dem Deckmantel des Mutterkreuzes oder des Salafismus oder was auch immer macht. So, das ist dann halt noch so eine kleine Geschmacksfrage. Aber im Grunde.
Franke Intensität.
Das auch, genau. Das sind dann noch so kleine Unterschiede, aber der Rest ist im Grunde gleich. Ein großes Thema, das hier besprochen wird, die Medien, denn die unmittelbare Lebenswelt Frankfurt am Main. Klar, ich sehe sie auch ab und zu im Fernsehen, wenn irgendwas mit Börsenbericht ist. Aber typischerweise erlebe ich Frankfurt durch eigene Erfahrung. Und jetzt muss man auch hinterfragen, mal die Realität der Massenmedien von Luhmann. Wir kennen die Welt, in der wir leben, aus den Massenmedien und nirgendwo sonst. Das stimmt und er macht es ja mit einer sehr klugen Argumentation, die Maßstäbe, auch wie wir im konkreten Alltag mit anderen Leuten reden und was wir beobachten, wird davon geprägt, was in den Massenmedien stattfindet. Nur wenn dann ein gigantischer Medienwandel stattfindet, also ein Redaktionsschluss, ein Aufbau von Facebook, jetzt TikTok, der ganze Kram, Wahlkampf noch bei TikTok, in Videoformen und so, dann müssten wir doch eigentlich mal, also klar, ich renne jetzt offene Türen ein, was meine Podcasts angeht und so und was wir hier besprechen, aber da müsste man doch einmal drüber reden, oder? Also das ist jetzt, sorry. Hier in dem Gespräch wird es jedenfalls auch mal gut thematisiert.
Das wirklich Ausschlaggebende in meinen Augen war das rasante Wachstum in dieser Kohorte. Du wirst das wissen. Wirklich ein hitlerisches Lauffeuer. Zwei Jahre zuvor gab es dieselbe Studie schon mal. Die Kohorte war um ein Jahr verschoben. Bei denen waren dann 17 bis 30 Jahre.
Also es gibt eben die sehr jungen Männer.
Und die da als Manifest rechtsextrem gemessen worden waren zwei Jahre davor, ein Prozent. Also in zwei Jahren von ein auf zwölf Prozent. Ich würde so weit gehen, das als den Ahrenseffekt zu bezeichnen.
Ja, das ist sicher so. Also ich war sicher in Deutschland insofern durch diese TikTok-Kampagne mit gerade Auslöser dafür, aber nicht die Ursache. Und es hätte auch vielleicht statt mir jemand anders auf diese Idee.
Was ist dann die Ursache?
Ja, also vorher auf YouTube konnte man halt einen Kanal der Hitlerreden-Posted irgendwann einfach zensieren. Aber auf TikTok kann halt jeder eine Hitlerrede hochladen und kann damit sozusagen relativ schnell viral gehen. Und wir sehen also innerhalb weniger Jahre jetzt, dass tatsächlich so um die 20 Prozent auch der Jugend halt rechtsextreme Veranlagungen haben, oder also Prägungen oder wie auch immer, aber sie sind halt irgendwie rechtsextrem.
Aber die sie, also wenn ich dich richtig verstehe, jetzt durch Social Media bekommen haben?
Die sie nicht dadurch bekommen haben, sondern die sie jetzt halt authentisch ausleben können und sich dann dafür auch nicht mehr schämen, weil sie auf TikTok halt Gleichgesinnte finden. Also wer rechtsextrem irgendwie ist, der findet auf TikTok sofort die richtige passende Wabbel und dann auch die anderen. Und man kann sich dann gegenseitig in den Kommentaren halt bestärken.
Stimmt soweit. Hier muss man die Genderfrage noch mal groß einbauen.
Und auch einbauen, dass wir jetzt gerade wieder andere Trends erleben, nämlich bei den ganz jungen Leuten, dass sie gerade nicht weiter nach rechts tendieren.
Genau. Und das wird aber getrieben über Frauen und junge Männer, die sich vielleicht dann doch auch mal an Frauen orientieren. Das ist ja auch noch ein Phänomen, dass man mal mit einpreisen muss, wenn es hier um 17 bis 30-Jährige geht. Das ist ja nun das Mating-Alter. Bender beschreibt das natürlich jetzt aus seiner Sicht. Also der, wir haben doch hier die große FAZ und so.
Das Internet, ja. Also kurz bevor die AfD aufkam, fingen auch die ältere Generation in Deutschland an, sich auf Facebook zu organisieren und den ganzen Social-Media-Kram mitzumachen.
So, das war ja schon bei Trump 1 ein ganz wichtiger Punkt. Nee, es ist nicht YouTube, es sind die Talkradio-Hörer, die alten Leute, die einfach Rush Limbaugh den ganzen Tag gehört haben.
Und war dann sozusagen an der Welt ausgesetzt, in der diese Algorithmen wirkten und diese Emotionalisierung und war eben nicht mehr in einer Position, wo einzelne Akteure in einer Debatte, die immer gleichen sind, also der Journalist, der das vollberuflich macht, steht in der Pressekonferenz und stellt dem Minister eine Frage. Und wenn der Minister am Dienstag nicht antwortet, stellt er die am Mittwoch nochmal und so. Und so entsteht auch so eine Verantwortung. Der Minister kann sich dem nicht entziehen und der Redakteur ist auch immer der gleiche. Und wenn man so einen Mob hat im Internet, so einen Shitstorm-Mob und was auch immer, dann zerfließen alle Prozesse, in denen es eine Verantwortlichkeit gibt. Also wenn der Trump heute die einen vom Kopf stößt, dann holt er sich die Unterstützung halt von den anderen. Also es sind immer wechselnde Figuren, wechselnde Verantwortlichkeiten. Und so ist jetzt sich alles zerflossen dann, was wir mal an demokratischen Strukturen hatten, die ja immer gelebt werden müssen. Also es geht ja nicht nur um Parteien oder was im Grundgesetz steht, sondern muss ja irgendwie in der Gesellschaft sowas sein. Wir diskutieren das jetzt, dann kommen wir zu einem Ergebnis und dann akzeptieren wir das auch und so. Und das ist, glaube ich, alles zusammengebrochen. Also wir müssen eigentlich gar nicht und die lange Rede kurz dazwischen, wir müssen gar nicht so viel über Trump und die AfD reden, sondern über die Art, wie wir politische Entscheidungen treffen in der Gesellschaft. Und wenn wir das wieder reparieren, dann sind die Symptome auch weg.
Wie jedoch soll das repariert werden? Das ist mir nicht klar.
Das ist mir auch unklar.
Wir können ja jetzt nicht sagen, schalten wir wieder einen Gang zurück, stellen wieder eine Presseanfrage, warten einen Tag, so lange wird bei YouTube nichts gesendet. Wie sieht das aus?
Genau, also das ist ja absurd. Ich würde auch sagen, klar, hier ist Justus Bender jetzt einfach gefangen in dem Willen, dass auch die FAZ einfach noch 20 Jahre da ist, solange er seine Schreiberbiografie noch beendet. Aber was wir auf jeden Fall haben, ist ein Medienverhalten, das in einem gewissen Verhältnis zur Welt steht. Also damals war einfach völlig klar, die Leute interessieren sich für sich selber, also müssen wir für sich selber Politik machen. Das Ausland dagegen ausgeblendet. Also, dass wir heute so Lieferkettenverantwortlichkeit, Klima thematisieren und so. Das kommt ja alles aus einer Sensibilisierung über Chaos, mediale Kommunikation, dass einfach alles jetzt mal in einen Top geworfen wird. Und plötzlich heißt es, ach so, jetzt müssen wir auch noch an die Nichtdeutschen, die nicht mal in Deutschland sind, denken und für die Verantwortung übernehmen, was auch immer.
Ja, auch das globale Kräftespiel. Das ist ja, also diese Präsenz, einfach diese Akteure in den Nachrichten, in dem Podcast laufen wird darüber geredet. Das ist in der Weise nicht früher gewesen.
Genau, so ein ganz unmittelbares. Schömer hat ja damals so gesagt, alles, was wichtig ist, ist heute in der Zeitung. Sie können in Berlin keinen politischen Move machen, der nicht in der Zeitung steht. So, und das ist erstmal eine gute Sache. Auch wenn es natürlich ein bisschen schmerzlich ist, plötzlich zu sehen, ah Mist, im Sinne von Willy Brandt kann nicht nur schöne Reden halten, sondern da geht es auch abends zur Sache oder was auch immer. Oder was hat Adenauer mit irgendwem besprochen in so einem Hinterzimmer und so. Das haben wir einfach nie in einer Aufklärung bekommen. Und es hätte damals, wenn da Ehrlichkeit gewesen wäre, einiges in Wallung gebracht. In deren Sicht ist ja das, was Trump so überzeugend macht, diese krasse Authentizität. Einfach zu sagen, ich will einen Ballroom. Und dann ist scheißegal, ob irgendwer das für eine schlechte Idee hält und so. Ich will einen Ballroom. Und diese Überzeugung einfach, an der klebt man dann so und fragt sich, krass, das ist ja irgendwie auch mal erfrischend, so was zu sehen. Nur, das muss halt noch eingeübt werden. Deswegen würde ich auch sagen, ne, hier muss nicht das alte Mediensystem repariert werden, sondern wir müssen halt, und ich meine, nach 20 Jahren fangen wir so langsam an, zu diskutieren, ob wir nicht auch mal das ein oder andere inhaltlich verbieten sollen bei, was weiß ich, 14-Jährigen oder so. Also, so ganz langsam werden ja so Linien eingezogen. Ich würde sagen, dadurch, dass wir jetzt Zora und so was haben, also Videoproduktion, die ununterscheidbar sind von Realität, wird es eh wieder einen neuen Dreh und eine neue Aufmerksamkeit für Leuchtturmjournalismus geben. Allein, weil man sich darauf verlassen kann. Nee, ich hab's auf der Seite der FAZ gesehen. Das war ein echtes Video.
Ja, wir sind ja hier eigentlich an der Situation, wo wir sagen, wer ist der Adressat? Und wenn wir jetzt über TikTok zum Beispiel reden, dann können wir sehen, dass dort der Adressat immer weniger eine Rolle spielt. Das heißt, es gibt zwar TikToker mit einer relativ großen Reichweite, aber deren Conversion Rate ist ja oft auch schon gar nicht so gut, wenn sie woanders hinmigrieren mit ihren Sachen, weil es nicht so sehr an den Adressaten geknüpft ist, wie beispielsweise bei einem Podcast. Ja, also auch da gibt es Clips, die irgendwo herumschwirren schon mal. Aber wir haben dann eine viel festere Verankerung an den Adressaten. Bei TikTok ist ja das so gewesen, das ist ja interessant, bei Ahrens und Kra, dass Kra ja verboten wurde auf TikTok. Und dann aber, dass er es richtig fad aufnahm, dass also andere irgendwelche Kleinstkanäle und großen Kanäle Kra-Videos produziert haben, sie hochgeladen haben und dort verteilte es sich immer weiter. Das bedeutet, es war gar nicht mehr an den Einzelnen geknüpft, nicht mehr an den Sender geknüpft, während man das bei YouTube ja noch eher dann vorfindet.
Ja, das ist soziologisch eine der interessantesten Fragestellungen überhaupt, nämlich diese Feststellung zu sagen, Kommunikation ist es nicht einfach nur, weil eine Information im Raum steht.
Ich sage jetzt immer Adressat der Absender ist es ja. Der Absender ist nicht mehr, aber der Absender ist bei TikTok nicht mehr so relevant.
Ja, aber es geht auch um den Adressaten.
Klar, nur wenn du nicht mehr es direkt an eine Figur verbinden kannst. Also wenn ich jetzt in der Filmanalyse spreche, dann spreche ich aus der Filmanalyse als Absender. Aber wenn irgendwo was geklippt wird von irgendjemanden, der einen Take raushaut zum Thema Migration und der geht bei TikTok viral, stellt sich für die, die das wahrnehmen, nicht mehr auf welchem Kanal habe ich das gesehen, von wo kam das jetzt genau, sondern es hat einfach der Take gefallen.
Also dass du jetzt bei dir eine Verwechslung von Adressat und Autor festgestellt hast, finde ich wahnsinnig interessant, denn dieser Kommunikationsbegriff heißt ja nicht einfach nur, es ist eine Information da im Sinne von, ich sehe etwas, ich nehme etwas wahr, sondern die Information, die eine Mitteilung so besonders macht, ist ja der Aspekt der Mitteilung. Also jemand muss etwas, man muss einfach merken, ich muss nicht gemeint sein, aber da wollte jemand jemandem was mitteilen. Und deswegen ist es für mich interessant. Oder ich wurde angesprochen, ich wollte jemanden ansprechen. Da hat jemand jemanden angesprochen, aber er hat ihn nicht gesehen oder was auch immer. Aber ich hab's bemerkt, wie eine Mitteilung flyforilte. Und da ist ja schon egal, ob man jetzt das vom Adressaten oder vom Autor wie auch immer, sondern allein der Aspekt, es gab eine Mitteilung. Und so ging das Social-Media-Zeitalter los. Mal nachschauen, was Friends and Family so sagen. Dann kamen irgendwann die Celebrities dazu, für die man sich interessiert. Und heute hat man einfach Inhalte, bei denen völlig unklar ist, ob das überhaupt noch eine Mitteilung war. Oder ob nicht einfach jemand irgendwas hat gebrommt. Also irgendwas wurde gebrommt, hochgeladen, fertig. So, nicht mehr drüber nachgedacht. Ist das überhaupt noch zu unterscheiden von, da wächst ein Baum? Gibt es noch eine Mitteilung? Also da sind wir mittlerweile angekommen. Von daher, ja, Bender hat hier gerade diese Reparation so betont. Und ich würde sagen, nee, sondern das muss jetzt rekombiniert werden. Wir müssen jetzt in diesem großen Wirrwarr von Informationen wieder Mitteilung erkennbar machen. Und sei es erstmal nur eine politische Mitteilung, bei der dann nicht ewige Podcasts von Nöten sind, indem uns der Föter-Herausgeber versucht, plausibel zu erklären, was der Kanzler gemeint hätte, wenn er doch nur so flehend von Kaube danach 20 Minuten Gespräch. Ja, stimmt schon. Er hätte so mitsagen können, was er nicht meinte. Und ich denke mir so, wow, das ist so verdreht gerade. Also, Teufelsküche, ja. Aber da sind wir ja im Grunde.
Aber nochmal, um auf diese 1 und 12 Prozent zu gehen. Ich glaube halt nicht, dass ich glaube nicht, dass sich das innerhalb von zwei Jahren verzwölft hat. Ich glaube nur, dass bei 12 Prozent innerhalb von zwei Jahren die Hemmung gefallen ist und das durch TikTok.
Schon klar. So, das ist jetzt seine Theorie, die Hemmungen sind gefallen. Da würde ich sagen, genau, wir sind nämlich nicht im Angststillstand, sondern wir sind in diesem Axel-Lotte-Ding. Ja. Hier sind einfach Hemmungen gefallen. Und Leute, und das ist ja, finde ich, immer noch das Wichtigste überhaupt. Sie müssen nicht von einer AfD-Ideologie überzeugt sein, um eine faschistische Gefahr darzustellen. Wenn die Hemmungen fallen, wie bei diesen jungen Migranten auf der Straße mit einem Mercedes-Benz Pullover, die können durchaus dafür sorgen, dass hier wieder Kassetts gebaut werden, also echte, ohne dass sie es wollten. Das ist die Gefahr, diese Hemmungslosigkeit.
Ja, das ist ja, ich hatte, das ist so irre, dass immer so gesagt wird, ja, wie überzeugt es jemand wirklich davon? Na ja, das spielt in dem Sinne keine Rolle. Ich will ein positives Beispiel geben. Ich habe das jetzt bei meinem Deep Dive auch gemacht. Thomas Mann ist ja durch die US-
Der Deep Dive ist übrigens Wolfgangs neues Bezahlformat auf der Filmanalyse. Du redest jetzt eine Stunde lang über-
Ja, sogar noch länger.
Oder länger.
Genau, bei Steady kann man das finden. Das ist am einfachsten. Das ist auch bei Apple, Patreon, aber wir empfehlen ja immer Steady. Dort gibt es die Filmanalyse Plus. Das bedeutet einmal im Monat Q&A und einmal im Monat ein Deep Dive. Da gehe ich dann tief rein in ein Thema oder in einen Film. Und hier beschäftige ich mich in der ersten Folge mit dem Lieblingsfilm von Donald Trump. Und das ist ein schwarz-weiß Film von 1950, nämlich Sunset Boulevard. Du musst ihn dir unbedingt ansehen. Du wirst es nicht glauben.
Weil er sich da drin wieder sieht.
Er sieht sich in einer Stummfilm-Diva, die ein Comeback herbeisehnt und zwischen Realität und Fiktion nicht mehr zu unterscheiden vermag. Jedenfalls habe ich mich da auch auseinandergesetzt mit der Frage, muss man dann überzeugt sein? Reicht das nicht, wenn man spielt, dass man Präsident ist? Oder zum Beispiel, dass man Demokrat ist? Und dann habe ich dann ein Zitat angeführt von Thomas Mann. Thomas Mann ist ja durch die USA gereist um für die Demokratie zu werben. Und dann gibt es in einem Tagebucheintrag den Satz, ich kann das jetzt nur aus dem Gedächtnis paraphrasierend wiedergeben, dass er sich fragt, inwieweit er dort eine Rolle spielt. Glaubt er wirklich eigentlich an diese demokratischen Ideale, die er verkündet? Die Frage stellt er sich und er sagt dann sich selbst, aber es ist gut, an diese Ideale zu erinnern. Das heißt, ob er wirklich so ein überzeugter Demokrat ist, bleibt unklar. Es ist aber wichtig, es zu tun. Und das kann man jetzt auch anders natürlich sehen, ob die wirklich überzeugte Rassisten sind. Nazis sind AfD-Anhänger, spielt in dem Sinne keine Rolle. Die Überzeugung ist nicht das Ding, es muss nur dahin geführt werden, dass sie sagen, ich mach da mal mein Kreuz.
Genau. Und viele Sachen müssen einfach geregelt werden. Wir müssen so tun, als ob, egal was Sache ist, wir können weder mit den Chinesen diskutieren, noch mit Trump, noch mit dem Virus. Und bei dem Virus war das irgendwie allen klar. Mit Corona können wir nicht diskutieren, müssen wir einfach machen. Und bei allen anderen Themen so, nee, erstmal diskutieren, erstmal alles durchs Bewusstsein leiern, ewig lagge hier nochmal am Podium, dann nochmal ein Marinitsch-Podcast und am Ende Teufelsküche. Also Medienverhalten und Strategie, ein sehr interessantes Kapitel, Bender.
Warum ist ausgerechnet diese Partei, ich sag mal...
Das ist mein Finanzminister hier, hört euch den mal an, klingt ja mal so, als würde er so völlig, warte mal, ich bin aufgestanden. Was bin ich, Politiker?
Das ist ausgerechnet diese Partei, ich sag mal, der alten Herren. Das ist ja nun mindestens mal was die Funktionsträger anbetrifft, soziologisch wirklich. Wieso sind die gerade auf diesem modernen medialen Ebenen so präsent und verstehen es dann auch, da die Jugend abzuholen?
So, jetzt kommt eine Antwort von Bender, die für alle interessant ist. Ich würde jetzt sagen, insbesondere für Benders Kollegen, alle, aber auch für uns, wir haben immer so Unterstellungen von Kompetenz und wie auch immer. Also wir unterstellen, wir warnen jetzt vor, nee, Leute müssen nicht davon überzeugt sein. Wir sehen Milliardäre und warum haben wir immer die Unterstellung, dass die sich auskennen mit Geld, mit Sachen und so weiter? Die haben alle keinen Plan und das ist ja bei Bender auch bei der AfD ganz, ganz wichtig jetzt.
Ich glaube, es ist keine junge Partei, aber es ist eine authentische Partei. Also denen ist ja alles egal. Also wenn man jetzt mit einem Mandatsträger von Union oder SPD spricht, als Journalist zum Beispiel, dann sagt der Leute, Herr Bender, das kann ich Ihnen nicht sagen. Und da muss ich jetzt ein bisschen aufpassen. Und wir haben hier Strukturen und wir haben das besprochen in der Fraktion und was nicht alles. Und so jemand von der AfD, der sagt, ich sag Ihnen mal ganz ehrlich, den 4. März kann ich überhaupt nicht leiden und den kann ich nicht leiden. Und gestern ist das passiert und dann dies. Und so ist auch der Erfolg zu erklären in Social Media. Es gab Versuche seit dem Europawahlkampf 2024, versuchen die etablierten Parteien da aufzuholen und haben das anfangs sehr schlecht gemacht. Olaf Scholz hat immer seine Aktentasche präsentiert, weil er die irgendwie schon immer hat. Und dann wollten die irgendwie diese Aktentasche in den Vordergrund stellen. Und das Social Media Team von Markus Söder hat ihn dauernd gefragt, was sein Lieblingsessen ist. Und dann hat er erzählt, weil die dachten, ach so, so ist dieser Hashtag Söder ist entstanden. Und so haben die, die dachten halt, ah, wir müssen authentisch sein. Also fragen wir Herrn Söder nach seinem Lieblingsessen. Aber was die AfD-Leute machen, ist was völlig anderes. Die setzen sich einfach da von der Kamera und sagen, die anderen Parteien lügen euch nur an. Ich sag euch jetzt mal, wie es wirklich ist. Und dann sagen sie irgendwas. Und man merkt, dann kommt natürlich etwas, wo vielleicht viele sagen würden, so ist es aber gar nicht wirklich. Das ist völliger Quatsch. Und dann machen wir mal einen Faktencheck. Aber was die emotionale Ebene angeht, hat niemand einen Zweifel, dass diese Person von der AfD wirklich daran glaubt, dass es hier, weiß nicht, die große Verschwörung gibt. Und Merkel hat das alles mit der Umfolgung geplant. Also das Authentische ist einfach in Social Media. Wie das Make-up im Fernsehen ist es einfach das Entscheidende.
Ja, nicht drüber nachdenken. Wer medial eine Rolle spielen will, muss einfach machen. Nicht planen. Plan ist kein machen. Plan ist das Gegenteil davon. Von daher einfach nicht drüber nachdenken. Wir bleiben an diesem Gedanken so ein bisschen. Ahrens beschreibt mal.
In diesem Zuge hatte ich eben mit Maximilian Graf vor allem zusammengearbeitet und tatsächlich die TikTok-Kampagne von ihm und dann später den Europawahlkampf, der eben ausschließlich über TikTok stattfand, durchgeführt. Und ich kann die Frage direkt zu Beginn beantworten, warum die AfD Social Media dominiert, weil es im Grunde der Bodensatz ist. Also Rechtspopulismus bedient die niedrigsten, urtümlichsten atavistischen Triebe, nämlich Angst und Abwehrhaltung.
So, das heißt noch lange nicht, dass Angst und Abwehrhaltung das Einzige ist, was attraktiv ist. Ja. Wir sehen ja, was auf YouTube attraktiv ist und so. Also das ist nicht nur Angst und Abwehrhaltung, nur politisch beuten die dieses Prinzip für sich aus. Und jetzt muss man sich halt fragen, warum beuten die anderen Parteien nicht ihre niedesten Triebe für sich aus, die sie da bespielen könnten? Könnte man ja genauso gut machen. Bender hat die mal besucht oder erzählt so, wie das so ist, mal über die Schulter zu schauen, wenn die AfD Medienstrategie fährt.
Ja, das war mir immer ganz wichtig, das zu vermitteln. Ich war in einer ganz besonderen Position, dass ich als Journalist mich da um Zugänge bemüht hab und ich wusste dann immer, was wurde im Bundesvorstand der AfD so gesprochen und in diesen internen Zirkeln. Und ich hab gemerkt, dass von außen immer der AfD irgendwelche Eigenschaften zugeschrieben werden, die gar nicht stimmen. Also die Leute sehen den enormen Erfolg dieser Partei und unterstellen dann so eine strategische Brillanz und so eine, wie machen die das? Die haben irgendwas verstanden, was wir nicht verstanden haben oder so. Und ich hab immer aus nächster Nähe halt erfahren, das stimmt nicht. Das sind ganz normale Leute, die eben noch immer dann Mutmaß, warum sind die im Internet so erfolgreich? Man schaut sich das mal an, wie das entsteht. Ich war in der Social-Media-Redaktion der AfD-Bundestagsfraktion. Die machen die erfolgreichste Social-Media-Strategie von allen Parteien in Deutschland. Da hab ich die gefragt, wie machen sie das? Die haben bestimmt hier irgendeine geniale Strategie.
So, Hüther, jetzt kommt die große Aufklärung. Wie machten die das bei der AfD?
Das ist sehr wichtig, denn wir hatten jetzt 100 Artikel über das Playbook, die Strategie, das weiß ich nicht.
So, jetzt kommt einfach, der Clip geht noch 33 Sekunden, es wird alles erklären.
Und dann haben die gesagt, wir nehmen dann so ein Foto von Alice Weidel und dann schreiben wir da drauf, was sie in der Rede gesagt hat und dann geht es raus und dann liken das 20.000 Menschen oder so. Also es ist sozusagen einfach nur eine Partei, die sehr authentisch ihre Emotionen kommuniziert und die keine Strategie verfolgt und wenn wir sozusagen von außen Strukturen beobachten, dann ist das unbewusst, jedes Mal. Also es ist mir wirklich wichtig, das sehr zu betonen, dass das so sehr nicht durchschaut wird von denen selbst.
Diese Diskussion immer darüber, welche Strategie ist es genau und wie können wir sie herausfiltern, erinnert mich immer daran. Erfolgsrezept. Welches Erfolgsrezept haben Sie? Warum konnten Sie fünf erfolgreiche Filme in Hollywood machen? Und in Hollywood gilt seit Jahrzehnten der Satz, Niemand weiß irgendetwas. Das ist auch das Prinzip hier. Wir machen, wie du sagst, das ist das Gegenteil von Planung. Wir machen, wir machen einen Post. Sehen wir mal.
Ja, Prince Ford Coppola hat diesen Megalopolis für 120 Millionen gekauft, hat sich selbst verschuldet, hat 14 Millionen eingespielt, pleite.
Ja.
Das war die Strategie.
Der hat aber auch 25 Jahre geplant.
Ja, also Herz ist vielleicht der Fehler. Das war gerne mal schief, aber man muss mal so was aus dem Ärmel schüttelt. Und hier muss man also auf die Frage hin auch, was kann die SPD jetzt da machen? Wir hören gleich Antworten von Bändern so, aber wenn die Miete zu hoch ist, ist die Miete zu hoch. Und wenn auf der Kachel nicht steht, die Miete ist zu hoch, dann hat die Kachel halt keinen Sinn. Warum sollte sich jemand für irgendwas anderes interessieren als die Miete? Leute kümmern sich um Ausländer, haben Angst und so weiter. Und für sehr viele ist einfach die Miete zu hoch. Und wenn das nicht draufgeschrieben wird auf die Kachel, dann fliegt sie halt nicht. So, Punkt.
Wenn man da nur drauf schreibt, wir stehen für eine starke Demokratie, warum sollte man das?
Wenig interessiert. Bender beschreibt es ein bisschen. Gegenstrategie. Wie könnte man das machen?
Wenn jetzt ein Anschlag passieren würde in Deutschland, was könnte ein amtierender Minister dazu sagen? Der müsste sagen, liebe Leute, furchtbar, was passiert ist. Wir warten jetzt ab, was die Ermittlungen zeigen. Wir können jetzt nicht zu irgendwelchen Schlüssen springen. Wir können jetzt auch nicht übermäßig einen emotionalen Ausbruch haben, weil wir wissen ja noch gar nicht, was genau passiert ist. Jetzt wartet erst mal ab und AfD-Leute, was machen die? Die gehen vor die nächste Kamera und sagen, es kann doch nicht wahr sein. Das 15. Mal und wir wissen doch genau.
So, wie soll der jetzt die SPD aufnehmen? Die Leute sagen, ihre Miete ist so hoch. Das kann doch nicht wahr sein, dass der Milliardärsvermieter, der in Berlin mehr als 3000 Wohnungen verbietet, schon wieder 20 Prozent auflegt. Punkt. Nein, da muss erst Volksgesetzgebung stattfinden. Dann schreiben wir das Gesetz selber so. Kann das nicht einfach die Partei machen? Wo wäre man denn in der Politik? So, also es ist eigentlich ganz einfach.
Wie ist Loi und so. Wir wissen doch genau, wer es war. Und die Leute, die das sehen, sind unglaublich stark abgeholt davon, weil sie ja selbst diese Angstreaktion haben. Und weil sie Leute wählen, das sagen Psychologen immer wieder, die ihnen ähnlich sind. Also wenn ich Angst habe nach so einem Anschlag, und mir erzählt ein Minister, weil er das ja machen muss, ja, ich verstehe ja auch, aber er erzählt mir eigentlich, dass mein Gefühl gar nicht gut ist in dem Moment und dass ich eigentlich was falsch mache mit dem, was ich fühle. Und ich habe das Gegenangebot von jemandem, der mir sagt, genauso wie du fühlst, fühle ich auch. Das ist schon sehr, sehr stark. Und das ist natürlich rational gesehen, ist da ganz vieles dran falsch. Aber in der neuen Medienlandschaft, in der wir sind, ist das möglicherweise wirksamer.
Ja, ganz schwierig. Also das ist ja auch das, was ich jetzt erlebt habe. Bei den Clips, die entstanden sind aus dem Gespräch, das ich mit Ben geführt habe, dass dann von den rechten Clips entstehen, in denen sie eigentlich mir vorwerfen, die Realität zu verdrücken, weil ich nicht ihre Angst teile. Und dann schreiben auch manche einen direkt an und sagen, ich habe aber Angst.
Ja, ich habe aber Angst. So und jetzt kommt Ben dann sagt, ja, man kann ja nicht nur mit der AfD Angst haben, man kann ja auch vor der AfD berechtigte Angst haben.
Ist die Ausgangslage ja so, dass es nicht nur die AfD gibt, sondern zum Beispiel Heidi Reicheneck von der Linken hat einen unglaublichen Erfolg bei jungen Leuten mit ihrer Art, wo man das Gefühl hat, wenn die was erzählt, die nimmt kein Blatt vor den Mund und ist volle Kande nach vorne und so. Und genau, wie sie sagen, es ist strukturell so, dass jemand, der gemäßigt ist, politisch ist natürlich auch in seiner Rhetorik gemäßigt und kann da nicht, und es wäre auch nicht authentisch und es wäre gelogen und es würde ja auch nicht ankommen, bei den Leuten, die ja auch gemäßigt sind und sich das wünschen. Und ich glaube, die einzige Lösung besteht darin, sich zu überlegen, welche Emotionen hat man denn, auch als Gemäßigter? Das ist ja auch eine Emotion. Die Sehnsucht nach Ordnung ohne dieses neurotische Element ist ja ein reales emotionales Bedürfnis, das man zum Beispiel bedienen kann. Also ich hab Angst vor einem Deutschland, das von der AfD beherrscht wird. Das ist nicht nur eine rationale Sorge um Demokratie-Theorie, sondern ich hätte wirklich Bammel, dass das hier voll den Bach runtergeht mit unserem Land. Wenn wir aus dem Euro aussteigen als Exportnation, ist hier Sense mit ganz vielem. Und lauter so Sachen. Und man sieht ja in Amerika, was dann wäre. Also ich glaube, man könnte Leute dann doch irgendwie auch, auch wenn die also gerade auch so jemand, der sehr differenziert ist und überlegt und so. Aber den kann man ja auch abholen dieser Situation. Das muss man glaube ich nur üben. Und da muss eine ganz neue Sprache entstehen als früher.
Also statt authentisch irre zu sein, muss man sozusagen einen emotionalen Zugang zur Mäßigung finden.
Kann man das so ausdrücken?
Ja, würde ich denken, ja. Und das ist glaube ich, das ist nicht unattraktiv.
Es ist nicht unattraktiv, weshalb ja die etablierten Medien eigentlich Erfahrung damit haben. Also wenn Griechenland morgen nicht zahlt, dann wird es ganz schlimm. Und Schömer hat damals so, kann mal jemand aufschreiben, was das bedeutet, es wird ganz schlimm? Was, wovon redet der Schäuble? Oder dieser Montgomery, Welterzte Präsident, sitzt in einer Talkshow und sagt, wir müssen den Leuten Angst machen, damit sie zu Hause bleiben. Und dann wird denen auch Angst gemacht. So, jetzt Putin. Ja, also eigentlich funktioniert es ja immer ganz gut. Nur nicht bei den Themen, bei denen man denkt, ja, da werden die Leute dann wirklich mal abgeholt. Nur das kostet halt auch.
Ja, man könnte zum Beispiel in sehr grellen Farben einmal zeichnen, wie das aussieht, wenn man im Alter, zum Beispiel, krank ist und möglicherweise Hilfe braucht. Oder man könnte ausmalen, was das bedeutet für Kinder, die irgendwann für ihre Eltern dort mit aufkommen müssen, was der Staat davor gesehen hat, was da schnell alles mit in den Topfen verwertbarem Vermögen eingespeist wird. Man könnte sehr viel auch dort mit einer Angst arbeiten, die sehr weit weggeht von Stadtbildfragen.
Also beim Thema Angst würde ich auch sagen, das Kind wird in der Schule nicht richtig ausgebildet, haben sie Angst, alle Eltern so, ja, große Angst. Sie werden im Pflegefall viel früher als sie glauben, haben sie Angst. Ja, ich kenne ja das Bildung, das System hier und so.
Aber offenbar geht das, ja, irgendwie kriegt das noch nicht zusammen, weil das ist ja bei der Wehrpflicht auch. Haben sie nicht Angst, dass ihr Kind getötet wird? Da würde man ja erstmal nicht sagen, ach nö, das macht mir nix, sondern würde sagen, ja, da habe ich aber Angst. Ah ja, dann müssten sie ja eigentlich zur Wehrpflicht eine andere Haltung haben. Wissen sie eigentlich, das hat ein Institut ausgerechnet, das Wehrpflicht leistet, später einige tausende Euro weniger an Vermögen aufbauen kann. Ich glaube, es waren 20 bis 30.000 Euro, wir hatten die Zahlen. Das haben die von uns die Türen. Macht ihnen das nicht Angst. Du hattest irgendwas kürzlich geteilt, wie sehr Frauen einen Einkommensschwund erleben, wenn sie ein Kind haben, nach dem dritten, vierten Jahr, wenn sie dann wieder zur Arbeit gehen. Macht ihnen das nicht Angst?
Stattdessen, nee, da haben wir ja sozialstaatliche Programme dafür und so. Und die Kinder sind ja auch nicht von Armut betroffen, sondern nur bedroht, puh, ein Glück, alles noch abwendbar. Bitte hab Angst vor Putin. So bitte kaufe für 500 Milliarden Stahl, das dann die Bundeswehr einlagern muss. Das ist das größte Problem, wo die Sachen einlagern.
Das wird jetzt erst mal geklärt.
Deswegen müssen die Liegenschaften von den Städten zurück und dann macht die Tagesschau einen Bericht, wie in Bielefeld eigentlich ja gerade die alte Halle bereitgestellt wurde, um da Basketball drin zu spielen, damit Vereine Basketballfläche haben. Aber nee, die Bundeswehr braucht es nicht.
Ist das wirklich so in Bielefeld?
Also gestern in der Tagesschau, was haben wir heute? Die Tagesschau 20 Uhr vom 28. Oktober.
Ja.
Berichterstattung mit Bildern aus Bielefeld, wie in der Kaserne im Alten Hof und in der Alten Sporthalle jetzt Schüler Basketball spielen. Und der Anlass, das zu zeigen, war, die Bundeswehr hat festgestellt, sie brauchte Liegenschaften wieder selbst, weil ja erstens neue Wehrpflicht und zweitens Munition muss gelagert werden.
Also schickt man die wieder raus mit dem Ball in die Innenstadt und dann können die mal gucken, wo sie bleiben.
So, ja, das ist verdreht, ja. Aber ja, Hauptsache die Angstorganisation funktioniert hier genau gar nicht, wie der Bender beschreibt.
Ich frag mich, wo stehen wir da? Haben wir die Menschen, ist das überhaupt realistisch, dass unsere Spitzenpolitiker...
Ja, das sind natürlich jetzt so Politiker, die in den Politikpodcasten nachfragen, warum immer nur die AfD Angst schüren kann, während sie selber die ganze Zeit die Ausländer...
So leisten können, was wir gerade ein bisschen zwar konkret, aber doch irgendwie abstrakter formuliert haben.
Also ich würde denken, dass man es trennen muss, das Abholen der Menschen in der Emotion und die Schlussfolgerung, die man daraus in der realen Politik zieht. Also die AfD holt die Menschen ab, weil sie sagt, ach, ihr habt Angst, wir haben auch Angst. Und dann denken die Leute, ach, die sind ja wie wir. Dann wählen wir die. Und was die Leute aber weder emotional noch rational dann wirklich wollen, glaube ich, ist die ganz rechtsextreme Ideologie, die dahinter steht bei vielen in der AfD. Also irgendwelche Vorstellungen, ethnisch homogene Volksgemeinschaft und irgendwelche Sachen aus der konservativen Revolution, der Weimarer Republik oder irgendso. Das kennen die Leute ja gar nicht, die wissen überhaupt nicht, was will denn diese Höcke. Das ist immer nur die Emotion. Und ich würde denken, der Vertrauensgewinn der AfD, das ist das, wo man gewinnen kann gegen sie oder wo man es ihr gleich tun kann. Und dann ist es aber kein Beinbruch für die Menschen, wenn man sagt, ich verstehe genau eure Angst, ich habe auch diese Angst. Und jetzt sage ich euch mal, was wir dagegen tun. Und dann machen wir was, was wirklich funktioniert. Denn das, was die AfD vorstellt, das funktioniert nicht. Kann ich euch sagen, warum? Aber ihr könnt mir vertrauen, ich bin nämlich genauso wie ihr. Ich habe genau diese Angst und ich will auch nicht, dass mein Kind auf dem Schulweg überfallen wird von dem und dem. Und ich präsentiere euch jetzt die Lösung. Und ich glaube, das würde funktionieren. Es geht nur um das Vertrauen, dass man sagt, das ist einer von uns. Lasst ihn mal machen.
So, und darauf lassen die sich aber nicht ein.
Die Politiker?
Ja. Nein. Hier in Frankfurt, wie gesagt, 11 Milliarden allein durch Einzelhandelsumsatz und Vermietung. Dieses Geld wird zu fast 100 Prozent aus der Stadt abgezogen. Das ist dann die Schwarzgruppe, die irgendwas macht, mit diesen unendlichen Milliarden. Und dann will man irgendwie ein KI-Klaster aufbauen, irgendwo einen Heilbronnen oder so. Diese ganzen Vermieter, also die geben das Geld nicht in Frankfurt aus. Die wohnen ja nicht hier. Das Geld wird direkt raus überwiesen, mit der Mietzahlung ist es weg. So, und so funktioniert eine Lebenswelt nicht. Und jetzt sagt der Justus Bender einfach, ja, man kann ja dann einfach das mal adressieren. Und ich denke mir so, ja, du redest hier gerade mit dem Finanzminister von Hessen, denn der wollte hier in Frankfurt Bürgermeister werden und so. Also hier der Boris Rhein und er redet jetzt mit dem Finanzminister, der direkt für Boris Rhein arbeitet und so. Kann man sich vorstellen, dass die sich mal hinsetzen und hier mal ernsthaft die Sachen besprechen? Nein. Ist ja völlig ausgeschlossen.
Wie heißt euer Kulturstaatsminister? Der aktuelle weiß ich nicht, aber der, der aktuelle war beim Hessischen Filmpreis und hat dann gesagt, dass das für eine wunderbare Veranstaltung sei und lobte und lobte. Und Film ist ja so wichtig und gerade für Hessen, um dann die Frage gestellt zu bekommen. Ja, wie ist denn das, ist das wirklich so, dass wir im nächsten Jahr keinen Hessischen Filmpreis bekommen? Also gibt es keine Auszeichnung, keine Tutorien und so weiter? Ja, die Klammkassen.
Ach, die Klammkassen, genau.
Dann wurde der Drehbuchautor von der Cum-Ex-Serie ausgezeichnet, kam auf die Bühne und sagte also, ich wüsste, wo noch ein paar Milliarden sind.
Genau, genau. Das ist so irre. Genau, und jetzt, also Lourdes war mal hier Kultusminister, der ist jetzt Finanzminister, Boris Rhein wollte hier mal Bürgermeister werden, das ist alles diese CDU-Soße. Uwe Becker, der hier Bürgermeister werden wollte, der wurde ja auch zum Glück aus der Stadt verdrängt, der ist jetzt Staatssekretär im Finanzministerium bei diesem Lourdes. Also mit denen ist das natürlich nicht zu machen so, also hier braucht man echt so eine Mandani-Revolution, man kann einfach nur hoffen, dass aus diesem ganzen Trump- und Mandani-Theater was folgt für alle, dass so ein bisschen aufgemischt wird. Ahrens?
Ich glaube, das ist ein Gefühl, ich glaube, das Gefühl ist die Untergangsangst. Und ich hatte dieselbe und viele Rechte haben die. Ich glaube, das ist das rechte Grundgefühl. Heutzutage glaube ich, rechte Politik ist eine politisierte Depression im Grunde, ein aus einem negativen Grundgefühl entstehender Reflex handeln, dass man sich angegriffen fühlt, dass man sich von der Welt angefochten sieht und in einer Defensivbewegung sozusagen dann zum Aggressor werden muss, um diesen Angriff abzuwehren.
So, ich kenne ausschließlich Leute, die sich in der Defensive sehen. Die kriegen bisher nur von der AfD ein Angebot, aber das sind halt einfach keine Rassisten, von daher funktioniert das nicht so gut. Für die muss man jetzt Programm machen einfach. Und zwar, so wie Ahrens jetzt auch sagt, einfach einen krassen positiven Populismus.
Reden wir vielleicht wirklich über das Kernthema, über das ich mit dir reden wollte, Strategie. Wie besiegen wir die AfD?
Ich glaube, es braucht einen progressiven Populismus. Also die AfD würde ich in erster Linie eben als Reaktionär frameen. Ich würde zeigen, dass die AfD für alle Probleme als Lösung vorschlägt, zurück in die Vergangenheit zu gehen. Also egal für welches Problem, es ist im Grunde, sie wollen die Zeit zurückdrehen. Das ist im Grunde, also auch das Grundgefühl, was die AfD bedient, ist nicht nur eben dieses, die Welt geht unter, sondern es war halt früher alles besser als heute. Und sie ist in dem Sinne eine reaktionäre Partei, die und das kann jeder rational denkende Mensch nachvollziehen. Das habe ich übrigens auch damals als Nazi so gesehen, dass die AfD keine Lösung anbieten kann, sondern lediglich eben Protestpotenzial bündeln und damit an die Macht kommen kann. Und die Leute, die dann an die Macht kommen, haben aber eben keinerlei Lösungen. Das heißt, man muss sozusagen einfach offen jedem sichtbar machen, dass das ein Sumpf ist und dass jeder, der sich dahin begibt und damit irgendwie interagiert, in diesen Sumpf reingezogen wird.
So, so weit so gut. Aufklärung ist vielleicht noch möglich und sei es nur, dass man Politiker darüber aufklärt, wie man einen positiven Populismus irgendwie so organisiert, dass Leute, die sich in der Defensive fühlen, was sehr viele sind, da irgendwie aufhängt. Jetzt machen wir noch ein kleines letztes Kapitel auf, bei dem ich sage, sehr gut, dass man da jetzt mal ehrlich drüber spricht. Denn wir könnten uns ja auch über die AfD mal aufklären. Und zwar weg von diesen vulgären Vorstellungen, dass da so geniale Strategien, das haben wir jetzt von Bender schon gehört, sondern was bedeutet eigentlich AfD-Politik für AfDler? Wer macht da eigentlich Politik? Was ist und so weiter? Ich will ausdrücklich dazu sagen, mir juckt es auch ein bisschen in den Fingern, mal so darüber zu reden, weil alte, fette, hässliche Männer sind halt durchaus alt, fett und hässlich. Und das kann man ja auch mal einpreisen in so einer Diskussion.
Aber was ist das, muss ich jetzt doch mal kritisch nachfragen, für dich für eine merkwürdige Kategorie. Also Schönheit hat ja nichts mit Politik zu tun.
Sagst du?
Nein. Also das ist ja nun wirklich Unsinn.
Nee, das meine ich jetzt nicht so im Sinne von, sondern ich sage, warum willst du per se Kategorien ausschließen, weil sie angeblich nichts mit Politik zu tun haben? Warum soll ich jetzt rechtfertigen, dass das eine Rolle spielt? Ich sage mal so, wir haben ganz viel über Insel und so geredet. Und das sind Leute, die von sich selber sagen, und im anderen Etat ist es völlig normal, ein Bullshit-Job wird darüber definiert, dass jemand, der einen macht, sagt, das ist aber ein Bullshit-Job. So ein Insel ist in seiner politischen Dimension im Grunde auf demselben Pfade. Er sagt einfach von sich, also so wie ich gerade drauf bin, kriege ich nie eine Freundin. Und dann folgt aber etwas daraus.
Ich weiß, du bist jetzt wieder auf deinem Sport-Trip, davon will ich ja von deinem Sport-Trip gar nicht abtragen.
Nein, es geht gar nicht um Sport. Junge Leute, die sich ausgeschlossen fühlen, die können auch super sportlich sein, aber mit sich unzufrieden, ziehen daraus ja Konsequenzen.
Also ich sehe gerade in der rechten Coaching-Szene oder so nur Leute, die so ein breites Kreuz haben, ungeheuer trainiert sind und dann... Also das hat mir...
Und das hat ja mit AfD gar nichts zu tun. Die findest du ja nicht bei einem AfD-Parteitrag.
Wenn ich das jetzt gerade so als sei-Leibes-Fülle in irgendeiner Weise korrelativ zu irgendeiner politischen Haltung, dann würde ich dem doch hier deutlich widersprechen. Erstmal, weil ich nicht irgendwelche Leute hier ausschließen will, ob sie dick oder dünn oder sonst was sind oder ob sie ins Fitnessstudio gehen oder nicht. Und zweitens, weil ich sagen würde, die Kategorie ist eine, die überhaupt nicht greift. Was man einfach daran sehen kann, dass es zum einen in einer rechten Kultur zum Beispiel einen enormen Körperkult gibt, der ja auch zum Beispiel von Joe Rogan und jetzt auch von Mark Zuckerberg gepflegt wird. Zugleich aber sind sie dann in einer großen Anhängerschaft zu Donald Trump, der wiederum jetzt nicht deren körperlichem Ideal entspricht, was aber jetzt auch da nicht wieder zum Problem gemacht wird. Und da sieht man eigentlich, dass das als Kategorie nicht viel greift. Ich weiß, dass Ahrens sich gerne jetzt so darstellt, wir haben jetzt die Clips nicht gehört, dass er so an so einer, er will eigentlich zu einer Elite gehören und hat aber dann gesehen, bei der AfD ist diese Elite ja gar nicht und er steint da irgendwie, das auch mit so einer Ästhetik zu verbinden. Wenn man sich jetzt einfach zum Beispiel eine Wirtschaftselite oder so ansieht, dann kann man nicht sagen, dass da ästhetische Gründe in irgendeiner Weise im Vordergrund stehen. Man könnte sagen, es gibt die Kategorie des gepflegten Äußeren oder so etwas, die wichtig ist in einer bestimmten Situation. Und ich hab ja auch selbst kürzlich in Berlin über Coolness und Linke und so diskutiert. Mir ist schon klar, dass wir eine Ästhetisierung der Politik erleben. Ich sehe die nirgendwo. Ich glaube, nein, eine Ästhetisierung der Politik im Sinne von, dass gerade im Aktivismus natürlich, wenn der Sozialen Medien stattfindet.
Dem muss ich wieder sprechen.
Nein, Ästhetisierung meine ich nicht mit, alle sollen aussehen wie German Sex Topmodel mit der Ästhetisierung. Ästhetisierung meine ich, dass also die Form über den Inhalt gestellt wird. Und das können wir in der Tat erleben. Das kannst du nicht leugnen.
Doch, das leugne ich und zwar mit ganz großen und wichtigen Worten. Und zwar, AfD ist nicht, was wir bei, und da sind zwei Podcaster, die heißen Haus und Hopf und die gehen in Fitnessstudio und die haben Muskeln und reden über rechten Kram. Diese Connection aus in einem Fitnessstudio sind lauter Muskelmänner. Und wir haben mal Filme in einem dritten Reich gehabt, in dem Muskelmänner und Muskeln mit rechter Ideologie und so weiter.
Das habe ich auch damit nicht gemeint.
Ich will meine Empathie jetzt darstellen, Wolfgang.
Wir haben doch einen Aktivismus und ich meine jetzt gar nicht nur den rechten Aktivismus, wir haben doch zum Beispiel einen Aktivismus bei Instagram. Menschen, die dort Positionen vertreten.
Das Zauberwort lautet bei Instagram.
Und dass das, ja genau, darum geht es ja. Das genau in diesem medialen Zirkus, in diesem medialen Zirkus gibt es eine Ästhetisierung der Politik.
Ich weiß doch, was du meinst.
Wenn du jetzt mir sagst, ja, aber wenn ich hier durch Kassel in die Innenstadt gehe, da sehe ich nicht eine Ästhetisierung der Politik, da gebe ich dir recht, die gab es vorher nicht, die gibt es auch heute nicht.
Also in meiner Heimat Thüringen und wir haben in Thüringen noch nicht ganz so, es gibt Orte, Bautzen oder so, 50 Prozent AfD-Wählerschaft.
Ja.
Dort gibt es keine nennenswerte Fitnesskultur.
Nein, das habe ich auch gar nicht gesagt.
Diese AfD-Wähler dort sind und es ist jetzt nur ganz grob, also leicht...
Weil sie sehen so aus, wie der Durchschnitt so aussieht.
Schlimmer. Wegen wie auch das? Schlimmer. Also wir hören jetzt mal, wie hier drüber geredet wird und ich finde...
Und so eine Ernährung, der soziale Status ist ja auch immer sehr entscheidend, das ist ja etwas, was immer da bei den ganzen Diskussionen so wegfällt, dass der soziale Status einfach extrem entscheidend ist, ob man zum Beispiel sich gesunde Lebensmittel leisten kann und all das führt dazu, dass du natürlich dort sehr viele Leute antrifft, die jetzt nicht irgendeinem Ideal oder so entsprechen. Was ich aber sagen will, ist, dass wir generell in der medialen Verbreitung von Politik eine Zunahme haben, die ich als Ästhetisierung des Politischen begreifen möchte. Das bedeutet aber nicht, dass jetzt die Wähler alle so aussehen.
So, und jetzt haben wir aber ein ganz großes Problem. Wir haben ja vorhin festgestellt, der Rassismus ist im Grunde so eine Methode, die da gewählt wird, weil sie erstens sehr viel Ordnung bietet und zweitens sehr viel Wirkung entfalten kann. Also da gibt es einfach historisch auch beispielhaft, wie man das programmatisch unterfüttert. Aber eigentlich ist es ja ein Sozialdarwinismus. Sozialdarwinismus heißt schwache Leute, die nicht leistungsfähig sind, von denen man sich nichts mehr erwartet, werden aussortiert. Das erleben wir in unserer Gesellschaft natürlich ganz viel. Allein durch eine Unterstellung wie, ach deine Eltern können kein Deutsch, damit haben wir gar keine Erwartung, dass du irgendwas leisten kannst. Hauptschule, ciao. Oder du bist alt, von dir erwarten wir nichts mehr. Wir bauen dir hier weder sowas wie einen Kindergarten, noch eine Tagesbetreuung, noch sonstiges, sondern geh ins Dachgeschoss. Wir kontrollieren auch nie, ob die Frau, die dich da dreimal die Woche pflegt, auf Schwarzarbeit und so weiter aus Polen angereist kommt. Ja, wir wollen einfach damit gar nichts zu tun haben. Also es werden ganz viele Leute aus diesen sozialdarwinistischen Gründen so richtig wegsortiert.
Und deswegen will ich dich ja nur davor beschützen, dass du jetzt auch in so ein sozialdarwinistisches Argument fällst, in dem du jetzt Körper von Leuten beschreibst und sagst, die sind näher an der AfD oder so dran. Das ist einfach unsinnig. Das ist, was der Ahrens gerne jetzt so sieht, weil er die ganze Zeit in irgendwelchen anderen Videoformaten sitzt und sagt, ich bin jetzt sein Twink und was weiß ich. Das mag ja sein persönliches Fable da sein, aber das ist einfach nicht das, was man so antreffen kann.
Na gut. Okay, also du willst mich beschützen, aber ich sagte ja...
Ich will dich beschützen, auch einfach weil man kann in die Spitzenpolitik blicken der letzten 10, 20 Jahre und wird nicht klar Zuweisungen machen können.
Nein. Wir reden ja auch nicht über die Spitzenpolitik der etablierten Politiker, sondern wir reden ja über die AfD und ihr Klientel. Und ich finde, und deswegen ist auch gar nicht so viel Schutz notwendig, wir sind zwar ein politischer Podcast, aber die folgenden Clips laufen für mich ja, wenn ich das so im Original-Romaterial höre, zu im Grunde 95 Prozent unter Unterhaltung.
Okay.
So und genauso sollten wir das jetzt auch mal, denn es ist auch, finde ich, wahnsinnig amüsant.
Ich hatte ja damals ein höchst kritisches Verhältnis zu dieser Partei. Ich sah die wie gesagt nur als Steigbügelhalter und dass die...
Du warst Selbstständiger.
Ja und dass die Partei zu 90 Prozent oder zu 95 Prozent von Idioten nicht nur geführt, sondern auch gewählt wird, habe ich damals schon so gesehen. Ich habe diese Leute, die AfD-Wähler als Stimmvieh und als dumme Masse gesehen. Übrigens...
Du hast versucht, das zu verbessern.
Ich habe versucht, das auszunutzen. Im Grunde habe ich versucht, auf dieser populistischen Welle an die Macht zu kommen. Und zum Beispiel gestern erst oder vorgestern erst ist auf secession.de, auf dem Blog von Götz Kubitschek, den ich immer noch aus diesem Grund lese, weil das interessante Einsichten bietet, ein Artikel von einem Haino Bosselmann erschienen, wo die Secession genau dasselbe schreibt, wo man sagt, ja leider sind bei der AfD viele Trittbrettfahrer und Idioten und die wirklich guten Leute kommen nicht zur AfD. Also selbst da macht man sich über das Personal am Boden.
Keine Illusion.
Ja, über die Wähler im Grunde lustig.
So, also als allererstes würde ich mal sagen, dass die ihre Wähler verachten, das ist ja völlig klar. Ja, aber ich will jetzt nicht über die Politiker und wie fies sie mit dem Publikum umgehen reden, sondern ich will über diese Leute reden. Und ich will ausdrücklich sagen, und ich habe jetzt wieder Erzählungen aus Jena bekommen, diese Leute sind strunzdumm. Und das ist ein echtes Problem. Ja. Man hört sich diese Familiengeschichten an und denkt, das kann doch nicht wahr sein. Das geht einfach nicht. Aber es ist die Realität.
Wir haben ja das Buch im Salon ausführlich diskutiert. Ich war ja mehr begeistert als du es warst. Demokratiedämmerung von Freizeck. Der geht ja genau auf diese Komponente ein. Was bedeutet das eigentlich, wenn ich die ganze Zeit sage, ich brauche einen politischen Diskurs und wir brauchen einen Austausch von Argumenten, stellt sich aber heraus, es gibt ein Fünftel von erwachsenen Menschen, die auf dem Niveau von maximal eines Vierklässlers lesen und schreiben, bedeutet also, wie soll da das Argument überhaupt ankommen?
Genau. Was aber bedeutet, wenn wir diese psychologischen Prinzipien alle kennen, wie die sich in so eine Selbstüberschätzung, weil sie die eigenen Maßstäbe nicht kennen und so weiter, immer wieder verfransen in so einer, und dann wird das nochmal besonders selbst behauptet, was sie da sagen. Und auch die eigenen Kinder haben dann keine Chance mehr, das im Gespräch mal zu machen und so. Da muss man einfach mal auch auf der Suche sein nach einer Strategie, den Leuten für sie plausibel zu vermitteln. Das ist ganz dumm, was ihr hier macht. Du kannst nicht deine eigene Eis-Abschiebe-Gruppe ins Amt wählen, als junger Migrant in Frankfurt zum Beispiel, nur weil du denkst, das ist jetzt irgendwie cool und das stützt so ein bisschen deine Identität, wenn eine Fernsehkamera läuft oder sowas. Man muss die dann nicht bemuttern und bepampern, sondern man muss sie wirklich konfrontieren.
Ja, auf Angriff ganz klar.
Genau.
So. Siehst du andere Mittel und Wege neben dem Markieren als Reaktionär?
Ahrens macht jetzt hier einen Punkt, den ich ganz wichtig finde.
Ja, Markieren als Alt, Markieren als gesellschaftliche Außenseiter. Man muss, das ist jetzt ein bisschen hart, aber das glaube ich ist...
Asoziale.
Ja, man muss sie als Asoziale bezeichnen. Man muss vor allem, also sie wollen in einer sozialdavinistischen Welt leben. So, sie sind diejenigen, die in einer sozialdavinistischen Welt leben wollen, in der die Armen, Schwachen, Fremden noch weiter sozusagen erniedrigt und unterdrückt werden. Sie sind diejenigen, die nach diesen Maßstäben eigentlich messen. Und jeder kriegt meines Erachtens, oder sollte das kriegen, was er will. Das heißt, man müsste die AfD selbst nach diesen Maßstäben bewerten und müsste halt zeigen, was ihr Personal für hässliche, häufig übergewichtige, häufig charakterlich im Grunde einfach Schwache, Genetisch Degenerierte, nach ihren eigenen, nach ihren eigenen Maßstäben nicht satisfaktionsfähige Leute sind, dass das Bodenpersonal auf den Stammtischen, auf den Parteitagen in überwiegenden Fällen eben ja übergewichtige, abgehängte Boomer sind, die viel Bier trinken, dass es da keine jungen Menschen gibt, die irgendwie attraktiv sind, Zukunftsperspektiven haben. Man müsste mal Interviews mit den jungen Leuten führen, die tatsächlich da sind, was das für Vollidioten sind.
Ja, ich habe jetzt das Argument verstanden, nur glaube ich, dass das so einfach nicht geht. Das kann der jetzt mal in einem Podcast raushauen und macht das so ein bisschen verschämt auch. Aber es ist ja einfach so, der Mensch, der in diesen Verhältnissen zu nicht besonders guten Bedingungen eben sehr lange gelebt hat, dessen Körper wurde auch davon geformt. Es ist ja nicht einfach eine Willensentscheidung, sondern wir sind sonst bist du immer dabei und sagst, ne, das ist nicht das Individuum, sondern das ist die Gesellschaft. Jetzt weise ich dich darauf hin, dass gerade Fragen der Ernährung, Fragen der Sozialisierung, also dass das alles sehr stark, doch im Ganzen zu verstehen ist systemisch. Wenn ich jetzt aber denen jetzt als Individuum gegenüber trete und nur sage, guck dich mal an, dann komm ich doch gar nicht weiter.
Nein, das ist ja nicht das Programm. Das Programm ist doch wie folgt. Nehmen wir mal Thüringen. Es geht doch hier nicht um die Armen und so weiter. Es geht hier um Leute, die eigene Handwerksbetriebe gegründet haben, die mehrere ein Eignisseigenheim, in dem sie wohnen, noch zwei vermieten und so weiter und so fort. Die Einflugsschneise für die AfD zu wählen ist Pessimismus die Zukunft. Nicht, ich bin arm und mir geht es schlecht.
Aber er hat ja jetzt lauter Leute gezeigt, die offenbar abgehängt sind.
Also, wenn wir jetzt mal sagen, okay, es gibt jetzt viele von denen, wir sagen, okay, die sitzen wirklich nur zu Hause und kriegen ja die Dinge nicht im Griff und da haben wir auch nicht die finanziellen Möglichkeiten, was auch immer. Ich habe die Leute vor Augen, die sich sehr wohl noch aus ihrem Sessel herausbewegen, um zu einem AfD-Orts treffen zu gehen. Und dann hast du einfach so eine Dorfschenke, in dem 100 Mal derselbe Phänotyp, der ist nicht von Armut gekennzeichnet. Der macht seine drei Urlaubsreisen im Jahr, die alle Kinder studieren. Der hat sogar ausländische Mitarbeiter in seinem eigenen Unternehmen, die alle mit Namen kennt, wo er die Familiengeschichten kennt. Alles super. Aber der eine, den man nicht kennt, ganz schlecht. Also was macht denn der schon wieder hier? Der raubt ja mir schon wieder meine Rente und so. Diese Leute muss man genauso konfrontieren. Ihr könnt euch gerne mit eurem Pessimismus hier zeigen und politisch organisieren. Aber wenn ihr euch mit einem Programm organisiert, um diesen Pessimismus zu bewältigen, der euch alle aussatieren würde, geht das einfach nicht. Und dann lassen wir es nicht drauf ankommen, dass in 15 Jahren die Mobilisierung so weit läuft, dass das dann Realität ist, sondern dann konfrontieren wir die jetzt schon mal. ICE macht gerade in Amerika die Erfahrung, dass diese ganzen übergewichtigen Loser-Männer zu ICE-Rennen in dieses Bewerbungsding und die Atlantic dann zitiert, dass die Ausbilder immer wieder eine Athletic Allergy feststellen. Da kommen Leute, die kriegen nicht drei Liegestütze hin und wollen aber mit ihrer Manneskraft den Staat verteidigen und glauben, das ist ihre Lebensaufgabe.
Das sehen wir ja auch in der Weltkriegsdiskussion.
Genau, die werden da gerade konfrontiert.
Bei den Umfragen haben wir ja immer Leute, also das eine war ja jetzt schon mal ein ganz klar ökonomisches Argument, dem ich mich anschließe. Ihr seid so doof, dass ihr den eigenen Untergang ankreuzt.
Das sind diese Mittelstands-Funktionärs-Eliten, die so Verbandschefs sind.
Das sehe ich auch als ganz großes Problem. Ich glaube nur da, wo er jetzt immer das so stark auf das Ästhetische auslegt, kommt man in ein schwieriges Gefilde, weil man plötzlich das als eine generelle Kategorie zur Beschreibung von Gesellschaft nimmt, wo man einfach sagen muss, das hat eigentlich da keinen Platz. Da aber sicherlich, wo Leute jetzt plötzlich sagen, Deutschland muss stark werden und ich habe da jemand, der selbst nur mit dem Bierbauch da sitzt und sich nicht bewegt, dann kann ich fragen, aber wie so stark wie sie oder was. Genau so stelle ich mir auch die Frage, wenn ich diese ganzen Politiker jetzt in den Talkshows sehe, die die Wehrpflicht wollen. Ich bin auch gespannt mal zu sehen, wie Anton Hofreiter so einen Fußmarsch macht mit hochrotem Kopf.
Lass mich das noch mal nach wie folgt eingrenzen, denn ich weiß ja, dass ich hier ein irrationales Argument mache. Nur wenn Friedrich Merz nach einer Woche Aufklärung durch seinen eigenen Stab plötzlich mir zittern, damit bloß jeder Satz sitzt, ja so einen Spruch vorliest, dass man ja die Migranten für den Arbeitsmarkt und auch für den Arbeitsmarkt und der Arbeitsmarkt ganz wichtig, dann sehe ich ja darin einen Pragmatismus, bei dem ich sage, okay, wir machen jetzt hier ein Reflektions- und Rationalitätsstopp, denn es reicht völlig, dieses Arbeitsmarktargument zu bringen, an den deutschen Wohlstand zu appellieren. Und damit zu sagen, ich weiß, das ist eine Verwertungslogik von Menschen und so weiter und fort, aber es ist halt Win-Win-Win.
Was ich ja nur nicht will, ist, dass wir jetzt, wir wollen gerne die eine Kategorie abschaffen, dass wir jetzt nach Ethnizität nicht mehr gehen und jetzt machen wir eine neue Kategorie auf und gucken uns jetzt plötzlich an, wie sportlich ist jemand oder wie jung ist jemand.
Ich will diese Poente kurz machen. Wenn im Osten Deutschlands meine Altersgenossen, die es nicht geschafft haben, ihr Leben auf die Reihe zu kriegen, sondern sich jetzt zusammenrotten in diesen Dörfern, wo sie es gerade so hingekriegt haben, das Haus der Eltern zu erben und so. Wenn das alles junge, durchtrainierte, super kluge Leute wären, die jetzt aber plötzlich Höcke anhängen und dort so eine Art neues deutsches Reich gründen, würde ich mein Argument nie machen. Aber, und zwar nur aus diesem pragmatischen Grund, weil ich weiß, dass die zu 98% übergewichtige Boomer sind, die einfach nur diesen Pessimismus durchleiden und deswegen so ein Höcke-Programm politisch waren. Diesen einen Moment, wo sie nach vier Jahren mal mich fragt ja keiner, mal die Chance kriegen, eine Stimme abzugeben. Nur deswegen mache ich diesen Punkt.
Ich will ja nur, ich will ja nur, ja ich habe es ja verstanden und gut, ich ahnte, als ich das Gespräch hörte mit Ahrens, dass du uns hier diese Clips präsentieren würdest. Ich war ja schon gewappnet. Ich will nur eines noch deutlich machen, warum ich gegen diese Verstärkung der Kategorie bin. Ganz einfach deshalb, weil du auch sehr viele korpulente Boomer finden wirst, zum Beispiel, die die AfD nicht wählen, die wichtige antifaschistische Arbeit da vor Ort in kleinen Kopierungen machen und sich dort anlegen. Und die sehen auch nicht alle aus wie irgendeine Elite, von der Ahrens da redet. Und ich würde sagen, dass es eh, wenn man schöne Leute sehen will, dann kann man Germany's Next Topmodel gehen, dann ist die Politik vielleicht nicht der allerbeste Ort dafür, ist aber auch nicht die Kategorie, die man dafür braucht. Abends kann man Hollywood-Filme gucken oder so. Deswegen würde ich sagen, diese Kategorie hat nicht so eine hohe Tragfähigkeit.
Und deswegen sage ich ja, unter Unterhaltungsgesichtspunkten wünsche ich mir sehr, dass der den Funktionären, den du gerade meinst, also auch ein übergewichtiger alter männlicher Boomer, der aber durchaus eine politische Geschichte hat und da so ein bisschen weiß, wo man sich verirrt, dass der einfach mal zu so einem AfD-Ortstreffen geht und sagt, sorry, ich habe ja auch mal einen Redebeitrag. Und dass er einfach nur sagt, sorry, könnten wir uns alle mal kurz anschauen? Wollen wir hier wirklich einen Sozialdarwinismus etablieren? Wir sind doch die Ersten, die dann raus, und so weiter. Also diese Konfrontation, diese Art, überhaupt darüber zu reden, so wie wir jetzt sagen, ist notwendig.
Aber bei Ahrens ist das, und da sehe ich eben, dass sich das noch nicht so ganz gelöst hat. Bei Ahrens ist das noch so, als sei es wirklich so, dass seien die guten Menschen die fitten Menschen, und die anderen Menschen sind nicht so toll. Und jetzt hat er festgestellt, bei der AfD sind viele dieser nicht so toll, und deswegen ist er nicht mehr in der AfD. Und das finde ich eben so fatal. Und da finde ich auch, muss dann eigentlich auch ein Interviewpartner, der nicht Ben heißt, sondern Philipp Hochreis, muss dann da einhaken und sagen, also hör mal, das ist aber eigentlich generell nicht in der Kategorie, nach der wir jetzt Gesellschaft sortieren, weil wir in der Gesellschaft der Solidarität bedeutet eben, dass man nicht in dieser Weise eingeteilt wird, zumal ja auch sehr viele Leute unverschuldet in irgendwelche Situationen kommen.
Das stimmt und das will ich auch ausdrücklich.
Fitness ist nicht nur eine Entscheidungsfahne. Fitness ist eine Entscheidungsfahne, wenn man einigermaßen gut dasteht im Leben und so. Und wenn ich sage, ich höre auf zu rauchen, dann ist das eine Entscheidung, die ich so treffe. Aber es gibt eben sehr viele Sachen, die körperlich bedingt sind, die nicht entschieden werden können.
Das ist verstanden und das ist auch richtig. Und in deren Sicht möchte ich den Ruch auch ausdrücklich kritisieren dafür, dass während Ahrens seine Aufzählung macht, der Ruch plötzlich die genetische Degenerierung da einwirft. Ja, weil das ist, kann man sich dann sparen.
Also wir können jetzt nicht den einen Faschismus durch den anderen ersetzen.
Richtig. Ich möchte einfach nur, weil ich ja sehe, wie die ganz konkret aussehen in Thüringen, denen sagen, sorry Leute, können wir mal ganz kurz ins Spiegel kommen.
Aber offenbar ist da der Ruch auch irgendwie ein bisschen nackwürdig.
Wir sind ja sowieso nicht so die großen Fans. Hier nochmal von Ahrens dieser Punkt, es geht ja eben nicht um die Armen, sondern man kann diesen Vorwurf, wie ich ihn jetzt so durchaus ein bisschen mache, denn diese Leute sind nicht ganz mittellos.
Das ist ja bekannt, dass AfD-Wähler halt strukturell nicht unbedingt alle arm, aber irgendwie alle Außenseiter sind.
So, dieser Außenseiter-Punkt ist nämlich ganz wichtig.
Die Verankerung ist jetzt nicht in der Kirche, oder in der Gewerkschaft, oder im Verein, oder in der Freiwilligen Feuerwehr.
Sondern allenfalls noch so in ihrem eigenen kleinen Unternehmen oder so, ihr Handwerksbetrieb, was auch immer, da sind sie noch so ein bisschen der Chefe.
Oder in den bestehenden Parteien, sondern es sind eben meistens Leute, die irgendwie außerhalb dessen stehen. Das können auch Wohlhabende werden.
So, ich will nur kurz anmerken, es betrifft im Grunde alle Männer. Ich habe jetzt ausführlich recherchiert. Ich habe sehr viele Gespräche nach Abendveranstaltungen gehabt und so. Das Problem, wie Männer aus der Arbeitswelt ausschalten und dass sie dann plötzlich feststellen, dass sie ohne ihre Arbeit gar nichts mehr sind außer an Außenseiter, ist in Deutschland wirklich ein gigantisches Problem. Und das lasse ich mir auch nicht ausreden, sondern das ist wirklich ein gigantisches Problem. Die Ehefrauen leiden ohne Ende.
Die fallen durchs Raster.
Absolut.
Es ist keine Tätigkeit da, wenn die Vereine sowieso schon abgebaut wurden.
Selbst wenn die Vereine da sind, diese Männer gehen nicht hin. Die müssen an die Hand genommen werden wie kleine Kinder, die in den Kindergang gebracht werden. Das ist ganz, ganz, ganz gruselig. Also falls ihr männlich seid und über 40, macht euch jetzt schon mal einen Plan. Im besten Falle seid ihr schon 20 Jahre irgendwo Vereinsmitglied und werdet dann irgendwie so ein Ehrenmitglied oder sowas. Aber das muss man vorbereiten. Da braucht man so ein bisschen...
Ja, in Gewerkschaften ja auch. Bei Gewerkschaften hat man das auch sehr gut, dass das da ja auch nicht mit dem Berufsleben dann enden muss.
Also dieses Außenseitertum ist ein ganz, ganz großes Problem...
.wobei wir dazwischen stehen. Das können auch wohlhabende westdeutsche Ärzte und Anwälte sein. Aber es sind irgendwie Leute, die sich in einem nicht pro- sondern kontra- oder halt asozialen Verhältnis zum Rest der Gesellschaft selber sehen. Und die diese Asozialität, ich weiß, dass das ein vorbelasteter Begriff ist, aber er trifft halt in dem Moment zu, weil er antisozial ist, zur dann schamlosen Maxima erklären. Also im Grunde, das, was die Gesellschaft halt die ganze Zeit schon, was an ihr zerrt und sie zerreißt, wird von dieser Partei zu positiven, also wird affemiert im Grunde. Man kann es so sagen, es ist dieses Stereotyp, dass die AfD die Partei der Falschparker-Anzeiger ist und der eben jetzt in den ehemals DDR-Bundesländern, der so am besten diesen Stasi-Geist den Nachbarn verpetzen und ihnen halt nicht die Butter auf dem Brot gönnen verkörpert. Aber das ist ja nun mal so. Also die AfD verkörpert eben die, kann man sagen, schlechtesten Eigenschaften der Deutschen kulturell betrachtet und macht daraus ein Programm.
Ja, also da sehe ich noch viel kommendes Potenzial für die AfD, genau das abzugrasen. Das ist jetzt in so einer Nullsummschrumpfungswirtschaft ein echtes Problem. Wir hören mal noch einen Clip hiervon, dann referiere ich noch kurz und dann hören wir noch mal einen Kontrast-Clip. Also Ahrens jetzt zum Thema, was ist zu tun? Ich habe jetzt schon ein paar Mal dafür geworben, einfach Konfrontation, nicht alles ewig durchdiskutieren. Also nochmal ein Podcast von Wir kennen sie alle zur Aufklärung von und so weiter. Und dann liegen sich alle in den Arm und so. Das hilft nicht, das überzeugt niemanden, sondern wenn schon Diskussionen, dann nur noch als Konfrontation.
Ich kann diese Assoziation wecken, da würde ich jeden drauf festnageln, der, wenn man über Sachsen-Anhalt redet. Bist du, sind sie der Meinung, dass Dönerbuden oder andere ausländische Restaurants, indische oder chinesische Restaurants, nicht in Magdeburg, nicht in Sachsen-Anhalt sein sollten? Wo für mich halt immer noch im Raum steht, wenn ich jetzt ein Restaurant betreiben würde, würde ich es halt nicht in Sachsen-Anhalt betreiben wollen, sondern in einem Ort, wo zahlungskräftiges Klientel ist. Aber bleiben wir mal dabei. Sollten ausländische Restaurantbetreiber aus Sachsen-Anhalt vertrieben werden? Oder sollte es denen dort unangenehm gemacht werden? Darauf müsste man jeden eigentlich festnageln und auch ihn selbst. Darauf müsste man auch ihn selbst festnageln, weil das ist ja das Alleinstellungsmerkmal der AfD. Das ist im Grunde sein Versprechen. Wenn er an der Macht ist, dann wird Sachsen-Anhalt ausländerfrei. Dann wird Sachsen-Anhalt zur nationalbefreiten Zone. Genau, er sagt das halt nicht so, aber das ist halt gemeint. Und das müsste man jeden fragen und vor allem auch ihn selbst. Und die allermeisten Deutschen, glaube ich vor allem in den unteren Alterskorten, gerade da, wollen das im Grunde nicht oder denen ist das vielleicht egal, solange es in Sachsen-Anhalt stattfindet, weil Sachsen-Anhalt ihnen sowieso egal ist. Aber die wollen das nicht für ihre Region. Die wollen nicht, dass jetzt ausländische Restaurants da vertrieben werden.
Viele Latino-Trump-Wähler wollten auch jetzt Eis nicht und bekommen jetzt trotzdem heftigste Deportation.
Ja, das ist halt, muss man den Leuten dann vor Augen führen. Also wollt ihr das? Man müsste im Grunde, wenn man was gegen die AfD tut, müsste man eben potenzielle AfD-Wähler und auch außenstehende Beobachter immer darauf festnageln, ist das dir ein Anliegen? Willst du dich dafür einsetzen, jetzt im Falle von AfD-Unterstützern, dass ausländischen Restaurantbetreibern und ausländischen Familien Sachsen dann so unangenehm wie möglich gemacht wird?
Ja, also während Corona hatten wir ganz viel so, ja da kennt sich jemand mit Modellierung aus und plötzlich war das so Gesprächspartner für Journalismus. Und ich denke mir so ein bisschen, ey, also das Kieler Weltwirtschaftsinstitut blablabla hat ein Trade Tariffs irgendwas Modell, wo sie so nachschauen, wie sich das verhält, wenn Trump jetzt die Zölle so und so macht. Warum gibt es das nicht für Migration? Aus so einer Webseite, ich habe doch auch die Demografie beim Statistischen Bundesamt, wo ich so einen Regler hochschiebe und sage, okay, zehn Jahre in die Zukunft, moderate Migration, wie sieht es dann aus? Und dann hat man halt Urnen und wie auch immer. Und warum kann man das nicht einfach mal simulieren? Das ist doch jetzt in diesem KI-Zeitalter sollte doch auf Prompt hin funktionieren, dass man sagt, okay, Remigration, was bedeutet das? Also ich bin ja wie gesagt großer Fan, Wahlprogramm nehmen, in die KI schmeißen, fragen, was bedeutet das für mich? Punkt, Wahlentscheidung treffen, was will man hier noch mit wem bereden? In der Inzicht Konfrontation und sei es erstmal über Simulation und dann je nachdem, wie es in Sachsen anhaltet und so weiter. So, jetzt haben wir sehr viel darüber geredet. Wir schließen es jetzt ab mit einem Clip. Der ist von Robin Alexander, unserem Lieblingsjournalisten. Ja. Wir haben jetzt sozusagen aufgemacht den Raum, über den man so reden müsste. Gefühle, Depression, Ordnung, Chaos, Angst. Ja. Und Robin Alexander so im Apokalypse und Filter-Café-Podcast.
Bei der AfD, ich rate, das einfach zu sehen. Die Leute wollen nicht so viel Migration. Sie wollen es wirklich nicht. Wir beide können es blöd finden, aber es ist so.
Aber verzeihen Sie, ist es denn so schwer vermittelbar, dass dieses Land, wenn es Migration nicht gäbe, kollabieren würde? Das Gesundheitssystem würde zusammenbrechen. Keine Müllabfuhr würde mehr funktionieren.
Ich meine selbst Wolfgang Heim hätte hier was dagegen und sagt so, aber wir haben doch noch so Themen, können wir nicht über was diskutieren, nur weil Leute irgendwas wollen und so. Jetzt auch mit Alexander.
Klar, also vermitteln Sie, vermitteln Sie Tag und Nacht, nehmen Sie ganz viele Podcasts auf, die das erklären. Also ich kann nur dazu ermunteren.
Das ist ja so zynisch. Die Bildzeitung Springer arbeitet die ganze Zeit daran, uns jeden Tag auf die Titelseite zu heben, dass Migration unsere Schicksalsfrage ist, unser Thema, mit dem wir uns beschäftigen müssen. Jetzt sagt Wolfgang Heim, könnte man nicht was anderes machen? Ja, arbeiten Sie daran, machen Sie das? Nein, Robin Alexander müsste mal darüber nachdenken, welches Thema wäre dann relevanter. Als das, was ich die ganze Zeit hier mit meinen Kollegen vortrage. Das war ja auch dieser große Witz, dass der Weltenbummel Paul Ronzheimer dann auch noch mal einen Leitartikel zur NRW-Wahl, der Kommunalwahl, geschrieben hat. Und dort auch noch mal gesagt, du kannst ja vorstellen, die SPD muss jetzt endlich anerkennen, dass Migration das Thema ist. Da muss sich Ronzheimer noch mal hinsetzen und noch mal ein paar Zeilen, ein paar Dürre, runterschreiben. Also dieser Stumpfsinn, der dort verbreitet wird, ist wirklich an Demagogie vergleichbar mit dem, was Erik Ahrens für Karah getan hat. Das ist Karah und Ahrens, das machen die Springer im Prinzip jeden Tag ein bisschen dezenter, aber in ähnlicher Weise.
Also wenn du Matthias Döpfner bist, brauchst du zum einen eine Verschonungsbedarfsprüfung. Die kostet dich lobbyistenmäßig keine Ahnung, 3 Millionen Euro oder so, aber hast halt eine Milliarde gespart. Und als zweites brauchst du halt einfach so ein Vorfeld. Also du hältst ja einfach so 100 Journalisten, die die ganze Zeit sagen, hä, das geht hier nicht um Milliardäre. Milliardäre sind doch nicht das Problem. Migranten sind das Problem. Ja. Und das ist im Grunde das Programm von Springer. Aber wir Linken kriegen auch noch was mit.
Erklären. Also ich kann nur dazu ermuntern. Und es stimmt natürlich auch. Also das sind ja die Argumente sind ja richtig.
Die Argumente sind sogar richtig.
Null Migration und ungesteuerte Migration könnte es ja vielleicht einen Mittelweg geben.
Aber wann?
Dass man den Leuten vermittelt.
Hier gelten jetzt nur die Maßstäbe von Robin, Alexander und der Bild.
Migration geben, Deutschland bleibt nicht wie 1950. Aber wir haben das in der Hand und es geht langsam und es geht so, dass alle mitkommen. Vielleicht wäre das ja ein Weg.
Aber dann scheitern sie auch möglicherweise daran, dass bestimmte Milieus auch gar nicht mehr bereit sind, irgendwas zur Kenntnis zu nehmen. Also ich finde auffällig, dass wenn man sich jetzt zum Beispiel die AfD-Zustimmungen in den ostdeutschen Ländern anguckt, dass es oft da, wo es entweder gar keine oder nur sehr wenige Migranten gibt.
Ja, auch das ist so ein, nicht böse gemeint, klassisch linkes Argument. Schauen sie sich an, wie hat die AfD abgeschnitten in Pforzheim zuletzt, in Mannheim, in Kaiserslautern, in Gelsenkirchen. Also das sind ja alles westdeutsche Städte, die von tiefer Migrationsgeschichte geprägt sind. Und auch da ist der AfD, sind erstaunliche Durchbrüche gelungen.
Ich habe das natürlich Gemmina gegeben, diese vier Städte, die er nennt, Pforzheim, Kaiserslautern, Dingsdermannheim und so.
Ich kann das auch wahrscheinlich schon auswendig sagen. Wir kommen jetzt auf einen wirtschaftlichen Punkt. Denn diese Städte, gerade Kaiserslautern und so, da ist ja wirtschaftlich nicht so toll.
Ich meine, dass Taylor Swift dann mal ein Tag ist, ist sozusagen die Nachricht für Gelsenkirchen. Also die AfD in diesen genannten Orten kommt nirgendwo über diese 25 Prozent. Das heißt, wir sind von Bautzen auf 50 Prozent oder von ganz Sachsen bei einer ganzen Bundestagswahl 43 Prozent sehr weit weg. Und die Migrationsgeschichten sind so ein bisschen nur, weil das westdeutsche Städte sind und Deutschland lange in Einwanderungsland war, ohne sich das zugestehen. Und ja, heute kommt die Aufklärung überall von der Einwanderungsstadt. Das stimmt so auch nicht. Also wir können jetzt nicht einfach sagen, dass eine deutsche Großstadt hat automatisch. Nee, es gibt schon Städte, die haben so 50 Prozent, und dann gibt es Städte, die haben halt nur so 30 Prozent.
Köln hat zum Beispiel so 50.
Genau, Frankfurt ja auch. Und von daher, diese Korrelation, die stimmt schon sehr mit, dass die AfD da erfolgreich ist, wo es gar keine Migration gibt.
Ja.
Und da, wo es sie gibt, ist es relativ viel weniger. Und die restlichen Phänomene lassen sich darüber erklären, dass über diesen Pessimismusgedanken usw.
Ja, man kann sich da noch viele Stadtteile sehen. Also die tatsächlich ökonomisch benachteiligten Stadtteile wählen stärker AfD. Das kann man wunderbar nachvollziehen. Und diese Grafik müsste Robin Alexander eigentlich auch kennen.
Also wieder eine Glanzleistung von unserem Lieblingsjournalisten. Wir wollen ihn doch so nennen.
Wir wollen nochmal hinweisen auf den Salon an dieser Stelle. Wir haben das eben nur mal kurz fallen lassen. Wir lesen das nächste Mal Zerstörungslust. Elemente des demokratischen Faschismus von Carolin Amlinger und Oliver Nachtwey. Da heißt es auf der Klappe der Dionysischen Kraft des Faschismus kann man nicht mit Technokratie, Demokratie, Trainings und Faktenchecks begegnen. Auch der Antifaschismus braucht etwas, wofür es sich zu kämpfen lohnt. Wir sind also gespannt, was uns dort erzählt wird. Das werden wir im nächsten Salon diskutieren. In den Salon kommt man über Steady. Das ist am aller einfachsten. Du hast ja jetzt diese Homepage nochmal ganz wunderbar für uns optimiert. Also man geht am besten auf neu20er.de.
Man findet jetzt alles auf der Webseite.
Und dort kommt man direkt dann zu dem Salon-Button.
Genau, man kommt auf den Salon-Button, man klickt drauf. Man kann auch noch mal auf Salon, Suche und Archiv oder so gehen. Da findet man auch alle bisherigen Salons. Da kann man sich nochmal warm lesen, was man so alles verpasst hat mittlerweile. Denn wir lesen ja seit, ich glaube, August 2020 jeden Monat ein Buch.
Gemeinsam, genau, erst hatten wir nur Empfehlungen und dann haben wir...
Genau, also wir haben jetzt schon 60, 70 gemeinsame Bücher oder so durch, plus alle weiteren Bücher, also ein paar hundert Bücher sind es schon. Und genau, es gibt diesen großen Salon-Button. Man kommt sowieso sehr viel häufiger heute auf die Steady-Seite, weil wir einfach die Steady-Seite nutzen als die inhaltliche, da stehen die Show-Notes und so. Und da klickt man einfach sich in den Salon. Man hat drei Möglichkeiten. Normale Salonmitgliedschaft. Gönner. Gönner-Salonmitgliedschaft und dann noch eine, wo man drei weitere E-Mail-Adressen angeben kann für Family & Friends, die man auf seine eigene Salonmitgliedschaft da mitnehmen möchte. Salon-Stürmer nennen wir das. Aber falls man eh schon einen Patreon-Account hat, kann man da einfach buchen. Falls man gerne mit Apple Podcasts hört und da den Button immer schon sieht mit Abonnieren, kann man da draufklicken. Im Grunde kriegt man ihn überall.
Und dann weise ich jetzt auch noch darauf hin, du bist ja auch noch mit einem extra Programm bei Steady. Du wirst da dein Buch kommentieren.
Ja, das ist geplant. Ich hatte schon angefangen, Redaktionsschluss zu lesen. Zwei Videos davon gibt es schon. Aber ich werde wahrscheinlich das doch nochmal elektronisch einfach einlesen lassen. Schon allein, weil mir der Lesefluss dann besser gefällt, als wenn ich mich so konzentrieren muss, zehn Stunden lang. Aber vielleicht unterbreche ich das nochmal so mit aktuellen Kommentaren oder so. Mal sehen, das Format muss ich nochmal genau finden. Aber ja, da ist eine Paywall. Man kriegt zumindest alle meine Texte, die ich schreibe, immer vorgelesen als Podcast, wenn man abonniert bei mir.
Ah ja, ja. Und bei mir gibt es auch rein Audio dann bei der Filmanalyseplusse, also Q&A. Einmal im Monat dann Publikumsfragen und dann den Deep Dive, es geht da so.
Sind Publikumsfragen so ein Ding? Sollte ich das auch machen? Interessieren sich Leute für sowas?
Also ich bekomme viele Fragen, ja. Interessante Fragen und ja.
Okay, bin ja gespannt. Ich werde es ja so hören.
Es bietet sich an. Nächste Woche mache ich das erste Q&A und arbeite gerade die Fragen ab. Gut, dann bis zum Salaam.
Kommt ihr den Salaam, will Wolfgang sagen?
Genau, wir werden jetzt erstmal in ein ökonomisches Thema hineingehen oder sagen wir, wir treten wirklich jetzt in die deutsche Wirtschaft hinein, in diese Welt, die wir ja immer mal wieder so mitbekommen, dass man sagt, ja, es ist irgendwie eine Rezession. Es gibt schon bessere Prognosen für bald, aber noch nicht. Und dann kommt dieses bald und dann sagt man, ja, es war doch, jetzt geht noch ein bisschen weiter. Es sieht alles sehr düster aus und das müssen wir uns jetzt im Ganzen ansehen, denn es ist nicht nur ein Gefühl, es ist Realität. Wir kennen den Handelsblatt Economic Challenges Podcast mit Bert Rürup und Michael Hüther. Zwei Ökonomen, die sich auskennen. Hüther über 60, Rürup über 80. Sie sprechen beide sehr viel über die Weltwirtschaft. Ich habe mir einige Folgen angesehen, angehört, habe…
Ich höre alle. Einer der wenigen Podcasts, die ich immer höre.
Ja, ich höre auch sehr viel. Würde aber sagen, wenn die beispielsweise über die Schulden in Frankreich sprechen, kann man es lassen. Dann weiß man, was da kommt. Aber man weiß, was da jetzt kommt. Die müssen sparen und warum sparen die nicht wie die Griechen und wird das ein neues Griechenland? Die denken nicht in Bilanzen, da kommt man nicht weiter. Aber wenn es um Industriepolitik geht, wenn es darum geht zu sagen, wie ist denn gerade der Status Quo in Deutschland für die deutsche Wirtschaft? Dann kann man dort sehr viel erfahren und ist mitunter erstaunt. Wir hören uns jetzt mal den Take zur Rezession an.
In Europa oder in Deutschland herrscht Rezession dann, wenn die wirtschaftliche Gesamtleistung eines Jahres unter der das Vorjahreslicht, also in Folge dessen sind hier dann bei uns Rezession etwas seltener. Und vor diesem Hintergrund, bei dieser Definition wirtschaftliche Gesamtleistung des Jahres, befindet sich Deutschland seit 2023 in einer Rezession. Und die aktuelle heute erscheinende Prognose des HI für dieses Jahr zeigt, dass auch in diesem Jahr die gesamtwirtschaftliche Leistung wieder zurückgeht. Das heißt, drei Rezessionsjahre in Deutschland, aber in Folge hat es seit dem Bestehen der Bundesrepublik Deutschland noch nicht gegeben.
Wir sind in einer dramatischen Situation. Wir können uns schon jetzt fragen, reagiert die Politik adäquat darauf? Und wir können das verneinen. Aber wir gehen das ganz strukturell durch, denn wir können ja erst einmal doch sehen, dass die Börsen nachrichten was anderes berichten, nämlich dem DAX geht es doch gut, Rürup.
Jetzt komme ich zum Thema. Vor diesem Hintergrund überrascht es dann, wenn wir mal auf dem DAX schauen, dass mit voraussichtlich 115 Milliarden Euro die DAX-Konzerne den drittgrößten Nettogewinn seit der Aufzeichnung verzeichnet haben, dass 15 der 40 DAX-Konzerne in diesem Jahr so viel verdient haben wie nie und der DAX ist seit 2021 um 50 Prozent gestiegen.
Ist ja ganz erstaunlich. Wie kann denn das zusammenhängen? Rezession und DAX-Rekorde.
Ist der DAX überhaupt noch eine Indikate für die gesamtwirtschaftliche Entwicklung in Deutschland, der es ja eigentlich sein soll?
Na, er ist sicherlich kein Indikator für die volkswirtschaftliche Entwicklung, aber für die Potenziale, die Unternehmen von diesem Standort aus erarbeiten können.
Aha, wir müssen also unterscheiden.
Wenn sie alle DAX-Konzerne werden, weil sie Aufstiegs, das ist im Sinne von, wir brauchen Milliardäre, damit die Arm sehen, dass man auch Milliardär sein kann.
Ja, ich weiß jetzt auch nicht genau, was Michael Hüther hier meint. Also er sagt, es gibt offenbar eine Volkswirtschaft, die ist in der Rezession und zwar schon seit drei Jahren. Aber einzelne Unternehmen, nämlich die Erfolgsunternehmen, nämlich nur die 40 erfolgreichsten Börsenunternehmen, sind ja im DAX gelistet. Die anderen sind ja alle gar nicht da drin. Das heißt, die Champions League ist da ja ohnehin schon. Die können unglaubliches Gewinnpotenzial entfalten offenbar oder auch hohe Erwartungen sind weiterhin mit ihnen verbunden.
Du hast ja eben schon gesagt, die denken ja nicht in Bilanzen. Also, ja, das wird hier bilanziert, aber...
Richtig, da wird es nämlich jetzt schon plötzlich so, dass sie dann in dieser Weise in Bilanzen bereit sind zu denken. Ja, erstmal geht es um die Faktoren. Deutschland und das europäische Ausland für diese DAX-Konzerne, Hüther.
Und diese Dissonanz, die du identifiziert hast und ansprichst, ist ja in der Tat beachtlich. Wären diese DAX-Konzerne auf den deutschen Markt verwiesen oder nur auf den Markt, auch nur den Markt der Europäischen Union, wäre es vermutlich nicht zu diesen Gewinnentwicklungen gekommen.
Das heißt, die Gewinne werden im außer-europäischen Ausland sehr stark generiert. Jetzt ist aber interessant, warum eigentlich im Ausland, also auch im nicht-europäischen Ausland, denn es ist doch so, dass die Lohnstückkosten sich eigentlich angeglichen haben.
Ja, das ist so. Wobei natürlich auf der anderen Seite auch gilt, dass durch den Anstieg der Lohnstückkosten in den nahen Märkten, den frühen Emerging Markets im Mitte- und Osteuropa, aber auch in anderen Ecken der Welt, gerade auch in Ostasien, deren Standort schwindet und insofern andere, also das Argument, was damals getragen hat, so heute nicht mehr treibt. Das muss man, glaube ich, ganz nüchternerweise sehen. Faktisch haben wir, wenn man das erste Halbjahr dieses Jahres anschaut, in der Beschäftigung auch die Deindustrialisierung erkennbar. Wir haben im verarbeitenden Gewerbe einen Rückgang der Beschäftigungszahlen von 96.000.
Ja, also ich finde, wenn ich das so höre, auch in anderen Podcasts und so, ich kenne es gerade auch auf die Lohnstückkosten, also dass irgendein Arbeitselement genauso viel kostet woanders wie hier, also dass sich das so angleicht. Ich war jetzt eine Woche durch Gelegenheiten genutzt in Lissabon und muss sagen, also dafür, dass das noch Europäische Union ist, wie da so gewohnt wird, wie man so ein bisschen sieht, wie so eine Fabrikhalle aussieht und so, das sieht schon irgendwie wirklich unmodern aus. Ich kann mir gar nicht vorstellen, dass man in irgendwelchen Kennziffern Datenblättern sieht, dass Portugal jetzt aufgeholt hätte im Vergleich zu, wie ein deutscher Handwerksbetrieb funktioniert und so. Weißte?
Das kann ich jetzt für Portugal nicht sagen, aber zum Beispiel, wir können ja feststellen, dass Ungarn, dass Polen, dass Polen ja einen enormen Aufstieg erlebt hat und das Pro-Kopf-BEP ist gestiegen, gestiegen, gestiegen. Es ist also jetzt nicht mehr so, bis auf jetzt Pflege, es ist wieder ein anderer Bereich, dass man sagt, da kommen mal die Polen aus dem Ausland, die machen das für viel billiger, sondern wenn das so passiert, so hat mir jetzt jemand vom Bau erzählt, dann kommen die Polen rüber, aber sie bringen Rumänen mit, die am Ende arbeiten. Ja, also wir sehen da schon, wie diese Angleichung stattfindet innerhalb von Europa. Und dann aber auch noch mal sehen wir ja, dass die Löhne gestiegen sind, zum Beispiel in China und auch teilweise in gewissen Sektoren, dann in Indien oder auch manches im Pakistan. Bedeutet auch da ist man nicht mehr in der Situation, wie Anfang der Nullerjahre, als Schröder kommt und sagt, wir brauchen einen großen Dieterichlohnsektor, wir sind global nicht mehr konkurrenzfähig. Das ist eigentlich etwas, diese Abstand, der sich neviliert hat, dadurch, dass in diesen anderen Ländern auch die Lohnstückkosten gestiegen sind.
Ja, ich muss das ja auch glauben, weil die sagen das ja.
Und die reden ja auch von Deindustrialisierung. Ich meine, wir hatten zum Teil Äußerungen gehabt während der Ampel-Regierungszeit, dass wenn jemand Deindustrialisierung sagte, man erklärte, das sei rechtes Framing. Nein, da sind wieder 96.000 Plätze weggefallen. Und was passiert stattdessen, denn es werden jetzt auch nicht alle arbeitslos.
Das wird gesamtwirtschaftlich überdeckt durch einen Anstieg bei den sozialen und öffentlichen Dienstleistungen von 105.000.
Halbtagsbeschäftigung von Frauen, die explodiert, aber in den Dienstleistungsbereichen und im öffentlichen Sektor. Und das kann natürlich die wirtschaftliche und industrielle Arbeit hinsichtlich der Wertschöpfung nicht substituieren.
Ja, das ist das große Problem. Diese Industriearbeitsplätze sind ganz entscheidend. Fallen diese weg, dann, ja, was dann?
Ja, die bittere Botschaft wäre das, was andere Volkswirtschaften, wie die der USA schon längst erlebt haben, dass die Industrialisierungsprozesse irgendwann unvermeidbar sind, sich jetzt auch hier manifestieren. Ich meine, wir haben Branchen wie die Chemie, die die niedrigste Auslastung haben, unter 80 Prozent. Da wird auch kein Gewinn mehr gemacht. Also die Branchen, die das Problem beschreiben, haben wir natürlich auch nicht im DAX. Das müssen wir auch sehr deutlich sehen. Das heißt, wir haben hier natürlich einen prächtigen Ausschnitt der deutschen Wirtschaft, sonst wäre er nicht im DAX. Aber entscheidend ist, was daneben liegt. Und da haben wir gerade den energieintensiven, du hast es erwähnt, einen Druck zur Deindustrialisierung, wo man die Frage stellen kann, was ist eigentlich mittelfristig überhaupt noch realistisch war.
Haltbar in Deutschland.
Das heißt, der Hauptstandort dieser großen Unternehmen ist zwar dann noch Deutschland aus verschiedenen Gründen, aber erwirtschaftet werden sehr viele Gewinne im Ausland. Und das ist aber dann offenbar gar nicht aufgrund der Lohnstückkosten, sondern das erklären sie auch nicht so richtig, weshalb das dann so ist, warum sie es dann machen. Vielleicht einfach, weil man sehen kann, dass Lieferketten relativ teuer sind. Hat man es dann dort direkt vor Ort, ist es besser. Also das kann man ja doch auch sehr gut sehen, dass diese Idee von Globalisierung so, man kann alles die ganze Zeit um die Welt schiffen, zum einen richtig ist, zum anderen ist aber auch da, wo das direkt geliefert werden kann und nicht erst verschifft, geflogen und sonst was wurde, ist es nochmal günstiger. Das heißt, das ist sicherlich eine wichtige Komponente.
Ich auch näher an Absatzmärkten, wenn man direkt woanders geht. Richtig. Also manchmal denke ich mir bei so großen Konzernen, das ist wie so ein Tanker, der hat halt hinten so eine Flagge drauf.
Ja, offenbar.
Die zeigt irgendwas, aber ansonsten, das war es dann auch.
Ganz offenbar, sonst, anders ist es ja nicht zu erklären. Drei Jahre Rezession, Rekorde beim DAX, ist ja anders nicht zu erklären, wie genau dieses treffende Bild, das du da hast. Gucken wir mal auf die Autoindustrie, es wurden noch Gewinne gemacht, aber als ich jetzt heute morgen losfuhr, habe ich gesehen, dass Mercedes auch ganz, ganz...
Also Porsche hat einen Gewinnanbruch von 96 Prozent oder so?
Ja, Mercedes heute auch schlechte Meldungen, aber es gab Gewinne, gibt noch Gewinne, da sagen sie auch was Interessantes zu.
Die BMW, Mercedes und VW hier aufgeführt, etwa 20 Milliarden Ertrag im Jahre 2022 waren es 48 Milliarden. Also das ist eine deutliche Minderung, aber es sind immerhin noch 20 Milliarden. Die entscheidende Frage, Bert, ist doch, was machen die eigentlich mit den Gewinnen?
Im Ausland investieren.
Aha, im Ausland investieren oder verkonsumieren, wir wissen jedenfalls, es landet ja nicht hier.
Ja, sie investieren nicht im Ausland oder kaufen Aktien selbst zurück oder haben andere Anlagemöglichkeiten. Sie zahlen ja hohe Dividenden aus, bedeutet, wenn man ja hohe Dividenden auszahlt, dann glaubt man gar nicht mehr so selbst an das Geschäftsmodell, das einem da eigentlich vorschwebt. Das ist schon ganz erstaunlich. Rürup, jetzt nochmal.
Wir stellen fest, dass es verschiedene Formen der Globalisierung gibt. Die erste Globalisierung ist die Exportorientierung, die zweite Globalisierung ist die Produktionsstättenverlagerung. Die Globalisierung wird weitergehen, aber nicht mehr durch eine starke Exportorientierung, sondern durch eine Verlagerung von Produktionsstandorten. Man muss natürlich zugeben, auch wenn es dir schwer fällt, dass der industrielle Kern in Deutschland seit geraumer Zeit am Schrumpfen ist.
Ja, warum soll mir das schwerfallen? Das ist ja von den Daten, ich habe ja gar keine Emotionen dabei. Die Frage ist nur, was bedeutet das?
Und ich gehe davon aus, dass wir das nicht mehr zurückholen werden, sondern das möglicherweise, weil auch die Welt multipolarer wird. Es gibt nämlich nicht nur zwei Welten, es gibt jetzt auch Indien. Und auch die wird man dann erobern, indem man Standorte dorthin verlagert.
Also Toyota hat auch immer 10 Millionen Autos im Jahr gebaut, genau wie VW, mit halb so vielen Leuten. Es ist doch irgendwie auch ein bisschen zwangsläufig, oder? Gerade, wenn da noch eine technologische Umstellung auf sowieso einfache Technologien stattfindet.
Durch e-Mobile-Detail ist das dann auch verstärkt. Aber siehst du da eine Politik, die jetzt gerade versucht, was anderes hervorzuheben?
Also Friedrich Merz hat sich ja damals schon, also in seiner ersten Bundestagskarriere, ein bisschen Merkel war immer sein, die Angebotsorientierung. Also die Idee, dass mal jemand Sensorik hat, irgendwo hin und sagt, wir reagieren mal auf was, nö. Da wird halt fast am Reißbrett, glaube ich, geplant, was jetzt gemacht werden soll.
Das ist der Ordnungspolitik, wir kommen da jetzt gleich noch zu. Standortverlagerung.
Nochmal, was passiert eigentlich mit diesen Gewinnpotentialen? Setzen die sich um in Investitionsperspektiven am deutschen Standort?
Ich möchte jetzt einen Punkt, den du obachtest, nochmal wiederholen. Wenn wir von der deutschen Automobilwirtschaft sehen, dann ist das ja nicht nur die Audis, die VWs und die Porsche, sondern die riesige Landschaft der darunter liegenden Zuliefer.
So ist es.
Und die sind nun einmal standortgebunden. Die können natürlich nicht mit der Fertigung gehen. Das heißt, sie sind standortgebunden, ja und zwar deutlich, weil sie einfach viel kleiner sind. Und das bedeutet natürlich, dass in dem Maße, in dem sagen wir die Marken sich verlagern, natürlich wir Kollateralschäden bei den Zulieferern haben.
Ja, da hat Rürup vollkommen recht. Und ich hab das ja jetzt auch gemerkt, ich war ja hin und wieder bei der E-Metalle auch zu Gast. Dort bekommt man das ja dann ganz direkt berichtet, was das eigentlich bedeutet. Und es entsteht nichts nebenan. Es ist nicht so, dass dann andere Industrien gerade da aufgebaut werden, dass man sagt, gut, man trennt sich vom Alten und es kommt etwas Neues. Sondern es ist nichts da. Und jetzt kann man natürlich sagen, ja, aber es werden ja Pflegekräfte gebraucht. Erstens sind da ja sehr viele Leute schon lange in Arbeit, die jetzt nicht plötzlich sagen, mit 45 ich wollte immer eigentlich Pflegekraft werden und verlasse jetzt hier den Zuliefererbetrieb. Zudem ist das nichts, worauf man jetzt eine Volkswirtschaft allein aufbauen kann. Also da hatte ja Gerhard Schröder tatsächlich recht. Wir können jetzt nicht nur davon leben, dass wir uns gegenseitig die Haare schneiden. Und in diesem Punkt bin ich einfach so verzweifelt, weil ich ja sehe, dass die Koalition das überhaupt nicht als ein riesen Thema ansieht. Wir werden ja gleich dieses Papier da von der Reiche vorgestellt bekommen.
Also ich möchte nur anmerken, wir hatten ja ein Buch, das heißt Abundance. Und da wurden verschiedene Ideen drin vorgestellt, von denen einige heute als mangelhaft wird nicht thematisiert, von denen jetzt kritisiert werden, im Sinne von, warum wird das nicht gemacht? Weil ich denke nämlich auch, die Frage, also diesen Spruch von Gerhard Schröder fand ich auch sehr gut, denn, und das ist ja auch so eine Idee, die man ganz häufig so in rechten Diskursen hat, irgendwer muss ja mal was schaffen. Wir können nicht alle nur und so weiter. Und dann hat man ja auch den Stephen Miller auf der Bühne, ihr könnt alle gar nichts, wir sind diejenigen, die was herstellen, was machen und so weiter. Und die Frage ist ja, wer soll noch was wie machen? Also was wir hier grundlegend brauchen, ist Nahrungsmittel, Häuser, Wohnen und Gebäude halt und so. Und jetzt haben wir natürlich so eine Nachkriegsgeschichte mit, das muss aufgebaut werden, alle müssen ran und so. Aber ich denke mir auch so zukünftig, die selbst genügsame Stadt, die ihr Getreide, Gemüse und so einfach selber anpflanzt in Hochhäusern, die so auf dem Stadtgebiet mitstehen, so wie heute überall hier in Frankfurt Rechenzentren gebaut werden. Also manchmal fährt man ja an hunderte Meter langen Gebäuden vorbei und guckt bei Google Maps, was ist denn für eine Firma da drin? Und da sieht man so, wieder irgendein Rechenzentrum. Und so könnte man ja auch jetzt Gemüseanbau machen und so weiter und so fort. Und dann hätte man, also man müsste sozusagen diese ganze neue Abandonsgesellschaft vom primären, jetzt geht es erstmal um Gemüse und Getreide neu aufbauen.
Nein, nein, ich muss wie im Ende wieder sprechen. Ich glaube sehr, dass man irgendein Gardening und alles machen kann. Bin ich überhaupt nicht dagegen. Im Gegenteil, ich bin sehr dafür. Aber wir haben ja auch keine Ressourcen mehr um eher Deutschland. Aber was man auf jeden Fall machen müsste, wäre ja eine Industrie aufzubauen oder zu erneuern.
Aber welche?
Ja, das ist die große Frage.
Nee, aber das ist ja die Frage an dich jetzt, welche? Also du willst ja eine Industrie aufbauen, aber einfach nur so oder hast du was? Man kann ja was bauen.
Man kann ja zunächst mal was bauen. Und zwar, hast du ja schon gesagt, Gebäude. Es muss also ganz klar staatlich investiert werden, wo die Privaten mit dann reingehen, sodass also tatsächlich Dinge gebaut werden.
Und das ist ja auch eine echte Lücke und da wird nichts gemacht. Das haben wir aber viel verkindisiert. Aber Industrie, was soll denn noch gebaut werden?
Ja, vielleicht hochentwickelte technische Geräte. Also wir werden jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht, also wir müssen eine Binnenwirtschaft offenbar stärken. Das sagen die jetzt hier so nicht. Die denken natürlich die ganze Zeit darüber nach, was können sie wieder exportieren. Das ist sicherlich auch richtig, an den Export zu denken. Aber nur an den Export denken, glaube ich, bringt nichts. Wir haben mit Europa ja doch entsprechend Fläche, sehr viel Potenzial, das ungehoben ist. Stichwort Jugendarbeitslosigkeit. Und hätten also auch die Kapazitäten, hier wieder was zu bauen. Bedeutet zum Beispiel jetzt nicht, dass wir sagen, wir müssen uns wieder darauf konzentrieren, dass wir T-Shirts zusammennähen. Das ist unsinnig, das zu tun. Aber man könnte ja, ich meine, alle haben über Trump gelacht, mit dem ich will, dass die Apple-Produkte hierhergestellt werden. Dann haben wir gesagt, das wird doch so nicht sein. Und wir wissen, wie kompliziert das ist. Richtig. Aber warum können zum Beispiel manche andere technische Geräte grundsätzlich nicht mehr in Europa hergestellt werden? Warum könnte man nicht die Kapazitäten aufbauen? Oder im Sektor Maschinen, die benötigt werden. Wir hatten ja Photovoltaik relativ weit vorausgebracht. Adam Tuos geht ja in dem Böll-Podcast auch noch mal darauf ein. Und dann geht das woanders hin. Das heißt, jetzt sind wir in der Situation, wo man sagen muss, kauft das chinesische Zeug. Wir brauchen das. Wir müssen den Klimawandel stoppen. Aber generell sind ja da Strategien zu erarbeiten. Und auch umzusetzen, wie man dann für Europa eine andere industrielle Infrastruktur aufbauen kann. Und das kann nicht nur funktionieren, dass wir jetzt, und das weinte ja Schröder damit, dass wir uns in eine reine Dienstleistungsgesellschaft entwickeln, weil wir dann natürlich keine skalierbaren Effekte mehr haben.
Also, kleines Gegenmodell aus der Realität. Derzeit haben wir ja sehr viele Schlüsseltechnologien hier nicht. Also, wir brauchen keine Handys mehr, keine Fernseher mehr, kein Gramm mehr und so. Keine Küchengeräte, aber vielleicht ein paar, bei Miele. Weil China. China hat genau dasselbe Problem. China hat eine Jugendarbeitslosigkeit von 20-25 Prozent. Und wenn man jetzt in China sagen würde, ja, wir müssen einfach Industrie aufbauen, und dann würde ich wieder fragen, ja, welche denn? Also, irgendwann ist man am Ende dieser Antwort.
Nee, das muss nicht wirklich so sein. Bleiben wir mal von dem China-Beispiel weg, weil das da ja nochmal ein bisschen anders ist. Das sind ja sehr, sehr viele Menschen. Aber wir können ja hier feststellen, dass es einen ganz erheblichen Nachfragenmangel gibt. Die Leute können kaum was konsumieren, haben wir eben nochmal gesagt. Die gehen zwar durch die Innenstadt, aber sie können da nichts kaufen. Dies alles bedeutet natürlich, dass weniger produziert wird. Wenn die Leute sich kein Haus leisten können, dann wird keins gebaut. Wenn sie sich kein Auto leisten können, dann können sie keins kaufen. Das gilt auch für technische Geräte und all das. Das sind jetzt wirklich Keynesianische Argumente, die ich hier mache. Aber wenn man die Nachfrage anregt, und das ist ja Binnennachfrage anzuregen, ein rotes Tuch. Binnennachfrage anregen wird nicht von Politikern angesprochen, auch nicht von der SPD merkwürdigerweise. Wäre eigentlich eine klassische SPD-Position. Dann würde man ja eben eine Nachfrage schaffen. Und das chinesische Modell hat ja momentan deshalb so große Probleme, um dann doch mal darauf zu kommen, dass man es geschafft hat, einige aus der absoluten Armutszahlen, nicht nur einige, sondern über 300 Millionen in kurzer Zeit. Man hat auch einen großen Aufstieg verschafft. Aber jetzt gibt es da so eine Stagnation. Die Löhne entwickeln sich dann nicht mehr weiter. Es gibt nicht mehr dieses Allgemeine nach oben. Und dadurch wird natürlich auch die Nachfrage geschwächt. Aber man hat ja dort Konjunkturprogramme, die sich sehr auf die Binnenwirtschaft auslegen, auch weil sie schon wohl eher verstanden haben als Europa, dass das schwierig werden kann mit zum Beispiel den USA.
Die Chinesen haben jetzt einen neuen Fünf-Jahres-Plan. Der wurde jetzt auch im Oktober, also jedenfalls so weit erarbeitet, dass man jetzt weiß ungefähr, was da drinsteht. Und Selbstgenügsamkeit ist da oberste Maxime. Das heißt, im Grunde machen die Chinesen schon alles selber. Also sie haben jetzt, seit Trump gewählt wurde, kategorisch gesagt keine Soja-Bohnen mehr aus Amerika. Sie haben natürlich ein bisschen Probleme mit ihren Böden und so. Die kriegen das jetzt nicht so hin, kaufen viele in Australien, wie auch immer. Aber das wird ja perspektivisch, also die arbeiten ja konkret an diesen, ja, dann müssen wir das alles synthetisch machen. Dann wächst das halt in so einem Substratwürfel einfach in der Stadt, das ist halt so eine Fabrik und dann wächst halt eine Soja-Bohne. Und diese Selbstgenügsamkeit ist ja im Grunde übersetzt dieses Bin-Nachfragen-Machen.
Ursula von der Leyen hatte doch die tolle Idee, wir machen hier die Klima-Union. Dazu braucht man ja technisches Equipment. Zum Teil, bin ich sehr dafür, muss man es importieren, und zwar aus China, weil es am günstigsten ist. Aber es gibt ja ganz viele andere Dinge, die zu tun sind angesichts des Klimawandels. Also um sich darauf entsprechend vorzuweiten. Und da ist ja eigentlich ganz viel Industrie, bzw. müsste Industriepolitik gemacht werden. Hüther, versuch jetzt mal einen Einwand.
Ja, aber auch da gilt, Bert, guck mal genau hin, was passiert ist in den letzten 30 Jahren. Dort, wo die OEMs, also die großen Hersteller hingegangen sind dieses Landes, hat man im Grunde sozusagen eine Folge Investitionskette auch der Zulieferer gesehen, weil sie dann Netzwerke vor Ort bauen. Sie hast in China, das sind USA, auch die großen Zulieferer präsent. So ist es ja nicht. Natürlich haben wir da auch in der Zuliefererstruktur, das deutest du an, größere, die, was weiß ich, 23.000 oder 15.000 Beschäftigte haben, d.h. dann Zulieferer bleiben. Und wir haben auch kleinere, die hier an den Standorten sind. Und natürlich ist die Betroffenheit dort erheblich größer.
Ja, okay, ich weiß so langsam, was du meinst. Es gibt ja ein, also das ist ja im Grunde de, oder re-Regionalisierung, de-Globalisierung, wie auch immer.
Die coupling.
Es gab eine, hier, lass uns doch mal ganz kurz einen Kretschmar-Clip spielen. Kretschmar, es gibt eine Konferenz, Autoindustrie und so weiter, alles brennt und dann äußert sich Kretschmar. Und ich denke mir so, genau, das ist nicht das Gegenprogramm, also was du dir wünscht, aber das ist im Grunde, um mal den deutschen Ideenkatalog aus der Politik sich anzuhören.
Es ist unmöglich, bis zum Jahr 2035 alles voll elektrisch zu haben. Und keiner, der heute ein Verbrennerauto fährt, muss Angst haben, dass es im Jahr 2035 abstellen muss. Und diejenigen, die auch in dieser Technologie arbeiten, werden auch noch in den nächsten Jahren eine Perspektive haben.
Ja, also diese Idee, eine Verbrennertechnologie noch zehn Jahre und darüber hinaus weiterzuführen, von der heute schon klar ist, das Tanken dauert genauso lange wie Flüssigkeit einfüllen und so. Da frag ich mich auch...
Ja, vor allen Dingen, ich denke jetzt kann du mal sagen, niemand muss Angst haben, wenn er jetzt einen Verbrenner kauft, dass er den 2035 nicht mehr fahren kann.
Das ist dasselbe wie bei der Heizung.
Es gibt wenige Menschen, die zehn Jahre lang ein Auto fahren und noch darüber hinaus. Ja, aber das ist jetzt nicht die größte Sorge, wenn jemand jetzt ein Auto kauft, ob das 2035 nicht mehr fahren ist.
Also wir müssen darüber gar nicht diskutieren, denn niemals wurde das formuliert, dass jemand sein bestehendes Auto, das ist genau wie bei den Heizungen, es ist genau derselbe Kram wie bei den Heizungen. Wir werden hier einfach belogen von diesen Leuten.
Ja, und das ist ja auch was, was Rürup und Hüther kritisieren, dieser Hickhack darum. Rürup legt jetzt nochmal nach.
Aber jede Verlagerung eines Produktionsstandortes bedeutet natürlich Kollateralschäden für die arbeitsintensive Zulieferindustrie, die sich nicht, sagen wir mal, verlagern kann. Und das bedeutet, was die Beschäftigung im industriellen Sektor angeht, bei allen, sagen wir mal, DAX-Performances dieser Unternehmen hat, muss man in Deutschland konstatieren, dass damit ein Beschäftigungsverlust in der vorgelagerten Stufe verbunden ist. Und der nicht kompensiert wird und nicht kompensiert werden kann.
So, aber wieso reden die so ganz selbstverständlich davon, dass natürlich VW all das, was so ein bisschen tricky ist, einfach in eine Zulieferindustrie outsourst, statt zu sagen, nee, zur unternehmerischen Verantwortung gehört dann, dass man halt alles integriert.
Naja, das muss ja nicht. Also ich finde, das ist ja überhaupt nicht zwingend.
Wenn diese Gefahr immer wieder droht, dass man sagt...
Die Gefahr ist ja noch gebannt, dadurch, dass man überhaupt... Also ich würde es eher andersherum sehen. Dadurch, dass wir noch diese Zuliefererbetriebe haben, der Autoindustrie, ist die Deindustrialisierung noch nicht so weit fortgeschritten, weil du ein Unternehmen mit dreieinhalbtausend Leuten, das möglicherweise dann wirklich das Familienunternehmen ist, nicht mal gerade nach, weiß ich nicht wohin, China, Bangladesch oder sonst wohin bringst. Während jetzt der Konzern BMW kein Problem damit hat mit seiner Größe und seiner Marktdominanz, das Werk in China zu eröffnen, bedeutet also, die Hidden Champions, die Zulieferer, sind eigentlich diejenigen, die noch diese Deindustrialisierung aufhalten bzw. aufhaltend dazwischen stehen, weil sie nicht so mobil sind. Aber diese Mobilität, die ja hier mit der Standortverlagerung einhergeht, im Sinne von BMW kann überall sein, bedeutet ja, die Arbeiter sind ja nicht mobil, das heißt, die werden hier arbeitslos und irgendwo anders arbeiten gehen.
Genau, also ich habe es gerade so verstanden, es gibt diese ganz großen OEMs, die halt zentral einfach ihre Marke, also VW baut ein Auto so. Und dann kommt aber der Bezug des Autositzes schon von einem Zulieferer.
Ja, der kommt aus Deutschland.
Genau, aber eben nicht von VW selbst, sondern von einem Zulieferer. Was bedeutet, VW kann einfach gehen und sagen, wir fahren jetzt die Produktion in den mexikanischen Lager hoch, mit anderen Zulieferern, und damit bleibt der deutsche Zulieferer zurück. Und da denke ich mir so ein bisschen, also das habe ich zum Beispiel nie verstanden, warum diese lose Verkettung, in der man einfach sagen kann, also ihr habt da 3000 Leute, die eigentlich für uns das Produkt zusammenbauen, aber wir sind überhaupt nicht in der Verantwortung, hier greift weder ein Kündigungsschutz, sondern noch sonstiges, sondern wir machen so einen Jahresverträger auf diese Zuliefferei und das könnte dann einfach von jetzt auf morgen, weil für mich ist das ja dasselbe outsourcen, wie zu sagen, wir machen es jetzt wirklich in Mexiko und sei es nur, weil wir dort einfach eine Lieferkette weniger kontrollieren müssen. Also man macht genau dieses Ausnutzenprogramm.
Das stimmt, das hat ein großes Problem.
Und da könnte man ja in Deutschland sagen, okay, wir fördern jetzt mal so richtig, was weiß ich?
Alles in-house.
Und zwar alles in-house, genau. Klimatechnologie, aber in-house. Wir wollen nicht wieder das, sorry Produktionsstopp, weil die Chips kommen grad nicht, weil sich China und Dings streiten.
Also hier bei der Autoindustrie ist das natürlich nicht mehr möglich. Aber jetzt bei allem, was man tut, müsste man das machen. Stellt sich also jetzt in einer weiteren Episode des Podcasts für Rürup und Hüther die Frage, ob Deutschland eine Industriepolitik braucht?
Aber Schumpetische Unternehmer ist ein gutes Stichwort. Die gibt es in Deutschland sehr viele.
Also Schumpetische Unternehmer sind die schöpferischen Zerstörer, die also jetzt nicht durch eine staatliche Industriepolitik dann eigentlich agieren.
Aber gerade Schumpetische Unternehmer emanzipieren sich da vom nationalen Standort. Das heißt, wir haben ja in der letzten Woche darüber gesprochen. Wir haben Rekorde im DAX, wo deutsche Unternehmen Gewinne machen, die man nie erwartet hätte. Aber bitte nicht in Deutschland. Das heißt, wir müssen schon sehen, das sind sehr erfolgreiche Unternehmen, aber in deren Zentrum steht nicht der Erfolg der Nation, sondern des Unternehmens. Und wenn die Unternehmen sich von der Nation emanzipieren, ist für die Nation wiederum nichts gewonnen.
Also das ist kurz vor Justus Bender sagt, wir müssen den Journalismus reparieren. Diese Idee, dass man noch mal Verantwortung für den Nationalstaat in die Konzerne zurückbekommt. Also diese Genie ist uns entflogen und zwar aus guten Gründen und ist ja auch richtig so. Man muss halt jetzt das alles neu bauen über, wo wir denn konsumiert.
Naja, aber wieso ist das richtig so? Also man könnte ja jetzt, wenn man auf dieser nationalökonomischen Schiene läuft, könnte man ja sagen, das ist schon ein Problem. Wenn man beispielsweise eine Steuerpolitik macht, die diese Konzerne enorm begünstigt, sie aber zugleich nicht daran bindet, in den nationalen Standort zu investieren, sondern ihnen eigentlich ermöglicht, diese Gewinne überall zu machen und auch überall anzudecken.
Und das ist ja der Punkt Steuerpolitik. Ich würde ja sagen, der Trumpf ist nicht die deutsche Geschichte und das hier schon mal und keine Ahnung, in München ist das BMW-Hauptwerk oder sowas, sondern der Trumpf ist natürlich Konsum. Also wir haben einfach 80 Millionen Menschen, und wenn die hier Umsatz machen, müssen auch die Gewinne trotz, wir sind in Amsterdam gelistet oder in Amerika, müssen die Gewinne da verrechnet und verbucht werden, wo sie anfallen. Jedenfalls in höherem Maße als bisher, damit diese Länder die Möglichkeit haben, über die so anfallenden Steuergelder eine Industriepolitik zu machen, die überhaupt dazu führt, dass es dort dieses Einkommen gibt, dass man dann für diese Unternehmen wieder ausgibt.
Obwohl wir auch viele deutsche Unternehmen haben, die hier deutsche Steuern zahlen.
Wir haben vor allem sehr viele Unternehmen, die auf der ganzen Welt Geld verdienen und dann wollen wir dieses Geld nur in Deutschland verbucht haben. Und wenn aber Donald Trump sagt, ne sorry, das ganze Facebook-Gewinnzeug muss in Amerika verbucht werden, haben wir plötzlich was dagegen. Also wir sind die größten Nutzen dieser hier von diesem Prinzip, weshalb ich dafür ein bisschen Ehrlichkeit wäre und sage, nein, nein, es ist jetzt ab jetzt. Und deswegen bin ich total dafür, dass der Rürup jetzt einfach einsieht. Also er sieht da noch nicht ein, aber ich sage, nein, nein, es gibt keine Standortverantwortung. Unternehmen machen Gewinne. Und mir ist total egal, wo deren Headquarter ist, sondern da, wo sie die Gewinne machen, nah am Endkunden wird einfach verbucht.
Das kann ich gut nachvollziehen und ist sicherlich auch richtig. Was aber bei der Industriepolitik ja noch hinzukommt, ist zu fragen, welches Ziel wird denn eigentlich angestrebt?
Zwei, sagen wir mal, Ziele für Industriepolitik. Einmal, dass ich den Standort resilient und zukunftsfähig mache. Und zum zweiten, dass ich die Unternehmen zukunftsfähig mache. Und das ist ja meine Frage oder meine These. Es könnte durchaus sein, dass diese beiden Zielstellungen sukzessive in einen gewissen Konflikt geraten.
Ja, das war nämlich durchaus erfolgreich sein.
Also Standortresilienz, was war das zweite?
Standortresilienz und die Unternehmen sind fit für den Weltmarkt. Das sind Dinge, die sehr weit auseinander gehen können und es auch schon tun. Dann gehen sie ganz kurz in einer weiteren Folge auf den Wirtschafts- und Weltpreis ein. Der wurde ja an drei Leute vergeben, die sich mit Innovationen beschäftigen. Ich habe mir die Präsentation die 30 Minuten angesehen, weil ich dachte, ich könnte Clips davon machen. Es war so hirnverbrannt, dass ich dachte, es ist völlig zwecklos. Also die Präsentatorin dieses Komitees, ich weiß, bevor jetzt jemand eine E-Mail schreibt, das ist nicht der richtige Nobelpreis, das ist dieser Gedächtnis, bla bla bla und so, hat tatsächlich in einer Präsentation gezeigt, wie toll Innovationen sind, wenn der Markt dabei ist und kluge Köpfe und all das. Und dann zeigt sie uns ein Telefon mit Wellenscheibe und dann ein Telefon mit einem Kabel und dann ein Smartphone und zeigt uns die Innovationen. Nicht darüber sprechend, dass gerade in der Telekommunikation der Staat eine so entscheidende Rolle gespielt hat, immer wieder und immer wieder. Ja, also das, das ist ja gut, das ist so aus der Welt und das sehen jetzt auch, das sehen jetzt auch, ja, es war aber dann auch so, man hat gar nicht begriffen, worauf es hinauswollte, aus dass man sagt, ja, man braucht ein offenes Klima, damit Innovationen entstehen. Dann denke ich mir, ja klar, also in einem Klima, wo nichts erlaubt ist, kann man wahrscheinlich nichts entwickeln. Jetzt gehen Rürup und Hüther auch nur kurz darauf ein.
Heute sind doch die großen Unternehmen multinationale. Sie sind damit natürlich vaterlandslose Gesellen. Das können wir ja in Deutschland sehen. Der DAX, wo die großen Unternehmen schießen durch die Decke, wenngleich Deutschland runtergeht. Das heißt, Unternehmen haben sich vor den nationalen Wachstumsbedingungen emanzipiert. Und deswegen glaube ich, müssen wir einen feinen Unterschied machen zwischen dem Wachstum, beispielsweise von wirtschaftlichen Unternehmen und dem Wachstum einer Volkswirtschaft. Und ich glaube, diesen Aspekt, den hat Schumpeter gar nicht gesehen.
Nein, Schumpeter denkt an diese Ideen nicht.
Er musste ja auch gar nicht daran denken, das war eine völlig andere Zeit.
Ja, Sie sagen dann auch an einer Stelle ja dieses Denken in Standorten, also diese Konkurrenz der Wirtschaftsstandorte, ist ein sehr neues Denken. Sie sagen 30 Jahre alt, ich würde sagen, er ist ein bisschen älter, ist es schon. Aber Sie haben im Grunde Recht, kommen dann in der weiteren Folge zum Thema Freihandel auf China zu sprechen, sagen folgendes dazu.
Ich bin noch mal sehr dafür, für diesen Detail hier. Industrie und Industriepolitik sind zwei ganz unterschiedliche Sachen. Und man kann nicht immer industriepolitische Verfehlungen versagen, was auch immer, auf die Konzerne und deren Verantwortung und so weiter und so fort, sondern da ganz Corridctoral-mäßig denken, jeder darf jede Scheißidee haben und so weiter und so fort. Probleme sind immer nur die Verteilung von Geld und so weiter und so fort. Und hier geht's einfach. Was will man jetzt den Konzernen nochmal Vorhaltung machen? Will man jetzt Adidas renationalisieren, sie auf den Standort München verpflichten und lautes und zeugliches?
Ich glaube, es geht eher darum zu sagen, wie richtet man dann eine Politik aus, wenn man Industriepolitik überhaupt betreiben will.
Dazu habe ich aber wenig gehört. Ich habe nur Konzerne und Verantwortung und sowas gehört.
Also sie rufen nicht die Konzerne auf, mehr Verantwortung zu übernehmen. Sie sehen aber, dass eine Industriepolitik fehlgeleitet ist, die nicht sieht, dass es diese Kluft gibt. Wenn man einfach nur sagt, wir senken die Unternehmensteuern, dann werden die schon investieren. Dann kann sogar sein, dass sie investieren, aber sehr wahrscheinlich werden sie nicht in den Standort investieren. Und das ist der Punkt, der hier gemacht wird. China-Exportkontrollen.
Man hat ja jetzt interessanterweise in China Exportkontrollen eingeführt. Das heißt, es ist nicht mehr im Benehmen der Unternehmen, wie viele sie exportieren. Das ist ja für mich auch ein Zeichen, dass der freie Welt herrnulkastriert wird.
Ja, dass man in einem Land, das in hohem Maße staatliche Lenkung und zentrale Planung in sich hat, auf einmal auch sagt, jetzt müssen wir mal gucken. Wir hören aus vielen Gesprächen, ob man in Brüssel unterwegs ist oder auch bei Unternehmen, dass die chinesische Seite sehr viel verständnisvoller ist. Weil sie natürlich auch sieht, ich kann nicht mit allen die volle Konfrontation fahren und ich muss jetzt schon mit den USA irgendwie zurechtkommen. Also verschieben sich ein bisschen die Perspektiven Richtung Europa.
Also wir haben diesen abgesagten Besuch von Wadephul in Brüssel. Machen alle Überstunden gerade, weil irgendein China Besuch ansteht. Und alle wissen, also wir versuchen hier noch das Krasseste zu vermeiden. China orientiert sich gerade nicht an Europa, weil Amerika ausfällt als großer Handelspartner, sondern hier wird komplett konfrontiert.
Weil Europa auch immer noch auf geheißte USA Druck auf China ausübt. Sprechen wir über diesen Fall. Nexperia. VW wartet auf Chips von Nexperia, bekommt sie nicht. Die sind aber grundlegend, damit die Autos gebaut werden können. Wie ist das nun? Nexperia hat ja den Hauptsitz in den Niederlanden und ist im Besitz eines chinesischen Technologie Konzerns. Und dieser heißt WingTec Technology. Diese Chips werden auch unter anderem in Deutschland produziert. Ist aber für die Weiterverarbeitung bestimmte Zulieferung von Materialien stark auf China angewiesen. Das heißt also, das ist nicht ein völlig autark agierendes Unternehmen. Jetzt ist es so, dass die USA Druck ausgeübt haben. Und zwar hat ja die US-Regierung der niederländischen Regierung gesagt, dass da doch ein hoher Einfluss sei, dieses chinesischen Mutterkonzerns WingTec. Deshalb soll jetzt mal versucht werden, den Chinesen der Zugang zu den Technologien zu versagen. Und die Reaktion dann der Niederlande war, dass die Regierung, die niederländische Regierung, die Kontrolle über Nexperia übernommen hat. Also man könnte jetzt auch durchschnittlich sagen, das ist eine Enteignung aufgrund von einer Ansage aus Washington. Dass darauf jetzt nicht die Chinesen mit Freude reagieren, sondern jetzt sagen, na gut, dann bekommt ihr jetzt unsere Chips nicht, ist doch völlig klar. Also diese, dass die Chips jetzt ausbleiben, liegt ganz klar daran. Das ist eine Gegenreaktion. Und ich erinnere daran, dass wir das schon mal hatten, und das war Adam Toos, der auch in einem Vortrag daraufhin hieß, wir hatten ASML, da war dasselbe. Die machen ja diese Letographie-Systeme. Und da war auch der Druck damals noch der beiden Regierung, oh, das bitte mal ASML, bitte nicht jetzt nach China, dass alles exportiert. Das war aber für die Niederländer, also auch ein niederländisches Unternehmen. Das war aber für die Niederlande ein wichtiger Markt, China. Und man hat sich diesem Druck gebeugt und hat dann das nicht an China mehr ausgeliefert, hat sich also selbst einen Markt kaputt gemacht, weil das der beiden Administrationen nicht recht war. Und das wurde ja immer noch weiter nachjustiert, auch dann noch unter Trump. Also es gibt auch wirklich große Kontinuitäten. Und das sehen wir jetzt gerade, bedeutet also, dass die europäische Wirtschaft einfach unter dieser Idee von US-Hegemonie, die unbedingt bleiben muss, enorm leidet. Sehen wir dazu irgendwo eine Debatte. Jetzt wird gerade immer so in diesen Kurzmeldungen zu Nexperia und dem Chip-Streit so getan, als hätten die Chinesen einfach mit verschränkten Armen gesagt, nö, wir haben keine Lust oder so.
Ja, also der Umgang von China mit Europa, den muss sich jetzt jeder sehr genau anschauen, weil das ist grundlos selbst schädlich, also als ob wir uns Trump gewählt haben, so werden wir gerade bestraft deswegen. Da muss ich sagen, nein, die Amerikaner haben das gemacht, ich habe damit nichts zu tun.
Und dass die niederländische Regierung Unternehmen enteignet, weil Washington sagt, das geht aber nicht und das ist irgendwas, gut man kann immer sagen, irgendwas ist sicherheitsrelevant, ist ja irrsinnig. Rürup kommt jetzt auf Trumps Politik zu sprechen.
Er ist natürlich auch so erfolglos, ist er ja nicht damit. Das heißt, wenn man sieht, wie unsere Wirtschaftsführer dort Kutau machen, muss man ja schon sehen, natürlich werden Produktionsstätten verlagert, ist das selbstverständlich. Und damit erreicht er das, was er will. So richtig erreicht das doch nicht. Unter der Mittelschicht will er Arbeitsplätze schaffen. Und da sind industrielle Arbeitsplätze eigentlich die attraktivsten.
Aber dann hätte er eigentlich den Inflation Reduction Act weiter profilieren müssen. Das war die bessere Strategie.
Aber die Idee, die dahinter war, war genau die gleiche.
Und interessanterweise wird sicherlich ein Antipode von Rürup, Flassbeck, Ähnliches sagen gleich. Jetzt wissen wir noch nicht, wie erfolgreich wird diese Trump-Politik.
Flassbeck würde dasselbe wie Rürup sagen.
Der sagte auch, das sei nicht falsch, was Trump da macht.
Ja, ich bin mal krank.
Auch wenn die Frage ist, ob die das organisiert bekommen. Das wäre eher die Sache.
Also derzeit die Kennziffern sind ja erschreckend.
Rürup bringt nämlich ein historisches Beispiel noch mit.
Wodurch kam es zur Industrialisierung Frankreichs? Durch die Sperre von britischen Importen. Das hat zu einer Industrialisierung Frankreichs geführt. Ich glaube, das steht letztlich auch hinter Trumps Idee.
Ja, aber das ist ja auch kein gutes Beispiel. Sorry, wenn ich sage. Denn die Kontinentalsperre hat ja dazu geführt, dass Frankreich nie in der Tiefe und Breite industrialisiert worden ist wie Deutschland.
Das ist richtig.
Muss man mal dran erinnern.
Aber es wurde aus einem Agrarland ein halbwegs moderner Industriestaat.
Gut, wie immer das jetzt war.
Also das finde ich alles total schräg, ehrlich gesagt. China ist doch nicht zu vergleichen mit so einem vor 300 Jahren, wo da waren Kontinentalsperre zu Großbritannien waren. Trump meint er jetzt?
Also was Trump macht?
Also China ist in allen Belangen komplett auf mindestens 90 Prozent des Niveaus. So, da ist doch jetzt nicht, das ist doch kein Agrarstatist.
Er meinte das jetzt bezogen auf Trump. Trump schottet sich ab, macht quasi eine Kontinentalsperre, um sein Land zu reindustrialisieren, wie damals sich Frankreich ein Stück weit industrialisieren konnte.
Ach so, wie gesagt, er ist eine Kontinentalsperre gegen China.
Nee, sich industrialisieren konnte aufgrund dieser Abschottung. Da sagt dann Hüther, so erfolgreich war es dann mit Frankreich auch nicht. Gut, das müssen jetzt die Historiker klären, das machen wir hier nicht. Hüther beschreibt uns aber mal die Dimensionen überhaupt, von denen wir hier reden. Also was meint das eigentlich?
Das Zerlegen des transatlantischen Westens heißt, es ist nicht nur das Ende dieser 80-jährigen Geschichte von Öffnung, von Märkten und mehr Kooperation, mehr grenzüberschreitende Strukturen und Abhängigkeiten. Das ist ja das, was wir eigentlich beobachten. Auf der anderen Seite ist es aber auch eine Absage an die europäische Moderne. Und das ist ein langerer Zeitraum. Das heißt, was heißt das? Europa setzt nicht mehr die Standards. Wir haben über China anfangs gesprochen. Andere setzen jetzt die Standards. Und der globale Süden läuft ja auch durchaus gerne dahin.
Ja, müssen wir diese Standards noch setzen? Ich finde, wir sind mittlerweile ausstandardisiert. Das Unglück der Leute und ihr Übergewicht und was auch immer hat nichts mit Unterernährung oder Mangel an sensorischem Input zu tun oder wie auch immer.
Stefan, wenn du noch einfach heute mit Übergewicht anfängst. Ich muss mich heute Abend vor meinen Freunden, die Übergewicht haben oder dann rechtfertigen.
Aber es findet doch in der Verfettung und Verdorfung statt. Und zwar nicht aus Mangel an irgendwas. Und eigentlich bräuchten wir noch diese eine technische Entwicklung. Wir sind längst gesättigt.
Wir wollen doch jetzt fair bleiben. Du beschreibst jetzt ein Phänomen, bei dem du sagst, viele Menschen lassen sich gehen oder sind im System abgehängt. Und das hat dann, wie ich dann eher stark machen würde, auch verschiedenes zufolge mit Blick auf die Gesundheit. Gleich auch einfach manche nicht die Prioritäten zum Beispiel haben, was Fitness anbelangt, wie du die hast. Auch das muss sehr gestattet sein. Es gibt ja auch Leute oder fast alle werden, also fast alle Menschen, ich will nur ganz sagen, fast alle Menschen, die rauchen, wissen, dass Rauchen nicht gut ist, aber sie entscheiden sich dafür. Und ich kenne sehr viele Leute, die wissen auch, dass sie vielleicht ein bisschen viel süß essen, aber sie essen es einfach sehr gern. Und dann ist das okay.
Anders formuliert.
Hier aber reden wir ja von Standards im europäischen Sinne. Man hat damals bei der frühen Klimabewegung, wo wir noch diese junge Merkel hören, die für den Kampf gegen den Klimawandel sich stark macht, da war diese Idee, Europa schreitet voran und setzt da Standards verknüpft mit Menschenrechten und so weiter. Das mag man immer als ein allzu heeres Ideal angesehen haben, aber es war da. Jetzt erleben wir aber, dass das nicht mehr der Fall ist, sowieso schon nicht, weil China so ein großer Player ist, aber auch, weil jetzt noch das transatlantische Verhältnis und der Wirtschaftsbund zerfasert. Bedeutet also, noch weniger Standardsetzung kann stattfinden und sagen wir auch ganz geil, das war auch oft eine ganz brutale Machtausübung, ist es auch heute noch in afrikanischen Ländern, aber man hat dann das Zepter weniger in der Hand. Das beschreibt jetzt Hüther.
Das Zepter in der Hand. Ich brauche kein Zepter in der Hand. Lass doch den Chinesen ihre Schlüsseltechnologien. Die haben doch noch diese Anpflege, noch hunderte Millionen Leute aus der Armut heraus, irgendwo hinzuführen und so weiter. Im Gegenzug dazu Amerika.
Aber kann man da noch was anbieten? Kann Europa noch was anbieten?
Das ist ja die Frage. So, auf die komme ich jetzt. Also China muss seinen Leuten noch was anbieten, weil da gibt es noch echten Hunger. Die Leute leben noch zu weit auseinander. Wenn sobald jemand eine Chance für seine Biografie sucht, du wohnst ja gleich 16 Kilometer weit weg, das ist irgendwie ungünstig.
Wir haben auch 200 Millionen Wanderarbeiter noch.
Genau. In Amerika ist man jetzt längst über den Wohlstandspiek. Vor 30 Jahren, die Amerikaner waren flächendeckend einfach glücklich und zufrieden. Die hatten ihr Medienentertainment, die konnten ihre Ausflüge machen, die hatten ihre Autos, alles. Und jetzt sind die ja wirklich in einem Abbau. Wir haben diesen Death of Despair, wir haben Leute, die ihre Biografie starten mit und so weiter. Und Europa ist ja genau dazwischen. Wir könnten jetzt in diesen industriepolitisch gesteuerten Kampf um die Schlüsseltechnologien einsteigen, was einfach hieße, okay, dann müssen wir auch noch eine KI-Bude und die muss dann so und so viel wert sein. Und dann investieren wir da alle rein und kriegen wir alle ein bisschen was ab. Oder wir ziehen einen Strich drunter und sagen, eigentlich ist genug Geld da und damit genug Handlungsvermögen. Es ist wirklich nur eine Verteilungsfrage. Aber wir müssen jetzt nicht industriepolitisch den Kopf zerbrechen, wo die nächsten Wachstumschancen für die Milliardäre damit hoffentlich was durchsickert. Sondern wir können jetzt einfach sagen, Verteilungsfrage.
Nein, das ist keine Verteilungsfrage. Das ist wirklich keine Verteilungsfrage.
Wir haben gigantische Verteilungsschwierigkeiten in Europa.
Ja, die haben wir.
Deutschland 200 Milliardäre und 40 Millionen Menschen in der Armung.
Aber selbst wenn wir alle Milliardäre aufgrund von Umverteilung abschaffen, dann ist das Problem immer noch da, dass wir weniger Arbeitsplätze vom Monat zu Monat haben und weniger Arbeitsplätze, in denen entsprechend hohe Produktivität da ist. Das ist einfach ein Problem, dass du nicht mit Umverteilung regeln kannst. Du kannst das kurzfristig mal, kannst du irgendwas umverteilen.
Es gibt doch genug Aufgaben zu erfüllen. Wir haben doch nur keine Möglichkeiten.
Ja, Aufgaben, aber wer zahlt sie?
Ja, die Milliardäre.
Ja, aber die Milliardäre müssen ja auch weiterhin das Geld erwirtschaften. Du siehst ja ganz schnell bei der Autoindustrie, wenn das jetzt noch fünf Jahre so weitergeht, dann brauchst du bei denen nicht mehr allzu viel umzuverteilen. Dann ist das Geld verpulvert.
Dieses Geld ist ja da und sucht sich ja seine Investitionsmöglichkeiten. Die Rendite fällt doch automatisch ab.
Ja, aber die Rendite wird ja irgendwo erarbeitet.
Genau, irgendwo weltweit.
Nein, aber das ist ja nicht richtig. Wir müssen eigentlich ja dahin kommen, nicht zu sagen, wir müssen jetzt auch diese Schlüsseltechnologie und deswegen müssen wir die Chinesen jetzt mit harten Bandagen bekämpfen. Das wäre ja falsch. Das richtige Modell wäre ja ein Kooperatives, das so aussieht, wie eigentlich auch mal bei einem Riccardo oder so ein Freihandel gedacht wäre, dass man sagt, dort in China wird jetzt gerade ganz viel, was wir brauchen, zum Beispiel Fotovoltaik produziert, wir kaufen es. Was hätten wir denn sinnvollerweise anzubieten, was die Chinesen kaufen, damit man einen ausgeglichenen, halbwegs ausgeglichenen Handel hat, kann man es noch woanders hin verkaufen, all diese Fragen. Und wie können wir darüber hinaus die Binnenwirtschaft so ankurbeln, dass die Autos, auf die die Deutschen so stolz sind, sich zum Beispiel die Deutschen auch mal an die Autos leisten können. Denn allein der Golf, der ja einfach so als das Durchschnittsauto mal galt, ist ja für den Durchschnittseinkommensbezieher nicht bezahlbar. Das ist ja die groteske Situation. Und da wäre also einmal die Binnenwirtschaft wichtig, den Blick zu nehmen. Wie gesagt, das ist alles Keynesianisch hier. Und man müsste dann schauen, was könnte man an Industrie noch anlegen? Und dann kann man immer auch Umverteilung machen und sollte das nicht wieder so explodieren lassen. Aber mit reiner Umverteilung kommen wir da nicht weiter.
Also die Leute kommen ja immer auf mich zu und fragen dann, Stefan, du sagst immer, die Japaner haben sich dafür entschieden, lieber früher zu sterben, als von den Vietnamesen gepflegt zu werden. Wo ist denn da die Quelle? Und ich sag dann immer, die Quelle ist das Internet. Google das einfach. Das ist der allgemeine Tenor. Und bei dem, was du jetzt sagst, wir Deutsche haben uns doch in diesen Fragestellungen längst entschieden.
Ja, ich nicht.
So, wir hatten doch einen Wirtschaftsminister, der sagte, wir brauchen irgendwas mit Chips. Intel-Investition. Ich mach mal das mit der Wärmepumpe. Die Wärmepumpe heute, Verkaufsschlager. Jeder Scheiß, also überall werden Werbepumpen verkauft. Sie haben jetzt die Ölheizung überholt. 350.000 Wärmepumpen gegen 320.000 Ölheizung oder sowas. Nur wir machen halt eine Anti-Politik dazu. Ja, genau, das ist ja das Thema. Die Reiche hat original gesagt, also ich klippe alle nicht, die hat original gesagt, wir haben uns in Deutschland überschätzt bei den Berechnungen künftiger Stromverbräuche. So viel Strom brauchen wir gar nicht, also können wir die Investitionen in neue Energien so ein bisschen runterfahren. Und dann denke ich mir, was war nochmal der Thema der CDU, CSU, als es hieß, wir nehmen drei Atomkraftwerke raus, was 0,003 Prozent des deutschen Energiebedarfs ist. Da hieß es, nee, also wir brauchen so viel Strom, also wir brauchen nie Atomkraftwerke. Und jetzt steht einfach die deutsche Wirtschaftsministerin von der CDU vor der Weltöffentlichkeit und sagt, ja, wir haben uns da verschätzt, so viel Strom brauchen wir gar nicht. Wir sind ein Land im Untergang, so ungefähr, das war der Subton davon. Also die deutsche Bevölkerung hat sich in sehr vielen Sachen, die haben sich einfach entschieden.
Ja, das ist ja das Tragische. Das ist ja das Tragische. Und dann sieht man auch, wenn wir eben vom Meeresgrund sprachen, an dem die AfD alles auffangen kann, der wird hier gerade produziert, weil man noch nicht mal mehr bereit ist, Rürup und Hüther zuzuhören. Also wir reden ja hier noch gar nicht von progressiven Ökonomen. Ja, wir sind ja ganz geliefert sind wir hier. Wir sind eigentlich im Mainstream unterwegs. Hüther fragt ganz klar.
Das ist das, was wir heute hier im Fokus haben. Wenn China jetzt so mutig vorangeht, oder kraftvoll sagen wir es mal, mit dieser Global Governance Initiative, um zu sagen, wir definieren jetzt hier mal, was souveräne Gleichheiten, menschenzentrierte Globalisierung ist, dann zeigt das hier nur, dass wir keine Gegengeschichten mehr erzählen können. Der Transfantastischen Wissen gibt es nicht mehr. Und die europäische Geschichte, Bert, ist nur noch eine, wo unsere Regierung nach Brüssel läuft und sagt, zu Recht baut mal die Bürokratie zurück, baut mal jene Bürokratie, aber wo ist denn die Vorwärtsgeschichte?
Ja, ja genau.
Es gibt keine Vorwärtsgeschichte. Wir kommen jetzt zur schon erwähnten Wirtschaftsministerin Reiche. Die hat ja ein Extra-Gremium nochmal, das sie berät. Ich empfehle die Folge, sich ganz anzuhören, über den Wachstumsschub, der da in Deutschland kommen soll. Denn Hüther und Rürup werden immer wieder, das habe ich jetzt nicht mitgeklippt, sagen, ja die geschätzten Kollegen und so weiter. Aber in Wahrheit stampfen sie das wirklich in Grund und Boden. Wir hören mal rein.
Das Anfang der Woche erschienene Gutachten, die Expertise des Beraterkreis von Wirtschaftsministerin Reiche reden. Die Autoren, Veronika Grimm, Justus Halkapf, Stefan Kohlef und Volker Wieland haben diesem 30-seitigen Text, seitenlangen Text einen gleichermaßen anspruchsvollen, wie interpretationsoffenen Titel vorangestellt, nämlich eine Wachstumsagenda für Deutschland.
Ah ja.
Ja, ich finde ja, Veronika Grimm ist mittlerweile dieser Öltropfen, der einfach den ganzen Ozean verseucht soll. Das ist nicht mehr gebrauchenslos. Veronika Grimm hat mitgeschrieben, ist schon klar.
Dann weißt du, man braucht den Text eigentlich nicht zu lesen. Hier wird es ja aber doch mal die Mühe gemacht. Was erfahren wir denn eigentlich jetzt so über Deutschland? Exportweltmeister wollte man doch immer sein, will man noch immer sein?
Dass das Wegbrechen der Basis unseres traditionellen Geschäftsmodells, des exportgetriebenen Wachstums mit keinem Wort erwähnt worden ist. Und deswegen weiß ich gar nicht, wer jenseits von Wirtschaftsjournalisten und Podcastern die Zielgruppe dieses Papiers sein soll.
Wie kann das sein? Also wie kann eine Wirtschaftsministerin ein Gremium haben? Und die ganze Zeit ist über die Merkel-Ära hinweg immer nur von der Exportnation Deutschland die Rede. Und hier, da haben wir uns jetzt mal nicht mit beschäftigt. Hüther, es ist auch ein bisschen erstaunt, welche Vergleiche so herangezogen werden.
Die Expertise hat zwei Unterabschnitte. Einmal geht es um die Diagnose und dann um die Therapie. Und ich finde, wenn man so etwas macht, muss man dann schon mal auch in der Diagnose genau sein. Da hätte ich schon ein paar Anmerkungen. Natürlich kann man Deutschland mit den Niederlanden, Dänemark und Schweiz beispielsweise vergleichen. Aber ein großes Land mit 82 Millionen Menschen, mit kleinen Ländern, mit maximal 10 Millionen Menschen, ich sage mal maximal 10, also ungefähr 10 sind, das ist ein bisschen schwierig.
Ja, ein bisschen schwierig.
Da muss er auch gute Stimmung.
Vor allem Dänemark hat ein Nachbarland.
Ja, aber warum diese Länder hat man sich jetzt vielleicht gefragt, warum werden die erweigezogen? Hat man einfach die kleinsten gesucht oder was war der Grund? Nee, man hat einfach Länder gesucht mit einem Handelsbilanzüberschuss. Und den hätte man ja auch gerne für Deutschland weiterhin ganz hoch.
Also reicher und so, das ist kurz vor, das ist der Rampersk-Blödsinn, das Zeug. Man kann das nicht verstehen.
Handelsbilanzüberschuss, das wollen wir wieder haben, damit die anderen das kaufen. Aber da kriegt man gleich noch mal ein Flashback zu. Ordnungspolitik steht natürlich da ganz hoch im Kurs bei Grimm und den Mitautoren. Hüther?
Also mir fehlt so ein bisschen, es wird so getan, als könnte man mit einer Ordnungspolitik für die Normalität argumentieren. Und diese Normalität haben wir aber nicht. Wir haben sie nicht aus geopolitischen Gründen, wir haben sie nicht aus Gründen der Klimapolitik und wir haben sie natürlich auch nicht aus Gründen der demografischen Alterung, die zu ganz anderen Konsequenzen führt. Die Dinge, die dazu genannt sind, sind ja alle richtig. Aber die beiden anderen wesentlichen fundamentalen Veränderungen, die unser Geschäftsmodell betreffen, das haben wir ja schon mehrfach diskutiert, werden nicht an den Anfang der Analyse bestellt.
Also Ordnungspolitik ist so die Idee von Kabinettstisch ist das Politbüro und es sagt der Deutschland AG, was so Sache ist und dann hoffentlich funktioniert es.
Nee, Ordnungspolitik ist ja im Prinzip das Gegenteil. Ordnungspolitik bedeutet ja, wir machen nur noch so eine Rahmensetzung, aber dann unternehmerische Freiheit.
Ja, aber die Rahmensetzung hat ja Zielsetzung. Also man hat dann so eine angebotsorientierte, das brauchen wir, das machen wir, wir hätten gerne in dem Falle einen Exportüberschuss.
Aber ohne irgendeine Bedingung. Also die sagen einfach nur, was brauche ich, wir senken euch die Steuern.
Das heißt ohne Bedingung, die Leute schreiben dir aus ihren Betrieben heraus, was sie sich wünschen und da du mit den Best Friends bist und ihnen vertraust.
Also du kriegst eine Steuersenkung, die Lohnkosten müssen fallen und die Arbeitszeiten müssen flexibilisiert werden.
Genau.
Und dann, wenn wir noch ein paar Euros aus dem Sozialstaat rausnehmen können, wird schon der Markt sich wieder erneuern und wird dank Innovationen alles groß werden. Das ist die Idee, die man dort hat. Interessant ist, dass selbst die Leute dann also Grimm und Co. in dem Paper aufschreiben, dass sie jetzt nicht davon ausgehen, dass große Wachstumsimpulse kommen durch die Aufrüstung.
Oh, um Wunder.
Interessant, dass das auch mal da so erwähnt wird und Rürup und Hüther nehmen da auch nochmal kurz Bezug drauf.
Dass die Wachstumsimpulse, die sehr differenziert betrachtet werden müssen nach den Verteidigungsausgaben, wo man höchstens die Forschungs- und Entwicklungsthemen sehen kann, die Innovationsthemen, die Dual-Use-Themen sehen kann, aber an sich die Produktivitätseffekte gering sind. Auf der anderen Seite, und da nur wenn skaliert werden kann, auf der anderen Seite in der Infrastruktur haben wir eine ganz andere Empirie dazu, die eigentlich positiv ist. Was mir aber dann fehlt bei der Betrachtung, dann muss ich ordnungs-, wenn ich ordnungsgültig argumentieren will, auch sagen, was sind denn die adäquaten Finanzierungsinstrumente?
Weiß man nicht. Ja, das ist doch ganz interessant. Wenn man zum Beispiel das Morning Briefing vom Handelsverband hört, dann bekommt man da laufend wunderbare Meldungen aus der Rüstungsindustrie, Rekorde, Neuinvestitionen, Start-ups werden gegründet, Helsing, unser neuer Star.
Also die Rüstungsindustrie braucht den Staat als finanziell. Es gibt ja keinen Abnehmer, also der Abnehmer ist der Staat. Und der Staat ist die Bundeswehr und die Bundeswehr nimmt gerade die Liegenschaften zurück, um einfach in Hausnummer eins wird eine Bombe produziert und in Hausnummer zwei wird sie eingelagert. Das ist der volkswirtschaftliche Beitrag.
Ja, und jetzt kann man mal überlegen, wie das bei einem Auto ist. Da ist es nämlich sehr anders.
Da fährt man 30 Jahre lang mit Rob.
Ja, und deswegen ist da auch die die eigentliche Produktivität viel höher, bringt also die Investition viel mehr in den Standort Autoland Deutschland als in den Standort Rüstungsland Deutschland. Das ist jetzt nicht nur einfach so ins Blaue geredet, sondern wir hören jetzt Patrick Kaczmarczyk dazu. Er hat mit Tom Krebs zusammen eine Studie veröffentlicht, hat das mal modelliert. Wie werden dann diese großen Rüstungsausgaben sich in der Wirtschaft auswirken? Im Heute-Journal ein Statement von ihm.
Es wird wahrscheinlich einen Impuls geben, aber der wird moderat ausfallen. Unserer Schätzung zufolge werden für jeden ausgegebenen Euro in der Rüstungsindustrie nicht mehr als zusätzliche 50 Cent zum Bruttoinlandsprodukt hinzukommen. In anderen Bereichen halten wir da deutlich mehr, beispielsweise bei der öffentlichen Infrastruktur. Dort haben wir zwei Euro, die zusätzlich generiert werden, bei der Betreuungsinfrastruktur sogar drei.
Also um das zu übersetzen, wenn der Zug pünktlich fährt und einfach so eine ganze Riege von Menschen irgendwo hinfährt, die dann dort arbeiten, konsumieren, leben, dann kostet das Ticket ein Euro und man kriegt zwei bis vier. Und wenn man eine Bombe einfach nur ins Regal legt, bleiben nur 50 Cent übrig von dem Euro.
Ja, und bei Bildung, sagt er noch ganz am Ende, sind es drei Euro. Bei Bildung sind es drei Euro.
Der Tom Krebs ist ja, ich habe ja auch eine Studie in der Kinderwüste drin, wo er den volkswirtschaftlichen Vorteil mit dieser Rendite, die Philippa Segel-Klöckner auch in ihrem Buch über das gute Geld da drin hat, das sind 14 Prozent Rendite. Mehr Rendite gibt es fast nirgendwo. Also es gibt jetzt keinen ETF, wo man das machen kann. Da eine kleine Pointe, nur weil es superwitzig ist. Wo kauft man ETFs? Muss ja ein Anbieter geben von ETFs, also BlackRock oder so. Und es gibt in Amerika so eine Studie, ich habe dazu auch einen Clip, wollen wir später mal spielen? Wenn man nicht in den ETF investiert, sondern in die Firma, die den ETF bereitstellt, macht man mehr Rendite als mit dem ETF. Also Börsenhattel ist mittlerweile komplett irre.
Nochmal auf diesen Punkt, den Patrick Schmatschek da macht. 50 Cent, also bekommt man daraus. Und jetzt wird aber unglaublich viel Geld gerade da mobilisiert für das, was du beschrieben hast. Die Sache ist ja auch, wenn wir jetzt hören, Reinmetall, 20 mal Mehrwert, bauen die jetzt 20 mal mehr? Ist das realistisch? Oder ist das vielleicht doch auch, weil es so eng miteinander verflochten ist mit Start-up, so eine sehr gute Gelegenheit, die Profite zu steigern, wo man ja eh sehr gut Geld jetzt gerade bekommt?
Ach, ihr wollt Leoparden und ihr habt nur uns als Anbieter? Kostet jetzt doppelt so viel.
Ich würde sagen, da ist man noch in einer ganz komfortablen Ausgangslage. Man sollte an diesem Thema vielleicht mal dranbleiben. Wir lassen Hüther noch den Sargnagel einschlagen.
Oder ich würde mal so sagen, vermisst man eine Wahrnehmung der gegebenen Realität, die eine völlig andere ist. Es wird an einer Stelle über Deindustrialisierung gesprochen, aber es folgt nichts drauf. Was heißt das denn? Dann wird nur gesagt, was gerne ja, das ist ja auch sehr wohlfeil, viele Kollegen auch sagen, ja wir tun so viel für Altes und zu wenig für Neues.
Sie kommen aber mit einer alten Ordnungspolitik. Ja, also Realitätsferne. Das ist das Wort, das hier eigentlich genannt werden muss. Wir kommen noch eine andere Episode, da geht es um das Klima, Rürup.
Ich glaube, leider können wir ja perspektivisch die USA als zumindest ökologischen Partner abschreiben. Das Gegenteil ist der Fall. Wenn der alte Kontinent aus verschiedenen Gründen an einer zukunftsfähigen Klimapolitik interessiert ist, gibt es da China noch einen Entwicklungsland, ist eigentlich nur einen Partner und das ist China.
Ja, China.
Das ist China. Deswegen müsste es uns eigentlich, so komisch es sich anhört, an einer Allianz und Kooperation mit China gelegen sein, wenn nicht gleichzeitig wirtschaftlichen Erfolg und Klimaschutz vereinbar sind. Und dieser Punkt wird eigentlich noch gar nicht diskutiert.
Nein, Rürup und Hüther sind sich einig.
Nationale Festung, USA haben. So und wenn uns dann wirklich an Klimazielen gelegen ist, geht kein Weg an einer Partnerschaft mit China vorbei.
Das ist ja mal eine interessante Botschaft in die deutsche Debatte hinein, denn wir haben ja in der letzten Woche einen Zukunftsentscheid in der freien Utansestadt Hamburg gehabt.
Hört, hört, die Leute wollten, dass das früher geschieht. Ja. Was ich auch sehr gut fand, dass der Chancharder gleich sagte, ja, also die Bevölkerung hat jetzt gesagt, von 40 auf 35 wird das vorgezogen, aber es wird noch keine sofortigen Konsequenzen geben. Die wollten gerade sofortige Konsequenzen.
Bis morgen ist aber noch Zeit. Morgen, also heute noch nicht.
Also das mit dem Klima finde ich auch wahnsinnig interessant, denn diese Musialisierung bedeutet ja, im Grunde soll alles bleiben, wie es ist, aber nicht weiter die Umwelt zerstören.
Auch ein Museum muss gut klimatisiert sein.
Genau, also ein großer Umbau Europas, der allen vor Ort eine Aufgabe gibt. Und für so Städte wie Lissabon oder Athen, wo es einfach 100 Tage im Jahr 40 Grad ist. Und ich habe das in Lissabon gesehen, die wohnen ja wirklich einfach in Kisten, so die Leute. Und dann klebt draußen so eine Maschine dran. Und man denkt sich so, okay, damit kriegt ihr jetzt einen Raum gekühlt, und dann lebt ihr einfach den ganzen Tag in der Küche. Das ist doch kein Leben. Also eigentlich kann man das doch richtig krass organisieren, mit China jetzt dieses Problem zu lösen.
Tuus sagt das ja auch. Pakistan 50 Grad.
Genau, da muss man doch jetzt mal richtig den Planeten auf Vordermann bringen. Stattdessen Hegemonie Amerika. Also langsam wird man auch ein bisschen wütend auf... Also man sieht Trump und ist belustigt. Und die Wut, die die Amerikaner auf ihren Trump haben, also der Teil, den hat man so langsam auf die eigenen Politiker. Weil sie sich da nicht abnabeln können.
Das mit dem Klima, das ist einfach nicht mehr fassbar. Wir denken aber jetzt noch in Bilanzen. Heiner Flassbeck, ein weiterer Ökonom, war bei Mario Lochner zu Gast und sagt mal Folgendes über das große Sparen.
Wir haben in diesem Jahr, es gibt jetzt ganz neue Zahlen der Bundesbank dazu, im vergangenen Jahr hatten wir 300 Milliarden Ersparnis der privaten Haushalte, 300 Milliarden. Diese 300 Milliarden muss man sich immer mal vorstellen, das ist das eigentliche deutsche Problem, nicht die Schulden, erst mal das Sparen. Das Sparen ist das Problem, weil diese 300 Milliarden fehlen den Unternehmen. Denn die Unternehmen und der Staat, natürlich alle Arbeitgeber haben ja Gehälter bezahlt, haben Löhne bezahlt, haben Renten bezahlt, aber sie kriegen nur 10 Prozent weniger zurück. Sie müssen aber wieder Löhne und Gehälter bezahlen im nächsten Monat. Und woher sollen die kommen?
Ja, ich bin total dafür, dass wir hier in Frankfurt, und klar, wir können sich alle nur in die Haare schneiden, aber ich bin für eine Verdopplung des Dienstleistungssektors, bezahlt durch nicht abgezogene Mietzahlung. Die Miete muss in der Stadt bleiben.
Das sowieso, bleiben wir mal bei dem Sparen. Also das muss man auch vielleicht für die Leute, die jetzt Flashback nicht so gut kennen, der denkt in Bilanzen und das ist auch richtig, macht ja auch Maurice oder macht auch Patrick Kaczmarczyk und bedeutet, dass wir jetzt hier Leute haben, die bekommen Lohn ausgezahlt und dann legen sie etwas davon auf die hohe Kante. Also zumindest die, die das können.
Ich glaube, wir leben alle in Bilanzen. Das ist das Schicksal unseres normalen Nicht-Böer-der-Seins.
Aber wir leben in Bilanzen, aber wir denken nicht in Bilanzen. Das ist glaube ich unser Problem häufig. Das bedeutet also, dieses Geld ist da gebunden. Das liegt unterm Kopfkissen oder auf dem Sparbuch oder im ETF-Plan wo auch immer. Bedeutet oder im Bitcoin, bedeutet aber dieses Geld kommt ja nicht zurück in die Wirtschaft. Das heißt, ich gehe damit nicht ins Restaurant oder ins Geschäft oder sonst etwas. Dadurch entsteht diese Lücke, Flassbeck sagt.
Da ist eine Lücke von 300 Milliarden pro Jahr. So, diese Lücke müsste in einer Marktwirtschaft, wenn wir an Sinn und an Feld und wie sie alle heißen folgen würden, wenn es das gäbe, was die Herren, wovon die Herren reden, nämlich eine Marktwirtschaft, dann müsste diese Lücke von den Unternehmen geschlossen werden. Dann müssten die Unternehmen 300 Milliarden Schulden machen, dann wäre alles gut. Dann könnte das Staat sich raushalten, dann wäre alles völlig in Ordnung. Das ist nur leider nicht in dieser Welt. Im Jahr 24, wie gesagt ganz frische Zahlen der Bundesbank, habe ich nicht erfunden, haben die Unternehmen 40 Milliarden gespart. Auch noch gespart. Das heißt, die Lücke ist nicht 300 Milliarden, sondern 340 Milliarden.
Wir wissen das von den Ordnungspolitikern, die jetzt hier auch noch mal namentlich erwähnt wurden. Die Grimm hätte man auch noch nennen können.
Sagst du jetzt, wie viel Lindner gespart hat?
Nein, der wäre auch noch mal zu nennen mit seinem Sparen. Also alle haben jetzt gespart. Lindner hat gespart, die Unternehmen haben gespart und die Privatfreude haben gespart. Und dann sagt man nicht, komisch, dass gerade so wenig gekauft wird. Ja, weil alle gespart haben überall. Wird auch nicht gebaut, weil alle gerade gespart haben.
Außer die Armen, die haben ja nichts gespart.
Aber komisch, dass man da keine Wirtschaft mit auf Dauer betreiben kann. Und diese Ordnungspolitiker jetzt, die er erwähnt hat, oder Grimm, die gehen davon aus, dass man nur so ein Klima schaffen muss, nur einen Rahmen setzen muss, einen ordnungspolitischen Rahmen. Und dann werden die Unternehmen schon Lust haben zu investieren. Und da sagt der Flassweg, nee, nee, die haben auch gespart. Jetzt fragt man sich zurecht, das, was auch der Moderator hier fragt.
Es kann doch nicht jeder immer sein Geld beim Fenster rausschmeißen, oder?
Ja, das wäre ja so eine Idee. Wir haben ja diese diese Schwundgeldideen und sowas, ja schon 100 Jahre alt, so alles Geld, was man verdient, wird sofort ausgegeben. Aber nein, etwas zu sparen ist ja gar nicht doof.
Hättest du mal polemisch gesagt.
Nein, aber natürlich muss nicht jeder das Geld zum Fenster rausschmeißen. Sparen ist ja auch schön, aber wir müssen immer einen Schuldner haben. Wir brauchen einen Schuldner. Und wie gesagt, wenn die Unternehmen nicht der Schuldner sind, ich habe überhaupt nichts gegen Sparen, aber wir brauchen einen Schuldner. Und jeder, der sagt, die Leute sollen noch mehr sparen wegen Rente oder so, der muss sagen, wer soll der Schuldner sein? So, wer war der Schuldner in Deutschland in der Vergangenheit? Ob das kann man den Bundesland zahlen einfach ablesen? Das war überwiegend das Ausland. Das Ausland war der Schuldner. Das ist doch schön.
Weil der Staat selbst gespart hat und nicht sagte, wir springen in diese Lücke von 300 Milliarden und wir investieren, wir machen etwas möglich, wir mobilisieren Geld, hat man gesagt, wir sparen, aber wir verkaufen was dem Ausland. Dann bekommen wir nämlich wieder Geld von dort rein. Zum Beispiel, welch Wunder? Frankreich spielt da auch noch Rolle.
So, das Ausland, das sind zum Beispiel die Franzosen. Jetzt sind wir beim Thema. Das sind die Franzosen. Die Franzosen haben Schulden gemacht, weil wir Leistungsleitüberschüsse gemacht haben. Wir haben ihnen Marktanteile weggenommen auf der Welt, den Franzosen ganz massiv, in China vor allem. Weil die französische Automobilindustrie war in China sehr gut, ist dann aber in den 2010er-Jahren von den Deutschen sozusagen weggeputzt worden. So, und deswegen haben die Franzosen Probleme. Die haben ein außenwirtschaftliches Defizit, bei denen sparen aber auch die Haushalte und die Unternehmen. So wer soll die Schulden machen?
Wir haben das ja in Kampf der Nationen nachlesen können. Kann man im Salon also nochmal hören. Patrick hat ja das Buch zugeschrieben, wie Frankreich und Deutschland sich da gegenüber stehen. Jetzt kann man ja einwenden, aber vielleicht haben ja die Franzosen einfach nicht so tolle Autos gebaut wie die Deutschen, aber darum geht das nicht. Also es ist jetzt nicht eine Frage von Innovation.
Ja, wir können jetzt den Argument nochmal machen, die Deutschen haben einfach zu niedrige Löhne bezahlt und die Chinesen haben sich an zwei Prozent Inflationsziel, alles muss immer zwei Prozent teurer werden, auch die Arbeit, Deutschland hat sich nicht daran gehalten. Ja. Und dadurch hatten sie einen Wettbewerbsvorteil, der Frankreich ausgeblutet hat und jetzt, oh Wunder, Frankreich steht ganz schlecht da, so diese Franzosen schon wieder.
Wie die Griechen damals.
Scale zum Fenster rausgeschmissen, ja, nach Deutschland.
Aber es darf nicht sein, dass ein Land wie Deutschland 20, 30 Jahre lang der Gewinner ist und immer der Gewinner bleiben will, wir wollen jetzt unsere Wettbewerbsfähigkeit wieder erhöhen. China hat übrigens weit geringere Leistungsplatzüberschüsse als Deutschland, weit geringere. Der chinesische Leistungsplatzüberschuss liegt bei 1,5 Prozent am Bruttoinlandsprodukt, der deutsche immer noch bei 6 Prozent. Also und die wunderbaren Nordeuropäer, die immer hier als Vorbilder vorgehalten werden, Niederland 8 Prozent, Dänemark über 10 Prozent, Schweiz 8 Prozent oder so die von Krim genannten, in der Größenordnung Schweden 6 Prozent, alle haben Leistungsplatzüberschüsse.
Toll, das ist so verrückt. Er kommt dann auf Trump zu sprechen, finde ich.
Okay, jetzt bin ich gespannt.
Ganz reizvoll, was er da sagt, aber wie gesagt, das ist ja noch ein Stochen im Nebel. Wir wissen ja nicht, ob da irgendein Plan aufgeht. Wir haben ja auch hier immer wieder betont, es gibt dieses exorbitante Privileg des Dollars. Damit kann Amerika überall einkaufen. Das ist ja auch etwas, was jetzt andere progressive Ökonomen beispielsweise stark machen. Flussback ist ja eher auf so eine Idee eines Keynesianischen ausgeglichen Handelsbilanz und kann deshalb dem Trumpschen Modell auch etwas abgewinnen.
Nur alle auf der Welt können nicht Leistungsbilanzüberschüsse haben und da hat Trump ja einen richtigen Punkt. Trump sagt, wir wollen Balanced Trade. Balanced Trade. Und das ist absolut richtig. Es geht um Balanced Trade. Wir können in dieser Welt nur vernünftig funktionieren, wenn wir im Prinzip Balanced Trade haben. Das heißt, nicht jemand dauern. Aber wie kriege ich das hin?
Also sind Zölle dann die Lösung oder wie würden Sie das machen?
Nein, nicht Zölle. Nein, nein, nein, langsam. Es gibt da eine wunderbare Lösung, die heißt Währungssystem.
Ich kann das Argument nachvollziehen und frage mich aber, will Trump wirklich einen Ausgleich, wie jetzt ein Flasbeck sich das vorstellt, wie er das dann auch sagt, mit dem Währungssystem? Oder will Trump einfach eine Dominanz haben und dadurch möglicherweise auch richtige Schritte für eine bessere Industrialisierungspolitik oder so einleitet, mitunter? Das will ich jetzt gar nicht leugnen, aber ich habe nicht den Eindruck, dass ihm es eigentlich um einen ausgeglichenen Welthandel geht.
Ne, genau. Also, Ausland, also Verschuldung durch Ausland und so, Absatzmärkte, Handelsbilanz, das hat ja Flassbeck selber als Allerletztes genannt. Zuerst waren die Consumer, die sparen, dann die Unternehmen, die sparen, dann der Staat, der spart. Und wenn man jetzt Trump Recht gibt mit beim Handelsbilanz, sagt er irgendwas mit Balanced Trade und so. Auf diesen drei vorherigen muss man ja sagen, da ist ja in Amerika, also da ist gar nichts balanciert, sondern da gibt es einfach eine superreiche Klasse, die sich durch eins auszeichnet, sparen, sparen, sparen, alles nur für sich selber ausgeben, allenfalls mal wo investieren, aber immer den Eigentums-Entitlement da oben drauf.
Also nicht nur bei Biden, auch bei Trump kann man schon sehen, dass aufgrund von großer staatlicher Investition, die er jetzt Trump auch macht, bei allem Doschke-Quatsche, kann man schon sehen, dass die Privatwirtschaft auch sehr dazu angeregt ist, mehr zu investieren, als jetzt das zum Beispiel in Deutschland der Fall ist. Das ist schon ganz, ganz erstaunlich.
Ja, wir haben ja auch in Amerika Phänomene wie, dass die ganzen Milliardäre schon das in ihre eigene Lebenszeit gemacht haben und so, schon allein, weil es da gar nicht so altes Vermögen gibt, das ist ja nur 250 Jahre alt. Aber die Disbalancen, also Disbalancen sind trotzdem enorm.
Die sind sicherlich hoch, aber ich könnte mir schon vorstellen, dass aufgrund dieses doch investierend auftretenden Staats, ob der jetzt von Biden oder von Trump gelenkt wird, dies im Ganzen eine wesentlich bessere Wirkung haben wird auf die Binnenwirtschaft und auch auf die Industrie vor allem, als jetzt das, was die Reiche und Merz vorhaben.
Aber investiert Trumps Staat gerade so viel?
Ja.
Wo denn?
Also der KI in dem Bereich.
Ja, die haben dieses Stargate-Projekt 500 Milliarden und so, das hat man noch nicht so richtig gesehen. Und KI finanziert sich eh gerade alleine so ein bisschen, weil es genug privates Geld gibt, das dann so über diese obskuren Pfade bloß kein öffentliches Ding hier zulassen und so.
Müssen wir uns noch mal ansehen, wie sich das entwickelt, diese staatlichen Investitionen. Ich sehe da nun ja...
Biden hat investiert.
Ja, ich sehe aber bei Trump jetzt auch nicht, was das anbelangt. Das ist ja eine Austeritätspolitik, der macht das irgendwie, sagt die NGOs bekommen kein Geld mehr und die progressiven Unis.
Also Trump räumt ganze Ministerien ab.
Ja, Ministerien, aber nicht unbedingt die Industrie.
Bildung und so.
Ja, ja, also das, das...
Studienkredit, Erleichterung, alle negiert. Also da wird ausgequetscht, oder?
Völlig irre. Das ist unbenommen so. Flassbeck hat natürlich eine andere Idee, er kommt auf Bretton Woods zu sprechen.
Es gab mal ein Währungssystem, das hieß Bretton Woods, 50er und 60er Jahre von Mr. Keynes ausgedacht. Nicht von Ludwig Erhard, sondern von Mr. Keynes ausgedacht. Das hat dafür gesorgt, dass wir relativ balancetrade hatten auf der Welt. Und komischerweise war das auch die Zeit, wo die Weltwirtschaft sich am besten überhaupt entwickelt hat.
Obwohl ich auch sagen würde, naja, so ganz balanced war das dann auch nicht. Deutschland hat schon sehr früh versucht, für sich das Beste rauszuholen und war dann nicht immer so fair, auch wenn das mal in dem System so angelegt sein mag. Denn die Idee dahinter ist...
Es muss über das Währungssystem passieren. Das Währungssystem muss dafür sorgen, dass Länder, die Lohndumpfigen machen, wie Deutschland, eine Aufwertung bekommen und sofort wieder zurückgeschmissen werden.
Tja, dabei ein guter Zaubertrick, einfach ein Euro einführen.
Tja.
Weil damit sind wir sicher.
Ja.
Ansonsten würde ja Griechenland darunter leiden, dass wir aufgewertet werden müssen. Hätten wir mal das AfD-Programm damals einfach gemacht, stand immer nur zur Wahl hin, es wird ganz schlimm.
Wir wollen jetzt noch einmal uns, nachdem wir jetzt gesehen haben, wie groß die Misere ist der deutschen Industrie, der deutschen Wirtschaft allgemein, auf die Innenstädte zurückkommen. Maurice Höfgen hat sich mal Zahlen für den Einzelhandel angesehen.
Den Einzelhandelsumsatz hier ist im August schon wieder real gesunken, aber auch das kann man sich über lange Zeiträume angucken, nämlich hier seit 2019 muss man auf die rote Linie gucken. Das sind reale Kalender und Saisonbereinigte Werte, also Saisoneffekt und Inflation rausgerechnet und man sieht Stillstand.
Ja, hier sind wir auf einem Niveau von 2019, 20.
Da schlage ich jetzt voll in deine Kerbe, Binnennachfrage und so weiter. Dass wir hier in Frankfurt, ich habe hier die Zahlen von eben, also 5 Milliarden für Vermietung, 6 Milliarden für Einzelhandel. Vermietung ist einfach, es steht ein Gebäude seit 100 Jahren. Da kommt ein Hausmeister und irgendwann wird ein Fenster ausgetauscht oder so. Dass wir da für 5 Milliarden ausgeben, ist absurd. 6 Milliarden für den Einzelhandel, also Einzelhandel bedeutet, da arbeiten sehr viele Leute, da wird sehr viel umgeschlagen, da muss produziert werden, beseitigt werden, wie auch immer. Also da ist richtig Durchsatz. Wenn man es hinkriegen würde, den Vermieteranteil auf 3 Milliarden zu senken, von 5 auf 3 und dafür den Einzelhandel von 6 auf 8 hochzufahren, ich glaube, wir hätten ganz viel Depressionen schon mal einfach per se, so ein bisschen eingebannt, die die AfD als Meeresgrund abgrasen könnte. Aber nein, weil die Vermieter irgendwie in Japan ihre Skireise machen müssten, die sie, wenn sie nur Millionäre wären, in den Alpen machen müssten. Oh Gott, jeder fährt in die Alpen. Wir wollen natürlich nach Japan zum Skifahren. Dann muss das Geld einfach aus der Stadt abgesaugt werden. Und es gibt keinen volkswirtschaftlichen Beitrag durch diese Verknüpfung von diesen Geldsträuben.
Ich bin mit Ole im nächsten Monat in Innsbruck und hatte jetzt schon da einer Zeitung ein Interview gegeben. Da geht es um die Mieten, die auch in Innsbruck katastrophal hoch sind.
Weil ich da nur Tourist bin.
Und dann ging es auch darum, ja, aber das Kapital, das dahintersteht, dann sag ich ja, die eine Seite des Kapitals. Während das ja nicht so ist, dass wenn die Mieten niedriger wären, das Geld dann sonst wo landen würde, sondern wir können ganz konkret sagen, wo das landet. Im Restaurant, im Kino, im Modegeschäft. Dort würde das Geld eigentlich landen. Das heißt, es gibt nicht da den Kapitalismus, sondern da gibt es sehr widerstreitende Interessen.
Wenn du in Brandenburg bist, musst du oben auf den Berg und dann fällst du mit einer großen auf die Seegrube und dann kannst du noch höher. Dann bist du mal richtig oben. Das ist ganz toll. Dann kannst du nach Deutschland rüber gucken.
Uri, es spricht jetzt von der Kaufkraft.
Warum? Na ja, weil die Kaufkraft der Leute halt noch immer auf dem Niveau von vor 2020 verharrt. Die Reallöhne auf dem Niveau sind, da muss man sich auch nicht wundern, wenn sie weniger einkaufen. Zusätzlich zu den Reallöhnen, die auf dem Niveau von 2019 sind, kommt übrigens erschwerend hinzu, dass ja die Sozialabgaben seitdem gestiegen sind, ungefähr um einen Prozentpunkt. Das heißt, die Bruttolöhne haben so wenig Kaufkraft wie 2019. Von Brutto zu Netto geht aber noch ein Prozentpunkt heute mehr ab als 2019. Bleibt also noch weniger über. Ja, kein Wunder, dass die Einzelhandelsgeschäfte so schlechte Daten aufweisen. Jetzt kann man ja mal flott überlegen, in welcher Lanz-Illner-Meichberger-Talkshow man sich da... Ich habe mich daran erinnert, dass zum Beispiel über die Einzelhandelsumsätze gesprochen wurde.
Sehr gut. Wenn man was dazu hört, dann und ich flippe wirklich aus, wenn ich jetzt nochmal höre, ist die Kauflaune der Deutschen ist schlecht.
Die Kauflaune, ja.
Es ist keine Frage der Laune und das können eigentlich nur Leute sagen und schreiben, bei denen das Geld so dicke da ist, dass die tatsächlich sagen, ich habe mal Lust, 500 Euro auszugeben. Ich gehe heute mal noch ins Städtchen.
Wenn ich 20.000 Euro die Stunde für eine Moderation im Fernsehen abends kriege, die ein Team für mich vorbereitet, also ich habe sozusagen sehr viel Zeit meiner Kauflaune und ich muss nur eine Stunde arbeiten, dann hätte ich auch sowas wie Kauflaune. Aber leider ist das nur für ganz wenige Leute. Ich finde jedenfalls, ich will mal ein Play-Doh dafür machen. Du hast ja vorhin schon angefangen, die denken aber nicht in Bilanzen. Das scheint mir wirklich ein sehr guter Hinweis zu sein. Wir müssen hier wirklich mehr in Bilanzen einfach Strich drunter. Also unterm Strich zähle ich. Was bedeutet das jetzt? Lieber und dann egal, wer auch immer redet mit einem gerade.
Helfen würde es auch, wenn die Unternehmer, die ja eigentlich in Bilanzen denken müssen, notwendigerweise auch in Bilanzen denken, wenn sie über Volkswirtschaft nachdenken. Wir haben so viele Unternehmer, die sich äußern zu dem, was gerade schief läuft. Und was sie dann sagen, ist der Sozialstaat ist zu groß. Und diese ganzen Dinge, diese Unternehmer müssten eigentlich auf der Straße stehen und sich für Mehrzahlungen einsetzen und all das. Denn dieses Geld, das schließt ja an sie. Es ist ja verrückt. Eigentlich ist ja Bürgergelderhöhung eine Erhöhung des Umsatzes bei Lidl Schwarz. Wir hören zum Schluss da noch Flassbeck zu.
Aber meine Vermutung ist auch ein bisschen Unternehmer, die im Fernsehen auftreten, bei der IHK einen Vortrag halten oder so. Die haben, glaube ich, mit Bilanzierung schon lange nichts mehr zu tun.
Wahrscheinlich.
Das ist ausgelagerte Bürokratie. Das machen halt die Leute da beim Personal und beim Rechnungswesen und so.
Vielleicht sollten wir mal so eine Tour machen durch die IHKs gegen ein hohes Honorar und dann erzählen wir denen mal, wie eigentlich zu denken ist.
Also wenn man einen Unternehmer öffentlich sieht, muss man ihn eigentlich wieder dran erinnern, sag mal, du bist doch Unternehmer. Also bilanziert ihr eigentlich? Und dann muss er ja sagen, ja. Und dann merkt er, er ist nicht sprechfähig bei seinem eigenen Unternehmen.
Du bist ja sehr für Konfrontation.
Das ist eine Konfrontation.
Flassbeck auch.
Ich sag gerade, dreieinhalb Jahre geht die Nachfrage zurück und unsere Politiker sagen, alle Unisonen müssen jetzt mal die Nachfrage kürzen. Wir müssen jetzt mal Bürgergeld, wir müssen mal an die Löhne, wir müssen an irgendwas, wir müssen den Sozialstaat zusammen streichen. Kürzen, das ist alles Kürzung von Nachfrage. Das alles betrifft unmittelbar wie die Unternehmen. Die Leute kaufen ja fast mit dem Geld. Wenn man den Geld wegnimmt, kaufen sie weniger. Dann haben die Unternehmen weniger Gewinne. Es geht immer um die Unternehmen. Nur das idiotische, Herr Lochner, ist, ich habe vor einiger Zeit leider einen Aufsatz schreiben müssen, der hieß, warum sind die Unternehmer nur so dumm? Die Unternehmer begreifen das nicht. Die Unternehmer begreifen diesen Zusammenhang nicht.
Ja, warum sind die Unternehmer so dumm?
Die Unternehmer bremsen. Okay, wir haben noch ein bisschen Zeit. Wir gehen jetzt hier mal Reichtumsclips durch, womit ich auch anmerke, es gibt noch viele andere wichtige Themen, die wir leider ein bisschen aussparen müssen, aber hier Reichtum, der All-in-Podcast. Ich habe ihn schon mal vorgestellt, da sitzen drei Milliardäre und der andere hat leider nur 600 Millionen, also dreieinhalb Milliardäre so zusammen. Und hier hört man mal, wie das so klingt, wenn die so, ich weiß auch nicht genau, manchmal reden die einfach so.
So, du bist gegangen und hast diese wunderschöne Aero, die wir alle in der Region nehmen.
Emirates First Class, ja.
Oh, Emirates First Class. Mit dem Wein?
Nimm alle wieder, denn ich mache Business Class für 14 Mal im Rund. Emirates ist unglaublich. Aber das Problem ist, es gibt ca. Also musst du 30 oder 40 von denen favorieren.
Warte mal ab, bis der Starlink in allen Flugzeugen mit WLAN ist, dann hast du alle Filme.
Ach so, die fliegen so oft, Ich glaube, dass die Auswahl knapp wird der Filme.
Er freut sich jetzt darüber, dass man tausend Filme der Auswahl hat, wenn man in Emirates fliegt, wo ich mir denke, ja das ist wie als ich zehn war und es hieß da oben auf dem Berg, da wohnt der Peter und der Vater, der hat 300 Videokassetten zu Hause. Ich sehe mir so ein Switch umgelegt, Internet überall und es spielt alles keine Rolle mehr.
Es gab 95 verschiedene Menü-Einkaufs, ich hatte wahrscheinlich 8000 Kalorien. Und das war nur der Wein, den ich genommen habe. Der Wein ist unglaublich, die Wine-Liste, 1996 Montrose und ich dachte, habe ich noch nie einen Air-Line-Wine-Liste gesehen? Es war ziemlich stark.
Hast du deinen Sommier Josh gebracht?
War er in deinem Kabin neben dir in seiner Zone?
Ich habe ihn nicht gebraucht.
Ich mag das, ich mag das.
Und du bist natürlich der Sultan von den Signen.
Du hast einen tollen Docket für ihn.
Es ist wie die Super Bowl für Sultan-Fans.
Ist es?
Ja.
Ja, bla, bla, bla. Also Emirates betreibt eine First Class. Die kostet, wenn man so 10 Stunden fliegt, irgendwie 20.000 Euro oder so. Für Leute, denen es auch egal ist, ob sie jetzt 20 oder 25.000 Euro sind. Und die fliegen die ganze Zeit 30 Jahre alte Wein rum, für den Fall, dass es mal einer bestellt, während es fliegt. Muss man sich aber vorstellen. Gut, im selben Podcast wird eine Beschwerde geäußert. Also wenn mal so ein großer Fundmanager irgendwie Probleme hat, finanziell sich verschätzt hat, keiner kümmert sich darum. Aber.
Wenn es den Konsumenten schlägt, wenn es den Individuen schlägt, dann gibt es diesen Schuss zur Protektion. Ist das fair, wenn man sich auf das, was passiert ist, aus dem 29% aus dem 08%?
Die Milliardäre haben es am schwersten.
Die armen Milliardäre werden die ganze Zeit transalliert, während die, ach so, du hast als Konsumer Probleme, der Staat springt das sofort bei. Also das ist so deren, so leben die. Noch ein Clip aus dem All In Podcast.
Und so war die große Transition in meinem Leben, wow, ich kann ein Apartment bekommen, ich muss nicht 12 Stunden pro Tag arbeiten, physische Arbeit in den Regionen, ich kann eigentlich leben und in einem Großerie-Store gehen und tolle Futter bekommen und Leute treffen und sozialisieren und in dieser tollen Stadt leben. Und das war, bevor wir all diese Versprechen gemacht haben, die ich denke, an diese Erwartungen leden, die die Leute dann zu verabschieden fühlen und sie verblieben alles auf den Fehler des Kapitalismus. Meine persönliche Meinung, wie du weißt, ist, dass es grundsätzlich eine Funktion des Überspenden von der Regierung ist und der Überverwahrung, anstatt natürliche Marktförderung zu erlauben, um alle zu bringen.
Ich versuche mit Psychologie weiterzukommen. Ich kriege das auch nie so ganz zusammen. Also man kann ja sagen, Mensch, da habe ich aber Glück gehabt. Ich gehöre zu den 0,001 Prozent und ich halte jetzt einfach den Mund und fahre mit Fliege, mit Fuss, Klasse und gucke mir alle 1000 Filme an und trinke alle Weine aus. Das ist ganz wichtig, dann könnte man ja noch sagen, okay, ich halte jetzt den Mund. Aber dann einen Podcast zu machen und dann noch zu sagen, also diese Armen und diese normalen Leute und die verlassen sich auf den Staat, so geht es ja nicht. Also das ist doch unfassbar.
So, wir haben jetzt dreimal in so einen Podcast reingehört, wo völlig klar ist, also mit einer inhaltlichen Aufklärung kommen wir hier nicht weiter. Also hier muss einfach die Entscheidung politisch zwischen Trump und Mandami fallen und dann muss sich die Bevölkerung einfach entscheiden, ob man jetzt und so weiter, was man da macht. Nun führen wir ja trotzdem Diskurse in Fernsehsendungen. Einer der bekanntesten Deutschen ist ja Lanz, der so eine Fernsehsendung hat. Jetzt denkt man so, ah ja, Lanz bietet also ein Forum, wo mal offen diskutiert wird, was man so tun könnte und so weiter. Aber was ist, wenn der Moderator selbst einfach zu diesen All-in-Leuten gehört, der die ganze Zeit nur mit Emirates um die Welt fliegt und 30 Jahre alten Weinen im Flugzeug? Oh, den haben sie dabei? Cool, servieren sie mal.
Da hat sich ja offensichtlich in der Haltung etwas verändert. Also ich habe manchmal den Eindruck, der Sozialstaat, so wie wir ihn heute definieren, ist sozusagen etwas, was versucht, maximal gerecht zu sein. Nach allen Seiten und nach allen Buchstaben des Gesetzes, maximal gerecht zu sein.
Man sieht sich die Realität an, 2,5 Millionen Kinder in Armut, meine Tochter mit 15 in einer Elite-Schule des Sports, jahresweise die best ausgezeichnete Schule des deutschen Sports. Nö, also Schuljahr geht jetzt drei Monate, Physik fand noch keine einzige Stunde statt. Im der zehnten Klasse, also da, wo es auch ein bisschen drauf ankommt, die Biografie zu sortieren. Ja, also der Staat tritt hier alles auf maximale Gerechtigkeit, verteilt alle Chancen genau fair und genau Herr Lanz, könnten Sie einfach bitte die deutschen Diskurse zum Thema führen? Wir können Ihnen so eine Fernsehsendung geben.
Ich bin so wütend darüber, dass das sein kann.
Wir wollen noch wütender werden. Wir hören jetzt unseren Lieblingsjournalisten Robin Alexander. Wir haben ihn ja eben schon in einem sehr überzeugenden Clip gehört. Jetzt haben wir also einen Staat, der in Amerika, wie die Milliardäre sagen, immer zu viel verspricht, immer zu viel bezahlt, wie wir in Deutschland hören. Das Maximale an Gerechtigkeit rausholt. Was bedeutet, wir brauchen jetzt mal, original wortlaut, achte drauf, einen großen Sprung nach vorn.
Als Thomas de Maizière, der frühere Kanzleramtschef, 70 Jahre alt wurde, veranstaltete die Konrad-Adenauer-Stiftung ein Symposium. Da war de Maizière, da war der damalige Kanzleramtschef Wolfgang Schmitt und da war eine ehemalige Verfassungsrichterin, die du heute schon mal genannt hast, nämlich Gertrude Lübe-Wolff. Und auf diesem Symposium, wo erstaunlich offen und frei gesprochen wurde, machte de Maizière den Punkt, man sei gebunden bei den Zahlungen, die man Flüchtlinge, damals ging es noch um Flüchtlinge, leiste, wegen dieser Rechtsprechung des Bundesverfassungsgerichts.
Also Existenzminimum und so, Artikel 1 Grundgesetz, Menschenwürde.
Können wir leider nicht runter.
Und Wolfgang Schmitt flüchtete ihm bei, also die Politik erklärte lagerübergreifend, wir können nichts machen, das Verfassungsgericht hat uns einbetoniert. Und die ehemalige Verfassungsrichterin sagte, man müsse sich schon an das halten, was das Verfassungsgericht entschieden habe, aber sie empfehle den Begriff Denkenden Gehorsam. Und Denkender Gehorsam.
Ja, das ist übrigens auch in Alexander Humor. Also bei sowas fängt er dann an zu lachen.
Können wir denen unten noch was wegnehmen.
Das ist doch superwitzig.
Und Denkender Gehorsam meinte nicht alles eins zu eins, sondern den Sinn erahnen.
Also Artikel 1 Menschen würde ein aktuelles Verfassungsgerichtsurteil dazu, aber jetzt noch mal den Sinn erahnen.
Also ich mein, man muss sich das mal vorstellen, wir können auch mal hier sitzen und es wäre ja richtig gut, wenn der Robin Alexander die nächsten zwei Monate keinen Gehalt bekommt. Ist doch einfach mal auch mal ein bisschen mitgedacht.
Also er hat ja noch ein bisschen Reserve, da braucht er jetzt nicht immer unsere Alimentierung. Warum auch nicht.
Sind erahnen. Und ein bisschen wurde bei der Veranstaltung vermittelt, wenn die Politik noch mal ein Gesetz machen würde und das Gesetz würde beklagt, könnte das Verfassungsgericht ja auch im Lichte neuer Erkenntnisse auch ein neues Urteil fällen.
Was sollen denn die neuen Erkenntnisse sein? Artikel 1 doch nicht so wichtig?
Es reicht auch mit Wasser und Brot.
Es ist wirklich absurd.
Auch ein neues Urteil fällen. Wie gesagt, damals total interessant, aber auf den Bereich Sozialleistung für Flüchtlinge gedanklich beschränkt. Wenn man das jetzt aber nimmt und wendet es an auf Merz, dass auch Merz sagt, Moment, ist denn das wirklich vom Gericht, war das geplant, die Politik so festzulegen? Oder können wir beim Bürgergeld nicht mal einen neuen Ansatz machen? Dann natürlich implizit eine Klage in Kauf nehmen und dann aber tatsächlich zu einer relevanten Veränderung kommen. Was ein bold move wäre und auch die Frage, ob die SPD den mitginge, aber natürlich große Lösungen werden gebraucht, auch große Reformen, das wäre der Versuch eines großen Sprungs nach vorn.
Ja, das ist genau das. Ich meine, da kann er dann nochmal den Heinies bei Apokalypse und Filtercafé erzählen und all diesen tollen Berlin Mitte Podcasts und wie die alle heißen, diese von links liberal bis rechts, es sind sich da alle einig, weil sie zu dumm sind, darüber nachzudenken, was jetzt eben Rürup, Flassbeck und alle anderen ausgeführt haben, wo eigentlich die Misere zu suchen und zu finden ist. Und wir reden hier nach wie vor darüber, ob man eine, zwei, drei, vier, fünf Milliarden wo sparen kann, wo eigentlich schon das Verfassungsgericht sagt, da geht es nicht mehr weiter. Dann machen die nochmal ein Fass auf, weil sie zu doof sind über die wirtschaftliche Situation, in der wir uns befinden, vernünftig nachzudenken. Diese Realitätsverweigerung, die als Expertise sich laufen tarnt. Robin Alexander, der große Politikversprecher und sonst was. Das ist wirklich unser Sargnagel für die Demokratie. Das ist mindestens genauso schlimm wie jedes propagandistische Video der AfD.
Wir können ja schon mal so ein bisschen in die Zukunft schauen. In Griechenland hieß es vor zehn Jahren, ne, da ist noch ein bisschen was zu machen. Also die können mal noch so ein bisschen, so Griechenland jetzt zehn Jahre später, also heute macht was und wir können jetzt so denken, ja okay, also 2033 sind wir dann so weit.
In Griechenland sind künftig Arbeitstage mit bis zu 13 Stunden möglich. Über diese Neuerung mehr von Moritz Pompel aus Athen.
Mit der Maßnahme will die griechische Regierung den Fachkräftemangel bekämpfen.
Ich meine 13 Stunden, ne, du kommst morgens acht Uhr zur Arbeit und weißt, du bist jetzt hier bis 21 Uhr.
Ja.
Wer kommt denn auf so eine Idee und verspricht sich da noch Produktivität?...
und Schwarzarbeit eindämmen.
Die Überstunden sollen mit... Das ist eine Handhabe gegen Schwarzarbeit.
Ah ja....
mit einem Aufschlag von 40 Prozent vergütet werden. Grundsätzlich betont Arbeitsministerin Niki Kerameus, bleibe aber der 8-Stunden-Tag die Regel. 13-Stunden-Tage soll...
Also eigentlich bleibt auch Artikel 1 die Regel, aber ja......
soll limitiert werden, auf höchstens 37 Mal im Jahr. Viele Griechinnen und Griechen gehen mehreren Jobs nach, mit dem neuen Gesetz, so das Argument der Regierung, sollen sie von nur einem Job leben können.
Verstehst du?
Ach so, ja gut, so kann man es natürlich auch machen. Ja, also du brauchst nicht mehr zwei Jobs, weil wenn du 13 Stunden arbeitest, wirst du nicht noch einen zweiten annehmen können. Lass uns dann aber noch die beiden Clips spielen, die ich eigentlich für das Ende vorbereitet habe, weil da geht es ja um Arbeitszeit. Es gab einen kleinen viralen Hit, einen Model, Julian Kamps, kannte ich nicht. Ähm, dort bei den Neunern. Julian Kamps war wohl bei Germany's Next Top Model mal dabei und hat dann folgendes TikTok gepostet, das viral ging.
Leute, ich arbeite ja seit drei Wochen. Es ist jetzt die dritte Woche. Krass, wie schnell die Zeit vergeht. Wir haben jetzt 18.41 Uhr. Ich habe das Haus um 17.30 Uhr verlassen. Ich bin jetzt gerade kurz vor meiner Haustür. Ich wollte mir doch nicht sagen, dass das das Leben ist. Ich hätte jetzt legit dreieinhalb Stunden umzuleben, damit ich morgen früh wieder fit bin, um auf die Arbeit zu gehen. Das kann es doch nicht sein. Das ist doch Quatsch. Das ist doch quatschig, Leute. Sagt mir bitte, dass ich nicht der Einzige bin, der sich so fühlt. Also wirklich. Es muss auf jeden Fall mal eine Stunde reduzieren. 100 Prozent geht gar nicht. Hört sich jetzt vielleicht noch mega gensieren, aber was soll das?
Sehe ich eigentlich ein riesen Potenzial drin. In dieser Haltung müsste man viel mehr politisieren. Folgt man ihm aber dann weiter. Ich habe dann mal geguckt, wie hat er dann nochmal darauf reagiert. Sieht man leider findet dann nicht eine entsprechende Politisierung statt. Denn es wäre ja jetzt die Zeit anzuknüpfen an das, was Gewerkschaften schon länger fordern, nämlich die vier Tage Woche. Es wäre anzuknüpfen an Homeoffice-Pflichten und, und, und. Wären viele Themen zu führen, aber wird nicht gemacht. Wir hören jetzt mal da rein. Er bleibt da auf so einer ganz individualistischen Linie leider.
Deswegen werden einfach Zeitungsartikel über mich geschrieben. Ich bin der Typ, der gesagt hat, von nine to five Arbeiten ist quatschig. Und ich stehe immer noch dazu. Ich finde es immer noch quatschig. Aber irgendwie hat das einen Ausmaß eingenommen. Ich möchte viele DMs bekommen von Leuten, die ganz meiner Meinung sind, aber auch von Leuten, die mich aufs Übelste beleidigen. Sorry, dass ich einfach das ausspreche, was eigentlich jeder denkt. Könnt ihr zwar sagen, ihr geht gerne zur Arbeit. Ich gehe auch gerne zu meiner Arbeit. Aber nichtsdestotrotz bleibt am Ende des Tages, total wenig Zeit für Family and Friends. Und ein Arbeitsweg oder lebenswichtige Lebensmittel kaufen, ist für mich auch keine Lebensqualität. Und es ist jetzt sogar so weit gekommen, dass der Focus Online einen Artikel über mich geschrieben hat. Ich finde es crazy, Leute. Ich finde es mega crazy. Gegensatz zu der Kommentarspalte ist der sogar ganz nett formuliert. Ja, ich wäre natürlich auch gerne viral gegangen mit einem Video, wo ich ein cooles Outfit von mir zeige oder wo ich euch mit auf einen Modeljob nehme oder so. Aber it is what it is. Ich würde mich freuen, wenn ihr mir trotzdem folgen würdet. Ich poste jeden Tag nämlich lustige Reels, Fashion Reels, Vlogs aus meinem Leben. Ich würde mich mega freuen, wenn ihr das auch mitverfolgen wollt. Deswegen folgt mir, Leute, folgt mir, Leute. Keine Sorge, es geht hier nicht nur um 9to5-Arbeiten.
Ja, es müsste aber jetzt mehr um 9to5 gehen.
Das ist deine Exit-Strategie.
Ja, er will jetzt einfach nur sagen, folgt mir, macht mich zum Influencer, damit ich aus 9to5 rauskomme. Aber ihr werdet drinbleiben. Und das ist wieder diese tragische Situation bei den meisten Influencern, die dann ein bisschen mal politisch kurz was aufgreifen. Weil es ist ja auch genau richtig anzusprechen, was ist denn eigentlich mit dem Arbeitsweg? Warum konnte zum Beispiel die Ampel-Regierung nochmal ein Gesetz erlassen, dass Bürgergeldempfänger bis zu drei Stunden am Tag zur Arbeit pendeln können, dass das eine zumutbare Arbeit ist? Da wären also ganz viele politische Themen, über die man sprechen könnte. Aber Julian Kamps leider hier versagt.
Ja, wir hören noch ein bisschen beim Reichtum weiter. Bernie Sanders im Podcast bei Carers Wisher. Ihm ist da was zu Ohren gekommen. Er musste sich sehr wundern.
In Musk und diesen anderen Leuten haben sie eine Philosophie. Und ich habe heute ein bisschen über meine Bemühungen gesprochen. Ich meine, jede Kooperation will eine Verbreitung des Taxis, jede Kooperation hat die Union. Gut, wir verwenden das. Diese Jungs sind anders. In Fakt, ich glaube, ich habe etwas vor dem Tag gelesen. Peter Thiel war tatsächlich mit dem Wort Antichrist, ein religiöser Termin, wenn jemand suggeriert, dass diese Big Tech Jungs nicht unbedeutungsvolle Macht haben, dass du sie kontrollieren willst. Antichrist, wir sind die Königinnen.
Ja, wir haben ja ein bisschen Aufklärung zum Thema gemacht. Und ich denke mir so ein bisschen, ja, Bernie Sanders verklickert mir auch noch mal. Das ist wirklich irre, was wir da hören bei denen. Ja, also da kann man sich, sollte man sich immer wieder drüber wundern, statt es zu bewundern. Lieber Ijoma Mangold, nur weil es deine Diktion ist da an der Uckermark, wo es angeblich ja dann wohl nur Kirchen gibt und Privatwohnhäuser. Ich glaube, das ist hier ein Clip von Mamdani. Er war in der Radio Hour. Mal kurz reinhören.
You know, I specifically...
Ah ja, das ist Mamdani. Er hat Beobachtungen gemacht. Er hat ja sehr viel mit Bürgern gesprochen und so. Sind wir zu diesen ganzen Sport-Events, da hat er einfach draußen mit den Leuten geredet.
You know, I specifically went to two of the neighborhoods that had the largest swings towards Trump. Some of the largest swings were taking place in the hearts of immigrant New York. And I went to Fordham Road in the Bronx, I went to Hillside Avenue in Queens. And I wanted to ask New Yorkers a question and to listen to them. And when you ask a New Yorker an open-ended question, you do not know where it will take them. And what I was struck by is the focus of two things at once. One, the inability to afford life today in this city. And the sense that that which was so difficult to purchase today, be it groceries, be it childcare, be it public transit, be it rent, was far more within reach four years ago. And so a message of a cost of living crisis, a message of cheaper groceries, a message of a more affordable life, very much spoke to the crisis that people were living through. And amidst this, a diminishing faith in the ideal of democracy, the value of democracy, in part because of its inability to deliver on these material concerns, but also because amidst being told that there wasn't enough money for so much of this kind of an agenda, here there were billions of dollars being sent for wars abroad.
So hochinteressant finde ich ja bei Mamdani jetzt, also man kennt ja jetzt so sein Programm, so zwischen den Zeilen oder so Halbsätze. Er hat jetzt die Teuerungszeit vier Jahre genannt als demokratischer Bewerber, also genau die vier beiden Jahre. Also hier werden jetzt auch die Samthandschuhe ausgezogen. Es geht darum, New York Trump-proof zu machen, weil der jetzt gerade regiert. Und Bidens. Wir investieren einfach nur in diese Richtung und kümmern uns nicht so sehr um die Inflation, weil wir hatten ja dieses Dilemma da mal besprochen.
Die Preise, ja, das war ein bisschen...
Dass sie da einfach die Inflation haben laufen lassen. Ja, Brecht. Lanz kriegt ja immer ein gutes Konto von Brecht. Brecht hat hier Ideen.
Was wir eigentlich machen müssen, ist was anderes, um zurück zu meiner Schiffsmetapher zu kommen. Wir müssen bei den ganz großen Bausteinen, wieder bei dem Rentensystem, uns überlegen, wie bauen wir ein System auf, in dem nicht die Arbeitenden, die nicht mehr arbeiten und nicht mehr arbeiten, allein finanzieren müssen.
So, ich erinnere an meine Idee von vorhin. Es ist ja schon alles da. Verteilungsfragen. Die Milliardäre, ja, die müssen irgendwie zu ihren Milliarden kommen, aber die investieren den Scheiß kreuz und quer für 10 Prozent im Jahr. Und das kann man einfach abkraßen. Also das Geld ist da. Und jetzt kann man einfach abrücken von dem Prinzip archimelischer Punkt der Gesellschaft ist Arbeit und sagen, win-win, wir haben trotzdem eine Finanzierung für die Rente, für was auch immer. Und diejenigen, die arbeiten, haben auch noch mehr Netto vom Proton.
Jetzt bin ich aber gespannt.
Das ist die erste grundlegende Frage, die sich keiner stellt. Bei der Steuer müssen wir nicht so sehr nur über die Steuern nachdenken, die wir schon haben oder abgeschafft haben, als darüber nachzudenken, kann man nicht grundsätzlich die Steuern auf Einkommen senken und die Steuern auf Geld ausgeben, erhöhen. Das wäre eine sehr gerechte Steuer, weil die Leute, die sehr wohlhabend sind, deutlich mehr Geld ausgeben als diejenigen, die wenig haben.
Mehrwertsteuer auch?
Nee, nicht die Mehrwertsteuer hoch, weil die trifft vor allem den kleinen Mann, sondern eine Mikrosteuer einführen von 0,5 Prozent auf jegliche Finanztransaktion. Ob du Geld am Automaten ziehst, ob du irgendwo in Geld überweist, ob du dir beim Einkaufen immer 0,5 Prozent, davon wird keiner, der am unteren Rand der Gesellschaft lebt, signifikant ärmer. Aber diejenigen, die Milliarden an den Börsen bewegen oder diejenigen, die sich sehr teure Dinge in großer Zahl kaufen, für die ist das schon, da kommen ordentliche Beträge bei rum. Das sind gigantische Milliardenbeträge, die man da bekäme.
Was hast dagegen? Das ist die Tobin-Steuer, ist ja seit Jahrzehnten im Gespräch.
Grundsätzlich kann man so eine Finanztransaktionsteuer machen. Sie ist, wie du sagst, schon ewig im Gespräch. Das Problem ist nur, ja, man wird immer etwas Geld damit einnehmen, weil wir alle Finanztransaktionen machen. Aber das, wo wirklich diese Summen bei rumkommen, also wo die Quantität viel höher ist, das sind ja Modelle, die nur deshalb so funktionieren, weil es keine Finanztransaktionssteuer dort gibt. Bedeutet also, das Risiko ist ziemlich real, dass wenn diese Finanztransaktionssteuer eingeführt würde, diese Finanztransaktionen an sich nachlassen, folglich auch die Einnahmen schwinden.
Aber die können ja nicht wirklich nachlassen.
Naja, es gibt ja manche Trading-Geschäfte, die auf ein ganz schnelles Kaufen und Verkaufen aus sind, mit sehr niedrigen Gewinnsprüngen, die nur deshalb funktionieren, weil es nicht so eine Steuer gibt. Wenn die jedes Mal an viele darauf, je nachdem, wie man das ausgestaltet, Der ist gleich Null.
Genau, also können die auch wegfallen.
Das könnte wegfallen, nur dann habe ich nicht mehr die Einnahme, mit der ich das Modell finanzieren kann, was Richard David Precht davor schlägt. Also ich kann damit die schnellen Finanztransaktionen, also dieses High Frequency Trading und so weiter, das kann ich damit einhegen. Das ist die eine Sache, die kann ich machen, wenn ich das gerne sein lassen will. Die Sache ist nur, wenn ich damit dämpfe oder abschaffe, dann habe ich die Einnahmen nicht mehr auf der anderen Seite. Deswegen bin ich bei dem Modell skeptisch. Es wundert mich aber jetzt gerade nicht, denn tatsächlich ist das keine neue Idee von Precht, sondern er hat in seinem Buch über das BGE ja genau das immer vorgeschlagen.
Genau, es ist grundsätzlich keine neue Idee. Und das, was du jetzt als Kritik vorgebracht hast, hier muss man jetzt auch in Bilanzen denken und zwar in Jahresbilanzen. Also das eine, hier gibt es ja schöne Texte, Milliarden in Millisekunden und so, dass alle nur diesen ganz kleinen Informationspunkt abwarten und dann finden alle Trading innerhalb von einer halben Sekunde statt und so. Genau, diese Phänomene gäbe es dann nicht mehr, als würde keiner mehr in Asporn.
Aber auch nicht die Einnahmen. Die Einnahmen fallen dann weg. Also wenn ja alle aufhören zu rauchen, hat man keine Tabatschneider mehr.
Diese Einnahmen waren da nie inbegriffen. Also das sage ich jetzt mal.
Also bei seinem Modell schon, also bei dem BGE Modell war das damals so, dass er das damals so hochgerechnet hat und dann dachte ich mir, naja, aber dann fallen ja eher die Einnahmen weg.
Okay, also weiß nicht, wie er das da...
Also ich glaube generell, dass man im Finanzsektor sowieso viel mehr besteuern kann. Und zwar fällt uns das allen sofort ein, warum werden Kapitalerträge nicht genauso besteuert wie mein Einkommen?
Wir hören mal noch ein bisschen weiter. Das ist ja nicht alles nur Finanzmarkt kann auch wegfallen und so weiter.
Das ist ja die Sache. Warum zum Beispiel reden wir, wenn wir von Rente reden, unter allem was in den Sozialstaat finanziert, warum bezahlen wir das nur mit unseren Löhnen? Warum machen wir das nicht auch mit unseren Kapitalerträgen oder um es ganz klar zu sagen, besonders mit den Mieteinnahmen?
Ganz genau. Wir hören mal noch seine kleine Ausarbeitung zum Thema Umverteilung.
Und ich glaube, dass nicht eine einzige Louis Vuitton-Handtasche weniger verkauft wird.
So, jetzt sind wir also nicht beim Superfinanzmarkt Transaktions, wo es einfach nur um eine Modalität geht.
Ja, es ist ja vollkommen klar, ob das jetzt ein Euro kostet oder nicht.
Aber das sind ja, also diese Steuereinnahmen dann, die bleiben. Also die fallen dann wirklich an, wenn man da, wenn sie noch teurer wird.
Die werden ja sowieso von Jahr zu Jahr immer teurer, damit sie immer begehrenswärter werden.
Und dann kauft sie dann im Ausland, richtig?
Ja, gut. Ja, wäre auch sehr schön, sich dafür einzusetzen, dass wir das europaweit einführen, weil die Probleme, die wir haben, die haben viele andere auch.
Das ist ja ein Unsinnargument von Land. Also man geht ja nicht um einen Euro zu sparen ins Ausland.
Also ich kenne auch sehr viele Leute, die in Frankfurt ihre Hermès-Taschen kaufen und das machen die einfach jedes Weihnachten. Und umso teurer die Tasche, umso besser, weil diejenigen, die beschenkt werden, sich umso mehr freuen, weil sie genau wissen, was sie kosten.
Also um einen Euro zu sparen, bemüht sich keiner, ob es irgendwo im Ausland eine Möglichkeit gibt, da billiger dran zu kommen. Das ist Quatsch.
Absolut, europäische Länder auch. Abgesehen davon gehört bei bestimmten teuren Produkten das Einkaufserlebnis durchaus dazu.
So, Standortpolitik. Wo gibt man sein Geld aus, ist gar nicht so unbedeutend, wie diese Superreichen immer sagen. Im Sinne von, ach so, in Frankfurt kosten Mietzahlungen jetzt 0,5 Prozent extra Steuern, dann verkaufe ich alle meine Wohnungen und vermiete nur noch Wohnen in Südkorea, irgendwo in Seoul oder so. Also zieht man sich dann wirklich aus Frankfurt zurück.
Ja, sehr viele Luxusprodukte werden nicht im Internet bestellt.
Mhm.
Also Umverteilung sozusagen.
Das wäre eine ganz elegante Form von Umverteilung.
Muss natürlich einmal tief durchgeatmet werden, also Umverteilung sozusagen.
Das wäre eine ganz elegante Form von Umverteilung, die überhaupt nicht die falschen trifft und keine volkswirtschaftlichen Nachteile beinhaltet. Denn einen letzten Gedanken möchte ich noch loswerden, auch wenn er dich wahrscheinlich ärgert. Aber alle diejenigen, die meinen, man müsste da jetzt noch irgendwie 50 Euro Bürgergeld oder so kürzen, ein Bürgergeldempfänger gibt im Regelfall alles, was er vom Staat kriegt, sofort wieder aus. Und nicht, weil er nicht mit Geld umgeben kann, sondern weil er muss.
Weil er es muss, ja klar.
Das heißt, Bürgergeld zu zahlen ist eine absolute Subvention des Einzelhandels, eine absolute Subvention für allejenigen, die Lebensmittel verkaufen. Ist auch ein Wohngeld zu zahlen, ist eine Subvention derjenigen, die Wohnungen vermieten usw. Das darf man nicht vergessen. Das ganze Geld, was ein Bürgergeldempfänger kriegt, geht in den Wirtschaftskreislauf unmittelbar und direkt wieder zurück.
Ja, Wirtschaftskreislauf.
Ganz richtig. Also da kann ich ja auch überhaupt nicht widersprechen, will ich auch nicht, stelle ich vollkommen zu. Insofern ist diese Transaktionssteuer begrüßenswert. Ich glaube auch, dass man damit was ausrichten kann. Ich glaube nicht, dass man damit ganz Großes finanzieren kann wie in BGE, aber ich bin ja eh da kein Fan, bekannterweise. Das ging mir auch nicht um BGE. Was ich aber sagen will, ist, dass wir ja eigentlich hier in der Situation sind, wo etwas so Moderates vorgeschlagen wird und ja auch schon gleich vom Luxussektor da anfängt, weil dort natürlich dann entsprechend was einzusacken ist, wenn da hohe Preise bezahlt werden. Und dass da Lanz noch so vorsichtig ist und sagt da Umverteilung. Also wenn man dazu nicht bereit ist und die ganze Zeit aber erzählt davon, wie bereit Leute sein sollen, um jetzt mal mit anzupacken und weiß ich nicht was zu tun. Ich kriege das einfach nicht mehr zusammen. Also man kann doch nicht so geizig sein, um es mal ganz klar auf den Punkt zu bringen.
Man kann also mit Geld geht eigentlich einher, dass man ein bisschen undurchdachter durch die Welt geht einfach.
Ja, dass man sagt, es mir egal, kostet das was, weiß ich nicht, ich fahre einfach mal.
Von daher, die psychologischen Konzepte, mit denen man sich kognitiv einigelt und mit möglichst wenig Dissonanz einfach, nee, kann doch nicht sein, ich bin doch von Gottes aus erwählt, mir geht es doch gut und so. Also dieser Neokalvinismus steckt da überall drin und dann erzählt man halt einfach in seinem Podcast, wie man mit Emirates fliegt und so. Und es gibt natürlich andere super Reiche, also Scott Galloway gehört ja auch zu den Leuten, die so mehrere 10 Millionen Dollar haben und so, der ist in der Uni irgendwie jetzt 15 Millionen geschenkt, einfach nur als ihr habt mir den Start in mein tolles Leben ermöglicht, wie auch immer. Und diese, also, sagen wir mal, Reichsein und aufgeklärt sein kann einen genauso wütend machen über Ungleichheit wie arm sein und aufgeklärt sein. Nur da gibt es halt eine Notwendigkeit, sich darüber aufzuklären, während die Reichen manchmal einfach so sich darüber aufklären, also Scott Galloway zum Beispiel.
Du musst Geld zurückverdienen. Lass mich das R-Word benutzen. Redistribution, du musst taxieren. Unsere Zeiten des größten wachsenden Wachsens sind, wenn unsere Kooperations 50, 60, 80% Taxibegriffe bezahlt haben. Und ich gehe zurück zu Daniel Kahneman. Die Unterschied zwischen 10 oder 15 Millionen Dollar pro Jahr macht dich nicht mehr glücklicher. Also wieso auf der Erde könnt ihr nicht über eine bestimmte Zahl von 60, 70% an Individuen mit und ein alternativer Minimumtax von mindestens 30% an Kooperations haben, so dass ihr universaler Kinderangriff habt, so dass ihr Training habt, so dass ihr Pellgräfen habt, so dass ihr Taxincentive habt, um mehr Wohnungsmittel zu kreieren, um die Kosten der Wohnungen zu bringen. Ihr braucht auch, ich gehe auf Basis oder auf Skript hier, ihr braucht einen massiv aggressiven FTC und DOJ, um zu verhindern, dass keine einzelnen Firmen, wie 10, 40% der S&P kontrollieren. Aber all diese sind Common-Sense-Solutions, die andere Regierungen implementiert haben. Und wir implementierten sie von 1945 bis 2010. Aber wir wurden wepennisiert von alten und rischen Leuten, die die gleichen Takten wie jede dritte Weltnation folgen. Und das, wie sie gesagt haben, weißt du was, genug ist einfach nicht fucking genug für mich.
Es ist unglaublich, ich muss immer noch jetzt dran denken, selbst bei 0,5 Prozent ist Lands noch zögerlich bei einer Finanztransaktion.
Es ist einfach absurd, als ob es nicht reicht, dass einem die Liegenschaften halb Norditaliens gehören sollen. Wie viele Quadratkilometer sollen es denn noch werden?
Es ist wirklich erstaunlich, dass man da nicht eine gewisse Großzügigkeit entwickelt und einfach sagt, gut, ich hatte Glück gehabt, jetzt wollen wir aber auch nicht noch weiter auffallen. Das wäre ja nachvollziehbar.
Okay, das war's. Hier sind noch einige Clips.
Das machen wir bald. Wir verweisen auf den Salon nochmal. Wir lesen Zerstörungslust von Carolin Amlinger und Oliver Nachtwey. Wir gehen also wieder in die Soziologie. Der Untertitel lautet Elemente des demokratischen Faschismus. Erschienen bei Suhrkampf. Wir werden also schauen, welcher Faschismusbegriff uns angeboten wird. Was hat das alles mit den Wählern und Followern von Trump, Musk und der AfD zu tun? Wir gehen da tief rein in die Debatte und schließen damit sicherlich auch an, an viele Diskussionen, die wir schon hatten, über die Zukunft der Demokratie oder ob sie überhaupt eine hat. Da knüpfe ich auch insofern dran an, als ich mich ein bisschen mit dem BSW auseinandersetzen möchte. Ich habe zwei Artikel schon herausgefischt, die sagen, die Stimmen müssen neu ausgezählt werden. Der Bundestagswahl, so kann das nicht gehen. Es gibt berechtigte Zweifel, möglicherweise könnte das BSW doch in den Bundestag einrücken. Zumindest könnte es sein, dass da mehrere Stimmen doch verschüttgegangen sind. Es gibt zwei Artikel da aus seriöser Quelle und damit müssen wir uns mal auseinandersetzen. Und auch mit der Frage, was ist da so impliziert eigentlich und warum wird da eigentlich gar nicht so viel drüber geredet. Also, dass man auch so ein Zusammenzucken direkt bemerkt bei vielen, dass man sagt, aber was würde das bedeuten? Genau, aber ist das...
Die Regierungsbildung zurück abzuwickeln ist natürlich...
Ganz genau, das ist selbstredend ein extremer Einschnitt und wir wissen, wie stark die AfD und so weiter ist, aber man kann zugleich auch nicht sagen, naja, aber gut, dann heute ist uns die Demokratie doch nicht so wichtig. Wir müssen also das besprechen. Dann gibt es noch Musik und Dittatur von mir, aber das halte ich mir noch ein bisschen offen.
Ich habe jetzt meine Liste nicht offen. Ich weiß nicht, was ich mir schon zurechtgelegt habe, aber einiges bestimmt.
Das alles kann man hören im Salon der Neuen Zwanziger. Das ist also der Zusatzinhalt hinter der Paywall. Hinter die Paywall kommt man, wenn man schon bei Patreon ist, kann man das darüber tun. Oder wenn man ganz einfach und praktisch bei Apple nicht nochmal eine andere Plattform aufsuchen will, kann man auch bei Apple das abonnieren. Aber wir empfehlen Steady. Dort hat man die schönste Übersicht auch. Auch mit den anderen Folgen hat man da nochmal den einfacheren Zugriff. Und bei Steady sind wir ganz von Anfang an, also von Januar 2020. Bei den Plattformen sonst kann man natürlich auch sehr, sehr viel nachhören. Dort sind auch die Live-Salons. Und wir freuen uns, wenn ihr auf diese Weise den Podcast unterstützt. Das ist ja auch die einzige Möglichkeit, den Podcast zu unterstützen.
So ist es.
Bis dahin.
Bis dann.